[Music]
it's Sunday here day two for the 2023
Champions chess tour finale beautiful
Toronto Canada the lovely CN Tower she
welcomes all she welcomes everyone to
this amazing City north of the Border if
you're in the states a capital of Chess
in Canada in many ways it's day two and
it's coming at you right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end in the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
we see a reaction Magnus mous Magnus
Mouse slipped oh my gosh look at
Jordan's face some have pulled over but
some what is he doing slam that foot to
the floor just kept going any second
Nakamura is the
winner Maxim the Frenchman he wins the
AI cup after six stops along the way
it's time for the greatest proven ground
and online chess to drop that final pin
in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
now I don't think there is a cooler
voice to help open a chess show than
Wood Harris no cooler pictures I think
we've ever had of the world's top
players than that hype video and no
cooler place to be alongside James candy
it is Danny wrench here we are in the
playing Hall in Toronto we're getting
set for day two but C before we focus on
today biggest takeaway you had from day
one yeah hikaro being my guy you know I
just like love hikaro that's my guy
everybody loves hiar right so he lost
yesterday man on his birthday Danny on
my birthday man dude 0 and2 is not how
you want to spend your birthday I think
some players struggle on their birthday
but we're all hoping hikaro can turn it
around although he does he does have two
very tough matchups so all right we're
here in Toronto but as you know we have
a third member with us every single day
she is Kaa and she is ready to take it
away yeah Danny and I have to tell you
my heart is just warm from day one in
the CCT finals the players were so good
to me to the fans they stopped for
interviews even after losses even before
Arma get on drama they would come for an
interview to share their thoughts with
the fans to share their genius Minds
their feelings and I'm hoping for more
of that today the only player that I
didn't get to talk to that I really
wanted to talk to yesterday was taru
Nakamura you mentioned it on his
birthday losing two matches so my
biggest hope today is that we get to
talk toaru Nakamura But first you guys
let's go back to day one in the CCT
finals the Champions chess tour finals
are off to a blistering start with
brilliancies upsets and of course
Armageddon in the first round of the
round robin Magnus Carlson took down
Dennis lzc Ali Rea fuja defeated Notre
Becka dorov and Fabiano kowana scored a
win against Maxim Bash graph which
required Armageddon in the Armageddon
game Fabiano showed incredible attacking
chest with the black pieces winning with
three brilliancies and here we go the
black pawns are just marching two pawns
up still and uh if he can remove White's
remaining pawns on the king side even at
the cost of his material advantage that
guarantees the draw and Maxi V grab
actually resigns wow the most shocking
result of the day came from Wesley so
and birthday boy hakaru Nakamura Wesley
secured an impressive win in the first
game with the black pieces at the end he
had a bishop against taru Rook but also
a passed Pawn that was
Unstoppable he's going to all he's going
for more in this position he's
threatening mate again check mate but
Wesley just gets his King out and
Black's winning CaRu he gambled he
bluffed and the bluff was called
Wesley's porn is simply going to March
down the board oh God there's no me the
bishop slides back and you see a car
resign Wesley so the magic continues in
Toronto in the second game of the match
Wesley had yet another winning position
but agreed to a draw to safely win the
round the excitement continued in round
two with three of the four matches going
to Armageddon in fact in the Armageddon
game between Hikaru and mvl they bid the
exact same time that's Hikaru submitting
his bid and he burst out laughing as
they realized that they submitted the
exact same bid have we ever seen
anything like this in the Chess World NL
ended up winning that game with the
white pieces to win the match Carlson
also won his Armageddon game against
abator of and carolana repeated moves to
draw with black in his Armageddon game
against
fuia West so was the only player to not
require any Armageddon games to win his
matches and as a result he has the sole
lead of the round robin stage going into
day
[Music]
two you know Robert said the magic
continues for so here in Toronto he is
the chess.com Global Champion the
defending and he sits there at top the
standings I I agree with Robert
something about Toronto seems to suit
Wesley so well if it ended right now
Magnus and Wesley would get immediate
buys into the semi-finals and those
middle six players would still be here
Hikaru and Dennis would be going home
how will things look at the end of day
two we're going to we're going to find
that out as we get set for the matchups
but uh yeah you've uh you've got a lot
of people already feeling the nerves KY
Carana Carlson Vash the grao lazic Abdus
saurov and peruja Nakamura match up that
sticks out to you real quick before we
start previewing one by one yeah I mean
it's always Karana Carlson I mean that
one right there of course since the 2018
World Championship 12 draws going to a
rapid game I mean it was crazy there fa
was right with him in the classical but
in the rapid he is having some trouble
but he wants to try to make up for that
today it will be interesting to see what
happens with Carana Carlson of course
but before we start previewing that
we're going to start with the guy that
as we said just seems to love Toronto it
feels magical to Wesley to be here we
know from talking to him that he loves
the hotel he loves the he loves the city
and it is reflected with chess whether
it's on a computer or over the board he
may not have known that it was over the
board if you paid attention to what we
talked about yesterday but it doesn't
seem to make a difference will his hot
streaks continue as we look at Wesley
one of the most interesting things about
him is that throughout the entire tour
this is not just from day one throughout
the entire tour Wesley so played the
most accurate brand of Chess of anyone
in the entire Championship field KY your
thoughts on that that's ridiculous I
mean that's like Point 20 point a little
bit more what is that 21 more 24 more
than than Magnus like you playing better
than Magnus I mean when do you ever sit
that he's like no I'm not playing better
than Magnus I'm just trying to play I
just like playing Jess and having a good
time but he's playing better than Magnus
Danny we doing fair play right cuz he
like we're doing fair play on Wesley
we're doing fair play on car we do fair
play on everyone it doesn't matter
whether you're in a facility with what I
think is the tightest fair play
restrictions in the world players have
even been kind of ruffled by what we've
been doing here doesn't matter what
you're doing to Wesley the dude just
played is an accurate mistake-free brand
of Chess and continuing to talk about
Wesley so right now we're going to throw
it over to Ka because she has
more Wesley so he is uh so kind such a
good guy I did sit down with all the
players before the tournament started
and I got a chance to ask everyone their
thoughts on Wesley
so and uh what's your thoughts on W so
hyper solid player you know a very solid
player
Wesley is solid I think that if he had
more maybe selfconfidence or belief in
himself then he could have even achieved
more than he did but what he achieved in
his career so far has already been quite
enormous and I've always found him one
of the most difficult players to get
even in the advantage against if you can
regain some of the for that he had last
year in the global Championship here in
Toronto then then he has a chance Wesley
is a formidable opponent very early
loses always ready to pound uh when you
make him mistake but otherwise it's also
very difficult to beat him so that's a
great combo when he feels the blood he's
he's always there normally I would say
that the match format is very well
suited to to his style but it feels that
he's been he been considerably less
solid maybe the last year and a half
doesn't really look for win sometimes
but he really hates losing so it's
really difficult to beat him he's a very
good person his character is really good
so um I have a lot of respect
so good to hear just the massive respect
all the other top players have for
Wesley so so solid almost unbeatable so
the question today Danny can anyone beat
Wesley
so it's not going to be easy but NBL
Maxim bash the gro would like to answer
that question with a yes people are
going to beat Wesley so although you see
not as many draws historically as AAR
Nakamura has against Wesley so but KY 30
draws still a lot I'm still I'm getting
bored like heyy man I'm tired of playing
you maybe that's just the strategy from
Wesley play very solid and you get
annoyed and then you just crack under
the pressure somewhere trying to make
something happen you heard the words
from the players words like solid words
like difficult words like doesn't beat
himself we know it but NBL one of the
hottest players on the planet let's
remember he beat Magnus twice to get
here he is streaky by nature though AB
so I think even more than Wesley wanting
to be slowed down if you're the rest of
the field NBL needs to write his ship
right now right of course I mean as
tactical as he is but he is very
predictable too as well as you we can
prepare for his grfs the nidor we know
this as Fabby was able to do that and
the candidates took a whole year to prep
still played night ORF lost with this
crazy P sack we just know what you're
going to play usually so maybe he might
have to make some changes but then again
he's not playing to his style so we'll
see well let's remember he he already
has won one match he beat hikaro
Nakamura in Armageddon so he's not in
the bottom rungs maybe he finds the
right mindset against Wesley so but
either way it's going to be e Epic yeah
my first my first live slip up there
let's bring up what we also have to take
a look forward to the next matchup that
we're going to preview we start by
seeing the next match up the two players
in it Magnus Carlson and Fabiana Carana
are right at the top the odds makers had
Magnus at 50% before the event now at
51% what's funny is as crazy as that
seems KY when we talked to a lot of the
players before the event a lot of them
said that that might have actually been
too low for Magnus yeah that was
actually scary to say I'm like you know
you guys are really good too right you
guys are forgetting how good you guys
actually are but it says a lot to the
testimony of how strong Magnus really is
especially in these rabbit formats and
maybe what you said there maybe it also
says a lot to how much the players fear
him right I mean Magnus Magnus has
dominated his generation and that can
pay off but of course Fabio Carana the
second highest predicted player to make
it to the final and perhaps win it all
we know that Fabby played incredibly
well yesterday but a different type of
of well I guess you could say Magnus was
dominant in his games against the two
youngest players Fai had to go to
Armageddon twice but he won twice with
black KY oh I think he's his confidence
to the roof winning with black like that
too as well now I get you know white
pieces here it's a new day it's fresh
I'm at the top of the leaderboard I'm
feeling good now I just want to make
things a little bit easier for me today
if I can his pedigree also is a a strong
one he won the air things division 2
Division 2 is almost as hard to win in
this tour as division one he's a grand
chest tour winner won the singfield cup
and the rapid and Blitz this year among
many other things but how will he play
today against Magnus who no one will
ever let him forget that he lost a world
championship title in Rapid time
controls he never lost a classical chess
game to Magnus Carlson don't forget that
from 2018 but he lost in Rapid is that
in his mind today honestly it's it's
hard to get out of that of course
because you are playing Magnus you know
World Championship rapid but you just
kind of have to do it you know you just
got to really you know do it hey I have
to get out of my own head here and say
Hey look it's rapid it's a new day it's
only two games so we see what happens
especially if I can get a good start use
my white correctly maybe draw with black
I can win this match it's only two games
here in day two but he played a lot of
games this year in the Champions chess
tour to get here and earlier this week
actually Ka caught up with him and
here's her thoughts on that
interview we are in Toronto for the CCT
finals here with Fabiano Carana on fire
these days and you had a great run in
the CCT 2023 as well how will you
describe your journey through the season
Bobby uh I was really motivated from the
beginning so I played all the events I
think was one of the few players to play
all the qualifying events and it was a
bit up and down for me some
disappointments but overall a lot of
really close ones I think they were all
close I don't know if there were any um
any uh you know wash overs one way or
the other and and some disappointing
ones because the when you lose and it's
really close that also is a bit uh
painful now we are here with the top
eight players in Toronto what makes you
excited about being here now oh I'm
excited for the format it's going to be
really um I think unusual I don't think
I played in a format like this and also
so I think it's going to be a very close
fight yeah it's going to be very
exciting what are the fans in for this
week it's it's going to be exciting
that's all I can say um there there will
be a lot of tough fights and I hope that
I'll be able to um to keep the form that
I've I've been having recently but uh
I'm yeah I'm a bit nervous it's going to
be really tough and also excited can we
get you to describe your playing style I
don't know if I'm the right person to do
that I think probably someone else would
be better I was sort of known at some
point for my
calculation um so I I've uh generally
been good at very good at calculating
like because I I'm I'm sort of a
perfectionist in some way that I I
always want to to calculate to the end
and sometimes after that my um I I Veer
away from my initial assumption about
the position which was more correct so
I've noticed that at times that uh my
instinct is actually better than what I
achieve after I start to calculate
things what would it mean to you if I me
to win the championship to 2023 yeah
actually that that would be amazing I
mean it would really Crown off the year
for me yeah for me this is like a rapid
in Blitz World Championship I know that
we'll we'll have that later this month
as well but uh this has really all the
all the best players or nearly all the
best players in the world including
Magnus and Hikaru and yeah Maxim and Ali
Resa and so it's it's such a highlevel
event that winning it is is such a
Prestige awesome well we hope you have a
great time in Toronto best of luck Fabby
thank
you
I thought it was super self-reflective
the way Fabby broke down his style
talked about historically really relying
on his calculation his perfectionist
mentality see to the end now even
talking about the fact that he wants to
trust his intuition more maybe his
intuition is better than he thought
right away and I'm talking about him as
he's behind me because I've been giving
him that advice for a long time just
kidding Fabby remember how you were
going to make me your second and then
you
didn't never mind okay crickets all
right crickets all right there's Bobby
all right the players are starting to
fill in we still got two more matchups
to preview though so we're going to roll
right into the next one we haven't taken
a look at yet that is fuia versus
Nakamura here we have a couple of guys
who played each other a lot online I
think fans are really used to some epic
epic throwdowns they both had four D1
appearances this year canny your
thoughts on what speaks to you in this
match up this is very nice versatility
and both of course they can always mix
up openings I mean looking to strike
back is he Caro here fza trying to you
know uh get it more of a lead win
another match here so that's going to be
a class of Titans as we always see as we
see in the Blitz and the bullet they
play online now we have the LTB here so
it is going to be one for the year well
I can't wait to see what fu is thinking
after his day one played really well
even though he's only one in one Kaaya
caught up with him just a minute ago
before day two
begins I'm here with Al Rea fuja ready
for day two day one ending I know with
an Armageddon lost but overall how would
you sum up the start to the finals yeah
I think I'm playing decent chess the
second game against Fabiano was a bit
unfortunate but I am happy with my play
but the result should improve of course
and I bet ready and eager to bounce back
then today after losing that last match
yesterday yeah of course I think it's
very important match today Yaro also
lost two so um there is more pressure on
him than me so but it's a everybody is
trying to play their best so and you car
both known as speed demons so what can
we expect from the match with the two of
you yeah I think it will be very
interesting match um always when we play
a lot of people like to watch it so it's
a cool always cool to play Yaro and it's
very exciting always definitely and
finally beautiful outfit today I have to
say what was the plan behind your outfit
today Alo I wanted to mix it up I didn't
care so how it would look I just wanted
to mix it up everything so let's see how
it go looking very good looking very
good looking confident so best of luck
to Ala thank you thank you for joining
us he's looking good today ala Vera back
to you guys
he is looking good today there he is in
the yellow shirt mixing up the style get
him you know it's funny and Magnus said
Magnus even mentioned Oli Resa in his
postgame interview that despite losing
that Armageddon battle to Fabby he felt
like Oli Resa might have played some of
the best chess in day one so we'll see
if he can continue that with this he's
all smiles right now looking good in
that shirt right if you look good you
feel good you feel good you play know
what I'm saying maybe feeling good you
going to play good right got the drip
right drip Master Gucci Reser whatever
you want to call of course the man is f
today and he's going to try to do the
same thing on the board today all right
we got one more match up to get set
before our predictions let's remember
the two youngest players in the field
are battling it out and even though
these faces will continue to get to be
more known by fans for the next many
years to come they want to get the fans
attention today because if they beat
each other that might be their best
chance to maybe stay out of the bottom
rungs who wins this matchup might still
be here in a few days KY absolutely 100%
I mean lazic has a lot to prove here
being the youngest here in fact but ABD
sator of being the youngest World rap
Champion right ever you know so he's
like I mean you know hey I'm going to do
my thing here on paper that is but lavic
is going to try to change that today
there's Dennis lavic as he was waiting
in our player refreshment area we keep
that thing pretty secure and that's
right before they step into the fair
play room here comes Magnus to get his
fair play check on people uh people tend
to love love seeing that and getting
that going but all right we've uh We've
now talked about all four of the
matchups that are getting set to go down
here in day two let's remind everybody
of what the format will be throughout
the entire week here in
Toronto the Champions chestor finals are
here eight players who have earned their
Spot Will face off in an epic battle to
determine who will be this year's
champion of champions up for grabs will
be $500,000 in prizes with first place
taking home $200,000 for the victory the
action opens with an eight player round
robin the top two finishers Advance
directly to the semi-finals while the
bottom two are eliminated the remaining
four players players will do battle in a
double elimination survival bracket
again the top two players Advance while
the bottom two players will be
eliminated the final four Champions are
headed to a single elimination bracket
the winner will be crowned our champion
of
champions boy I'm excited to see this
play out all week it's time for us to
make our predictions for just today
though I'm throwing to you KY first
we're starting with Abdus turov lavic
who you got
gotta go to Abdu satoro there okay world
raing champion I'll agree with you Abdu
satov yeah I'm also going to go with
Nordy I think this could be close but
I'm going with norty all right let's
move oh sorry we're doing so MBL next
I'm sorry about that we're doing Wesley
so max the gra your thoughts Wesley so
MV I pick so in that one okay Wesley so
okay I'll disagree I'll say MBL I still
think his state of mind just something
big will happen there I also think that
is going to is going to find the form
here and we're going to get a very very
packed and close standings as this one
plays out now we're moving on to Carana
Carlson your thoughts on that one uh
slight favorite for Fabby Fabby yeah
Fabby I had a feeling you would say that
and I just want to disagree I'll said
Carlson it's funny because I'm also
going with Fabby even though they got
here in very different ways I think this
is going to be a really close one 2018
World Championship rematch can't wait
all right last one Nakamura and fuja got
to go in Nakamura I mean you know bounce
back from yesterday yeah I don't see him
losing three in a row Nakamura I I tend
to agree I think it's hard to see hikara
losing three in a row so I'm also going
with him all right we've given you our
predictions for the four games that are
about to go down give us your
predictions in chat let us know what you
think how crazy are we or are we right
on before we throw it across the pond I
want to remind everybody that you do
have one last chance I think there are
very very few tickets available still to
join us in the fan Zone Saturday is sold
out completely sold out you missed it
wow you got to risk it to get that
biscuit you missed your chance but there
may be a few tickets left for Friday so
head over to the Champions chess Tour
website and get them to hang out with
the chess bras I'll be there lby will be
there probably some of the players so
make sure you check it out and on that
note it is time for the games to begin
we throw this thing across the pond the
big pond over to Tanya and the boys
bringing you the hits since the 1980s
Tanya take it away hey Donnie James guia
you guys are ready the players are ready
and we're ready in the studio for the
action to begin David a day two about to
get underway give me one name one player
you've got your eyes on today Wesley so
he's at the top and I think he might
stay there Wesley so he finds himself uh
at that pole position currently along
with Fabby and Magnus Wesley today he's
playing against Maxim vasher lra that's
not going to be an easy one for Wesley
no it's never easy when you're playing
Maxim vasher lra but Wesley's in great
form we saw his accuracy and he can
bring it for Wesley so it is so much
about ambition and confidence and the
others can't be too happy with the
performance he had on day one and the
chess is underway we see the handshakes
between the
2018 World Championship players there
Magnus Carlson about to make his first
move against Fabiano Carana currently
ranked world number one and number two
and he starts with Knight to F3 are we
going to see a ready I thought I saw a
knight F3 there I'm pretty sure we saw a
Knight come out as well it looks like
like this is actually a board from
another game this is the board between
Wesley s Max shocking right we see a
grunfeld it must be
Max yeah it's not Fabby here we don't
see his hands moving he's not making the
moves but uh yeah kg start there it
looked like neither player ready to
start the clock need the player in a
rhythm Magnus makes a move and Fabby
took a while to
respond and I'm just wondering we saw
our gang in Toronto make some
predictions do you think Fabby and
Magnus had their uh ears on what was
going on there that was definitely
awkward because you could hear them
being like fbby Magnus they wanted to
lower their volume because they didn't
want the people to be upset with them
and uh Fabby and Magnus they're
professionals they've been going at it
for a long time specifically against one
another the 2018 World Chess
Championship came down to Rapid they
drew all their classical games and then
in the rapid that was where Magnus was
able to separate himself for a second
world championship in a row uh this is
not their board we will switch to the
Magnus and Fa game as soon as we can but
this looks like the Wesley so versus
Mexi V gr board and there we got the
players it was definitely one a knight
F3 uh both these players with backto
back victories on day one and Fabby
almost did topple Magnus in the world
number one rankings back in 2018 he was
just two points behind him what do you
think is Fab's match strategy coming in
today well I think it uh appears at
least that he's trying to be solid with
black he will try and strike with white
Fabby so well well prepared um he's
known for his openings he showed us that
yesterday he's been showing us for years
now already but uh yeah I think as long
as he can survive the openings he will
believe uh Queen B4 is a mouth slip
they're playing over the board of course
it's a an error there he did play Queen
takes PA on C4 of course um but yeah if
Fabby can survive the opening I think
he'll gain in confidence he's a very
brand new Fabby of course his rapid
skills have just grown exponentially
over the last uh few months it's been
amazing to watch uh how Fab's chess has
transformed uh this year and he has been
on fire now back in 2018 it did go into
tie breaks what are the chances of this
match going into an Armageddon well I
think the fans want me to say 100% they
want to see Armageddon it is very fun
but truthfully little separates these
two we've seen that in some of their
head-to-head clashes I think David makes
a good point that it's not just
classical but also rapid and Blitz where
fabbi has improved I would say that
Magnus whoever he plays whenever he
plays the is the favorite but Fabby he's
bringing it yeah and in 2018 Magnus was
so confident to take it into the rapid
playoff he just wanted uh nothing of
that final game but I think now he just
cannot feel that same confidence in
speech chess against Fabby with the way
Fabby has improved and we see that it is
Fabiano Carana who goes into the first
think of the position this reminds me of
Catalan structures It Started From A
Catalan and it's very familiar to both
these players and David you know Magnus
very well he loves the white side of the
Catalin but how do you think he's
feeling about how this game is developed
I think Magnus is feeling confident the
Catalan uh as a mark of respect was his
world championship opening uh in 2021
he's now using it against Fabiano
clearly this is uh home cooking here and
I'm not sure if Magnus has played this
exact move order before he's got so many
kind of one-off ideas Within These
openings something that to test black to
force black to be accurate and he's
essentially saying to Fabiano I know
everything here look at the clock times
he's barely paused Magnus and it's
definitely Fabby who's on his
own it is uh Fabby on the think right
now and I was just about to say that in
these positions it's all about Black
getting this break in the central break
to get more space to get out of that
weakness the weak Pawn on C7 usually
when black achieves this break it feels
like you've neutralized White's
Advantage is that fair to say here it's
funny because I was going to say the
same thing but then I thought this is
Magnus Carlson we're talking about level
position equality those
are defined by who you're playing in
some ways so for five Carana he knows
that he's escaped the opening with a
good position but how quickly Magnus is
playing I think he smells that he can
actually get the upper hand the
evaluation Bar says well Fab's doing
everything perfectly and that is true
but maybe there's going to be a mistake
down the line and some players they'd
like to force their opponent to get into
this territory where it's a playing for
two results Magnus he can't really lose
this game but maybe he can win yeah this
feels like an optical illusion as
commentators because if you just showed
me the board I would say dead level no
chance White's going to be better
suddenly I look across and I see the
cameras I know it's Magnus Carlson I see
his clock time he's barely uh spent any
time at all and I'm starting to think
okay white must have an advantage
somewhere but why it must simply be
because Black's porns on the queen side
are slightly vulnerable um I mean other
than that I'm struggling to see any real
imbalances any reason for Fabiano to
sweat here must be very concrete but
surely with a couple of accurate moves
he has plenty of time he will find uh a
way to equalize this game and uh if
white is unable to create any pressure
in the next two or three moves this
one's going to fizzle out very very
quickly feels like Magnus not taking too
much risk here maybe hinting that he'd
be okay with a solid draw and uh
hopefully guiding it towards Armageddon
where he would Bank himself as a
favorite I'm already already wondering
what Fabby is so deep in the think tank
about because my first instinct goes my
Pawn on B5 is under attack I should take
the pawn that's attacking me but I'm
getting the feeling that it's going to
be about a fight for some of these open
files let's say black does take that
pawn on A4 white takes back with the
Knight you'd be well advised to move
your Bishop because you don't want to
give up that piece for a knight so let's
say you go back to A7 keeping on this
diagonal maybe white will just bring a
rook to C1 rather than D1 and I don't
know this kind of position where the A6
Pawn feels a little bit tender as the A1
Rook stares there and that's why Fabby
instead of capturing on A4 he brings his
KN back I think that's the wiser play
yeah very clever move here he's putting
some pressure on this KN and uh if he
trades off this night then the B5 Pawn
feels much safer also hinting that he
might NAB the bishop pair uh if given
the opportunity I really don't see where
White's Advantage lies but Magnus
continues to Blitz continues to play at
break neck speed trading off I don't
understand I'm mystified I've got to say
black looks totally solid no matter
which way you take back in the center
with your knight Bishop where can the
problems lie I don't see anything at all
here for Magnus Carlson nothing it looks
really solid for black so maybe Magnus
is saying I respect my opponent so much
that I'm going to play an opening
without risk Fabiano is handling this
perfectly thus far yeah it looks like
maybe after P takes porn Magnus will try
and leap his KN into the center uh in
the Catalan structure a D3 square is a
fantastic post for a night but at this
level this should be relatively safe
Fabiano opening success for him yeah
definitely surprising uh how easily
Fabby with the black pieces has managed
to neutralized I was expecting more
ambitious play from Magnus uh starting
it's it's a mini match of just two games
they've got one wi and then if Fabby
does secure the draw in this one he
might be the one getting ambitious in a
second game with the white pieces well
one player who needs to get ambushes
right now is Hikaru Nakamura there were
no birthday gifts for the five-time US
champion speed chess Beast Hikaru starts
his day he's on 0 to two he's playing
against alira later on he plays against
Magnus Carlson and this is such a
critical game for Hikaru if if things
were to not go his way that means a
third loss in a row that would really
jeopardize his chances to actually go
through to the
semi-finals what are you expecting how
does Hikaru make the switch up from the
start that he had on day one Well it
can't really get worse from day one
because he lost both of his matches he
made a mistake against Maxim Vash in a
position where the computer said he was
even I think hikaro knew that he was
playing quite well and the problem for
Hikaru they don't stop just because day
one ended you're playing Ali of fuza we
saw the Ferocious form that he was in on
the first day where he was sacrificing
pieces against Fabio Carana the match
ultimately was a win for Fabiano it was
really an epic comeback from him but fua
showed that he's ready to fight stylish
alira with some stylish player on day
one and he did say earlier today that
he's looking to mix it up against Hikaru
Hikaru is spe chess Beast currently
wounded but a wounded Beast can be even
more dangerous what do we make of the
opening outcome that that we have right
now uh David on the board has Ali Resa
managed to mix it up well it feels like
actually Hikaru just wants a solid
stable start here he just wants to play
himself into form perhaps uh alaza looks
solid as black white hasn't done too
much uh kind of anything special at
least in the opening stages white will
shortly Castle his King it looks
symmetrical other than the fact that
white has a set of double pawns on the
defile uh that gives more central
control however and gives a semiopen
file on the C file for the white Rook um
so I've got to admit I slightly prefer
White's chances um black is solid but a
bit passive right now and Nakamura does
have the luxury of time he plays a quiet
move like Pawn to A3 just on this last
turn he's basically saying to fua you
break out I'm going to slowly slowly
improve my pieces maybe creep forward
later on what are you doing in the
meantime well one way to break out for
Ali R if he really is in for an absolute
brawl is pushing the pawn in front of
his King two squares now considering his
last move was sliding his Bishop back I
don't think he'll go for the this choice
but there are positions where even
though we're told don't push Pawns in
front of your king you can get away with
it because white doesn't have the
makings of an attack so I do think that
hikaro has opted for a solid setup
because of his first day of action I'm
with you David I like his position with
this semi-open C file he's got those
Pawns in the center that mass is just
controlling so many key squares but for
ala he's also done nothing wrong so he
should feel quite confident himself yeah
I think Nakamura probably watched that
game against Karana yesterday where fuja
Unleashed fire on the board and he's
saying okay I want none of that fu is
not going to attack me in this one it's
just going to be a solid slow positional
fight and okay he's found another way
fuja uh of dealing with his slightly
cramped position he's trying to trade
off pieces often good classical chess
wisdom if you're lacking space if you're
lacking squares trade off and uh your
remaining pieces will feel much Freer
more scope for them and Knight to H5 not
a great post for that night but the dart
squar Bishops now are about to depart
and uh maybe a sigh of relief there for
black back but in the meantime just
looking very very level and uh
historically at least I think that would
favor uh Nakamura in terms of this Clash
of styles and it's funny because
normally I'm so eager to jump into the
X's nose of the position it's just very
solid there's really not too much to
speak of both players have played
sensible moves white will Castle
kingside eventually but with the bishop
staring at each other you need to make a
decision for Hikaru uh he can just trade
them but the way he's side eyeing the
position I can't tell if that's a carace
number six number 16 where he smells
that he has a tactic or if he's just
like I really got a whole lot of nothing
right now well the bishop trade is on
the board and the only way to avoid it
is to fall back with the bishop in G3
giving Ali Rizza the option to cause the
imbalance by trading it off for the
Knight and Hikaru is about to take a
decision on it will he be more ambitious
with the bishop Retreat or tradeoff a
pair uh you can you you you always talk
about trading on your terms once the
bishop falls back to G3 it can even find
itself on that Central E5 square and I
have a feeling the more time Hikaru
takes he's going to decide to retreat
the bishop but he goes for the trade
just as I say he takes the decision this
is looking more and more level and while
this one continues let's head over to
Maxim Vash gra playing against wesy so
wesy so with such a fantastic
performance on day one the only player
who needed no Armageddon for the two
victories and some decisions to be made
on the board right now Dynamic play that
last move which is being highlighted
asks questions Wesley needs to take a
decision on the center I think it's big
tactics that play here where Wesley
David I think Wesley's worse right now
Maxim has a dream come true out of the
grunfeld I'd be nervous if I Wesley yeah
first of all look at the clock times
Wesley has half the time of his opponent
mvl just blitzing he's gone back to
basics employing again his childhood
favorite the grunfeld defenses black
often a good strategy he's been
switching it up uh throwing new openings
out there throughout the last 12 months
24 months and he's uh somehow surprised
Wesley so early on here still looks very
tense a lot of pieces on the board white
has some control over the center but
yeah black pieces are all mobilized and
look how quickly mvl is playing he
sacrifices The Exchange oh we have to
dive in right now because Maxim's Rook
is under threat from that Bishop on G5
and he says I don't care take the rook
and that's probably what Wesley kind of
has to do otherwise he just lost the
pawn for no reason and The Rook takes
back and yeah you can take this Pawn on
D4 but after Knight takes D4 and we see
a trade of minor pieces trades are
supposed to be good for the side with
extra material but the problem for white
is black is Super Active there's a rook
staring through your own Bishops towards
the enemy bishop and queen there's a
queen on C7 that can line up with a
bishop on the diagonal maybe cause some
problems in front of the white king and
let's not forget a pawn count on the
queen side shows three for black and
only one for white that c Pawn can just
Rumble up the board C4 right in this
kind of position could be an option yeah
looks beautiful for black I've got to
say minimal material investment in
return you get so many uh advantages
long term and this is happening we're
rattling down this variation I love it
from Maxim I don't know if he's in
preparation or whether this is just
instinctive using all of those years of
experience in the grinfeld defense but
he's got the upper hand Wesley on the
back foot already as white he just
understands these positions so well
Maxim Vella gra the grinfield that we're
seeing on the board and he wasn't even
on the board when he took this immediate
decision he sits down and immediately
takes the pawn giving up the Rook it
just shows how much of an understanding
he has of this he loves the exchange
sacrifices whether it's the Rook takes
C3 Rook takes Knight in a night off or
in this case a giving up and exchange
for initiative this just feels like The
Clash of styles between two of the best
players on the planet but Maxim vagra
has managed to get the kind of position
that suits his style while Wesley
doesn't get the kind of positions that
he enjoys and that clock that you
pointed out that's going to be a major
major factor in this one whether it's
preparation or inspiration he's taking
him down this tactical Matrix where
Wesley doesn't always feel the most
comfortable or confident and Wesley did
just capture on D4 we will see some more
material come off but what's the
essential point of this position is
Black's King is very safe so that means
he could focus on the queen side where
he has three pawns just one for white
and that is going to tell the tale of
this position the eval bar slightly
favoring black I think from a practical
point of you how easy it is to play We
also should favor black as well look at
the speed with which Maxim is just
blitzing out his moves I me he's loving
those Bishops on the board The Rook
lined up he's got that extra Pawn this
is Maxim vasher lra's bread and butter
these kind of positions Wesley I think
he's in trouble and he knows it yeah
first I have to say Robert the propit
you've predicted this whole variation
and uh secondly I think yeah black just
has a dream position uh you still have
to play energetically you don't want to
allow too many more exchanges for
example if the lights score Bishops
disappear if Queens disappear suddenly
White's Rooks might gain in power but uh
for now with this exact material
imbalance um it feels like it does favor
black as long as you're quick and start
throwing pawns forward as quickly as
possible on the queen side uh I think
Max doing a good professional thing as
well after that t tactical mess that
tactical melee he's pausing he's
deciding Upon A CL of action and then
he'll change the pace again speed up yet
again and put pressure on Wesley so a
nice post for his Bishop here and yeah
massive pressure on white Wesley has to
be so accurate just to survive these
next few moves actually those pawns are
rolling the only bit of good news I
would say for Wesley is is that he has
Pawns of his own and as soon as I'm
getting these words out he plays Pawn to
F4 so black has three onone on the queen
side of the board our left- hand side
white has four on three on the king side
and you typically want to push the pawns
where you have that advantage and if
that pawn gets up to F5 and maybe even
all the way up to F6 we could see the
start of a checkmating net with the
queen running up to H6 and that could be
very dangerous so Wesley he understands
that he can't just sit and do nothing he
needs to act fast active defense really
uh really instructive stuff from Wesley
this time and actually yeah F5 I think
Maxi might have underestimated this it
did look like oneway traffic black about
to play the move C4 but pushing the pawn
to C4 would allow a Counterattack white
will not passively react passively
Retreat he'll go forward and go for the
black king so far from oneway traffic
and wow Maxi Vash graph again playing so
quickly so instinctively just plays King
to h8 into the corner mysterious stuff
he's allowing the attack to continue but
maybe he's recognizing that after f with
his King tucked in the corner he can
actually capture and the G2 Pawn is
something that he can Target place that
Bishop in the center throw your Rook on
over the G8 white is not checkmating in
fact white is the one who might get
checkmated if you're not careful this is
some crazy tactical Affairs here on the
board and Wesley I think he did another
very smart thing instead of throwing
that pawn up too soon he needs to time
it correctly he just sides Queen out of
the rook's line of sight he's covering
that C4 Square another time if White had
a free turn maybe bishop C4 let's trade
off those squ Bishops and then I think
we start to see an advantage for White
and the Queen on C2 is really nicely
placed because even now if black was to
go C4 you don't need to think about your
Bishop you can go with the idea that you
pointed out earlier just keep pushing
your F Pawn now uh you stepped out of
the pin and uh black still in the pin so
D3 Bishop will not be hanging really
nice play by both players but again
looking at the clock I think it's
pressure on Wesley in this one yeah
pressure on Wesley but the last few
moves he has been kind of fighting that
swing in momentum we thought it was
heading in Black's favor but the top
players in the world they always find
ways uh to kind of stem the flow and uh
yeah I love these last two moves Wesley
so playing really actively it feels like
again he's been woken up the opening
didn't go White's uh favor but he's
finally finding uh his rhythm and that's
when Maxim is spending the time so
Wesley is doing the professional thing
thinking on Maxim's clock and I think we
will see this time start to even out
unless Max says I need to make a
concerted effort to punish Wesley with
that 17th piece the clock but for now it
does seem like Wesley has found his
footing the position is double-edged
chances for both sides yeah feels like
this is one of the most exciting games
of the round so far uh very different
type of game to the maneuvering battle
the kg uh kind of standoff we saw
earlier between Nakamura and fua this
one is about to uh really heat up and
queen to E7 Queen slide feels really
slow suddenly from fashi lrav feels a
bit indecisive this one and all those
plans pushing pawns forward exchanging
off the light squ
Bishops suddenly maybe I'm starting to
favor white the evaluation bar certainly
shooting up in Wesley's favor and again
quick reply but if Maxim is also
starting to favor Wesley's position he
might be doing the defensive thing he's
saying you know what that even if these
bishops get traded I down a rook for a
bishop and pawn that's a one-point
Advantage for the white side and if
that's the case then I can actually get
a little bit of a fortress my Bishop on
D4 will blunt that defile nothing's
going on there the C5 pawn stops an open
file what do Rooks need open lines and
unless white is eventually going to push
that F Pawn the lines will remain closed
so perhaps Max says I can actually hold
this if I more or less do nothing well
that last move looks like Maxim isn't
doing much but keeping the pressure on
the clock and for more on this game
we're going to go straight to Toronto
we've got Danny with us Danny do you
think Wesley is in trouble right
now I definitely think Wesley's in
trouble and you know we were talking
about the game outside on the couch with
everyone weighing in and we obviously go
back to the point a lot about how mbl's
repertoire is so consistent almost
stubborn everyone knows he's playing the
night over the grunfeld but we also
observed that Wesley can also be a
pretty consistent creature of habit and
maybe against NBL those styles are not
going well I mean the most reflective
factor of the fact that Wesley is
obviously in trouble is actually not on
the board but on the clock Maxim is
playing instantly Wesley's position is
only getting worse I think we're going
to see the shy Frenchman turn it around
here big moment and uh when we were
having our chat earlier with Wesley I
remember you mentioned that for Wesley
it's so much to do with how confident
he's feeling now he's had a fantastic
start but things looking shaky here what
about Maxim did you catch up with him
yesterday how's he feeling about his
form after day
one what's funny is maxim of all the
players I feel like remains in the best
of spirits he's still teasing with Anish
giri on Twitter as far as where where
that autograph photo is being hidden
around I can't wait for people to see
the story of how he got that that's
coming that's coming later with some
content we did but no Maxim was in good
spirits obviously he lost one match in
Armageddon but won another and didn't
seem to phase him and so with Wesley
going right into the lion's den here in
the grunfeld I'm I'm I'm surprised um
but before we move on I wanted to say
that the reason I had to jump in right
now is because Robert thought I was
going to let it slide that he referenced
whether it was number six or number 16
hiar Nakamura faces first of all Robert
you got to stay in your lane bro
secondly it was actually number four cuz
what you misunderstood is it was the six
facial expression but when the wrist is
there that's actually number four which
is a sign of hikaru's confidence he's
very confident against fuja I don't know
why but he is but Hikaru also I think
Super confident and Robert don't don't
let that happen again please try to
involve you even when we are far apart
so that's a lesson to me I won't try to
speak to you uh when we're in very
different countries and continents so
I'll learn my lesson don't turn this
relationship negative right now you this
thing works long distance I'm just I'm
just needed to call you out a little
that's I I I was sitting there watching
and you're referencing number six and 16
and I about choked on my food I'm like
no no no I got to hop on
there thanks dny for that update tiny
Robin get a room guys I mean we got to
get back to the chest right now and look
at what we do have on the board the F
Pawn has moved forward the F6 square is
under control so at least that's not
happening anymore the one thing that
worries me for Wesley right now is that
Maxim can actually start getting
ambitious on the Queens side with his
own pawns can you think about advancing
that B Pawn one step ahead and creating
passes that can cause trouble to White
yeah feels a bit inconsistent what
Wesley has been doing uh he's been
trying to undermine the black queen side
something we call the minority attack
when one Pawn uh kind of attacks a
larger number of Pawns to create some
weaknesses suddenly he switched up and
gone for the black king but this looks
like a shot in the dark this is really
not being uh this is not a realistic
attack for white you have no pieces
simply and I liked your idea Tanya I
liked pushing the pawns forward why not
that's where your advantage lies push on
the side you're stronger but instead he
plays a quiet move Rook to D7 he's just
covering the king side covering the
queen side Maxim I think is trying to
hustle on the clock Danny mentioned it
uh maybe the biggest problem isn't the
position itself it's just that White's
position uh yeah not so instinctive to
play and no time two and a half minutes
only yeah W Maxim B gra still about four
minutes on the clock and drops a little
piece you think those are nerves what's
going on now he knows that he's up on
the clock the position everything to
play for and and the move that he just
made right Rook stepping up it's
actually quite a nice one David because
there were these ideas of trading on the
G file opening up The Rook the queen
could have lined up from the B3 Square
create pressure on the pawns so playing
prophylactic and also B5 always in the
air I would pick black any day uh of the
week in this one oh Maxim is definitely
in the driver's seat and the bishop on
D4 dominates this board because the dark
Square bishop and White's pawns are now
in light squares there's no competition
over there and on the queen side there
may not be competition for Black's pawns
that are about to advance all right we
going to keep an eye out on this one but
it looks like Wesley is in trouble on
the board and the clock uh and we will
shift our Focus to Hikaru Nakamura the
other player who has been in big trouble
so far in the finals against alira fuja
and once again alira with double drook
on the F line this to me is very
reminisent of his game against Fabiano
Carana where there was this kingside
attack that happened potential
sacrifices on F3 is Hikaru feeling the
heat right now with white definitely
feels that way uh the momentum of this
game it looks really solid for Nakamura
maybe he had a small Advantage he had a
nice Pawn structure but things have been
turning black has been improving every
move look at this fuja suddenly
centralizing his Queen maybe Shifting
the queen over to help out the black
Rooks white Knights are the final
bastions of Defense here just holding
the position together but Nakamura he is
certainly on the defensive look how
passive White's major pieces are the
heavy pieces White's Queen White's Rooks
not doing any work at all so I think
black is slightly better it's nothing
kind of tangible yet but it could
certainly become that way it would
probably be almost winning for black if
his Knights were better his Knights
right now are passive but they are great
defensive pieces covering the central
pawns but if one of those Knights could
hop into the D4 square a rook sacrifice
for that Knight on F3 would be imminent
so that's the thing that is allowing
hikaro to stay afloat right now he's
very passive himself but he is trying to
cover all his bases on the king side
yeah what do you play though how do you
I mean how do you improve your pieces
White's Knights are totally stuck
White's Rooks I mentioned a bit uh yeah
I mean struggling for air right now
Nakamura he does have a small advantage
on the clock I've seen him so many times
online playing these Blitz Games he kind
of keeps the status quo stabilized
stabilize stabilized and only strike
later but he's got to kind of survive
the storm first of all absolutely David
and and your question very valid how
does Hikaru create air for himself in
this position and I'm I want to bring up
a move here you know you're looking for
Pawn breaks you want more space is D4
ever on the radar for white in these
positions to try to get that space to
try to get some activity because one
thing about Hikaru he hates being
passive in these kind of positions and
just letting Ali RZA do whatever he
wants D4 is that something that he can
think about I want that to happen I feel
like if you play D4 I'm sacrificing my
Rook on F3 because I was just saying my
Knights need to become more active now I
take on D4 and if you take back on D4
with your queen in comes my knight to E5
and I'm about to go to forkville on F3
hitting your queen your king and your
Rook all at once so this type of
position it can open up yes for hicar
pieces but maybe even more so for
alzas Wow tactics Galore and uh I mean
D4 is so natural it's so desirable as
you say Tanya but if it doesn't quite
work concretely in this position you're
a bit stuck and Black's Knight does have
other ways around Robert mentioned the
D4 Square takes two jumps with one
Knight then you're in uh you're into D4
after perhaps sacrificing first on F3 uh
so there are plans available to fuia and
suddenly the clocks have balanced out uh
it's pretty much level now on time and
wow black definitely in the driver seat
Nakamura just unable to break this trend
of the tournament so far and we've seen
ala when he gets his kind of positions
when he gets the attack going he's just
so good with that in converting these
positions it's far from over but passive
passive play here for Hikaru really no
way to break through he does line up The
Rook so kind of eyeing that break that
we were looking at earlier D4 in the air
now uh and also let's remind everyone in
the round robin stage after this two
players will be eliminated Hikaru
Nakamura is yet to score a victory he's
yet to go on the leaderboard and he
plays Magnus Carlson next it's really
critical for him to try and get this one
uh in bag and here come the pawns if
he's going to try to prevent Black's
attack I don't know how because all of
pieces are ready now he pushed another
Pawn that frees the C6 square up for his
Knight and the big question is now that
D4 is unavailable from the white side
will he have to capture a pawn in the
center and that does allow some more
black pieces to flow so I'm looking at
this game and the overall standings and
I think that ala must be the happier of
the two he did struggle against Fabiano
in that Armageddon game but it's a new
day and I think it's a new Ala yeah Alla
so aggressive pushing pawns I love it
Robert these three pawns for black you
could see a fourth point por joining the
uh joining the fight Black's Knights
about to come forward as well uh
Nakamura contorting he's really finding
some odd moves to say in this game
Knight to H2 looks like an odd square
and now if I were allara I would not
hesitate I think that maneuver you
mentioned bring the Knight into the
center beautiful Outpost and uh big
Advantage he plays that move he's just
in the flow feels like Adera is really
hitting top form right now and Nakamura
such critical match he needs to somehow
pull that break and survive this game
all this is a big one and now both
players under two minutes uh I think for
Hikaru especially alir is a one-1 match
if he goes to 0 to3 Hikaru is staring at
elimination from the round robin stage
which would be quite disastrous he jumps
forward with the Knights so black does
have the opportunity to do the same uh
alira strong Position will he be able to
convert this one with the clock
situation that's the big thing is both
players are approaching severe time
trouble there is increment the players
get 3 seconds added every move that they
make so that is the good thing for them
they won't lose on time but when you get
down to those waning seconds that's when
the likelihood of a mistake does go up
and here I think that the likel of
mistake it's uh going up for both sides
because now that Knight has jumped into
G4 it's putting some pressure on the
black center it's also protecting that
weak spot on F2 so that Knight is doing
a whole lot it can continue rerouting
it's getting messy and the third thing
that you just pointed out I think that's
a really important point that he can
reroute and go to F5 and actually
challenge that uh very strong night that
Ali Resa has just dropped on D4
meanwhile we do have our first result as
the two youngsters nck and uh Dennis
lawick and their game one in a draw but
this is where the action is at and it's
really heating up yeah rotating those
Knights Nakamura he's so good at that uh
at that uh kind of maneuver phase of the
game and right now he's suddenly got a
30 second time advantage and whoa I just
saw an evaluation bar switch uh in the
game between Wesley so and vasra some
crazy tactics over there which we might
jump to but this one so tense Nakamura
he's traded off a set of Pawns with
white but Black's Knight on defa so
dominant by far the MVP the most
valuable piece right now and uh okay at
least he's trying to trade it off
Nakamura he's fighting hard it's not a
knight it's a stallion and unfortunately
for hikaro he wants to trade it off but
he also doesn't because if you take it
then black gets a pass Pawn cemented in
the center so look at hikaro trying to
undermine the defense of that night both
players are playing well I'll ra it down
under 50 seconds though and Hikaru very
resourceful he does keep the tenacious
defense going but we did see a big slip
on the eval bar in Wesley versus Maxim
Vash lra and we're going to take a quick
look and I think we're also getting a
result
in wow they just finished and wesle so
goes down Maxim vagra sacrifices The
Exchange and gets the job done with the
black pieces taking the lead in his mini
match against the tournament leader wow
and we will recap that one later because
there was some stunning tactics towards
the end but all eyes on this clash
between Nakamura and fua now both sides
down low on the clock just under 30
seconds for fuja just over a minute for
NAA and uh okay a bunch of knights that
stallion has gone Robert it is and now
it's that Knight on F5 that white had is
replaced by a pawn opening up that Rook
that is sitting next to the White Queen
so all of a sudden Black's pawns look a
bit fragile they're all split apart a
lot of isolated ones this really is
becoming a tense battle with chance for
both sides and you can start targeting
those pawns already by doubling up on
the E file The Rook on B2 suddenly
really nicely placed it was defending
that F2 pawn and now it can start
attacking uh uh Black's E5 Pawn with the
idea of going ahead but he chooses the
Queen instead lines up Queen E5 is a
threat
defended the eval eval evil bar either
way it is planted in the middle but to
me it looks like momentum on white side
suddenly Tanya you highlighted a couple
of weak porns three isolated pawns for
black such easy play for Nakamura Queen
in to the heart of Black's position
there nice uh kind of finesse added to
that move just with the gesture there
and wow Fu's clock I don't fancy his
chances of holding this maybe it was
less of finesse and more invitation
because it hovered on that C4 square and
Al says don't mind if I do I'm going to
push my Pawn up there that Rook on F4
that's defending that pawn laterally
that's Behind Enemy Lines and now that
Queen is behind Black's lines here both
sides have different ideas and I think
that white Rook that's on B2 that was
previously defensive it's going up he
does it he's up a pawn he's up a porn
but look at those white pieces the White
Queen the white Rook on the seventh rank
so many targets Black's King not
entirely safe okay there's a hit on
White's Rook at the bottom of the board
right now Black's Queen really agile
right now showing off all the angles but
surely that Rook just moves and also a
really nice Square because you defend
the C7 Square from White's Queen
doubling up on the seventh rank oh and
he reaches for the rook and moves it to
F1 yeah that that that was a hesi he
went to C1 and over to F1 and here we
see look at that Rook that black Rook is
defending the Czech M square and it's
putting pressure towards the white king
watch out for some night sacrifices from
Ali RZA because he's trying to exploit
the fact that the white king may be in
some grave danger why is Hikaru
hesitating so much on every move are you
seeing the indecision there and there it
is there's that Knight sacrifice it
couldn't be captured and hikaro he
attacks the black queen the queen goes
all the way back to the corner keeping
an eye at the square in front of the
white king the white it's blocked yeah
blocks it out again dominance on the
seventh Rank and blunder from fuia as he
allows okay I was going to say a queen
check but the white Rook comes in
threatening to eliminate the Black
Knight the Black Knight once it's taken
this will end in Checkmate wow a check
and now the Knight is going to be
captured this going to be a mate on the
seventh rank Hikaru Nakamura escapes oh
he turned it on just at the right moment
the black queen sacrifices herself she
drops off the board but white has a
decisive Advantage now Queen a knight
will beat two Rooks wow and that Knight
is going to jump to H5 a threatening
mate as well on G7 Hikaru Nakamura with
a big turnaround about to take the lead
in his
match what a tactical flurry that was
Nakamura really upping the pace turning
on the style and yeah this is a decisive
material advantage you're also Landing
potentially a checkmating attack and we
see a handshake that is resigns by alza
Hikaru Nakamura relieved after his first
win he takes the lead in his match
against Ali Rea and he needed this win
to stay in the race Ali RZA to bounce
back has to win the second game on
demand he starts with the white Beast
say Hikaru there walking off but then
takes a pause let's take a look at the
remaining game and Desperation probably
just brought out the best in aaru
Nakamura and these two players they've
been in pretty locked battle for a long
time now very few pieces remain on this
board uh there's a bishop for black you
can see it very close to Fabiano there
white has a knight but they've been
making little progress though Magnus
remains a pawn ahead no idea how he got
that pawn but Magnus is doing Magnus
things he's going to play this out till
uh the end of time yeah this makes me
feel all warm and fuzzy inside makes me
glow with pride that Magnus Carlson is
trying to grind like a Grandmaster
trying to squeeze water from a stone and
win this end game which should of course
be a draw because white doesn't have uh
too much ammunition left but a porn is a
porn and you can tickle you can probe
away hope for a blunder Knights are
tricky as we know but black essentially
should be fine with any Rook exchange
and uh it's hard to imagine white
winning this against solid defense but
he's trying he's trying Magnus Carson
the only thing you need to avoid as
black here is the tradeoff of both the
pieces the rook and KN if it's a King
Pawn ending then you'll be lost but
that's not going to happen as long as
one piece stays on the board you're
doing good but the opening we had it was
hard to imagine Magnus actually getting
an extra Pawn to start with to even
start dreaming about creating chances
well I think Magnus dreamed of exactly
this situation where with absolute best
play Fabiano would hold the draw you you
tip your proverbial cap you say you're
the second best player in the world
right now and for Fabby yeah he's down a
pawn but he's holding everything
together there very few ideas for white
and Fabby he's you know he's going to
hold this second best player in the
world but Robert that's quite debatable
the year that fabi's had if he stick to
23 he could be the best player in the
year just this year what a performance
he's had yeah what a performance and uh
it's really instructive how he's holding
this position um Fab's body language
looks very stoic right now he's just
keeping pieces active look at that black
Rook it's just annoying white it's just
a nuisance piece looking at the second
rank looking at White's fwnn giving any
checks any time the white king pokes its
head out Black's Bishop po kind of
poised perfectly as well blocking pawns
attacking pawns uh yeah Fabiano this is
one to learn from this game for both
sides and there is a 50 move rule in
chess if no pawns are moved no pieces
are captured and the game ends as a draw
so the Arbiters they're going to have
their jobs laid out for them on site and
it looks like well that King has a job
now the white King instead of passively
sitting protecting pawns it's out in the
open that could scare Fabby we'll see if
he's able to continue holding Magnus off
yeah Robert you mentioned the 50 move
rule the last time there was a pawn push
or a capture was move 49 so uh Magnus
has to make progress by move 99 look at
the move counter on the top left hand of
your screens we're now at move 83 he has
to it's reset push a PA before we get to
99 it's reset 50 more moves before that
becomes relevant again and the F Pawn
pushing forward it does uh cause Fabiano
some concern maybe he's going for the H
Pawn and it can you actually protect the
H Pawn now it looks like Magnus moved
his rook and the H Pawn is going down
and with the H Pawn falling maybe white
will push the pawn but black can
sacrifice his Bishop for the pawn just
for everyone out there you may be new to
chess it is a theoretical draw rook and
Knight versus Rook that is a well-known
draw especially for players of these
caliber and that Bishop on H4 really
nicely placed there it's taking away so
many key squares from White's Knight to
jump into to create any mating net
around Black's King and Fabby playing
really confidently he's playing fast
he's making All the Right Moves and that
is a forc rook trade and with that a
check comes in is he going to just trade
everything and Bishop takes Knight Rook
takes Rook King takes Rook well Bishop
takes Knight Rook takes Knight is
probably what caused fbby some concern
but it was going to be a draw regardless
and now we see it a King Pawn ending but
black gets the opposition this is going
to be played out and Magnus there he
size he's not happy but I think it was
just impossible to get anything more in
this position it's a draw this one ends
in a tie just like every classical game
did between these two in the 2018 World
Championship and I think Fabby is a
happy man well he played great defense I
mean he did not break there were moments
there where things could have gone wrong
for him but the fobby we've seen in 2023
is a man who is not very mistak prone
very few errors throughout the year and
the conference that you talked about we'
saw it on full display in that game and
Robert you and I were having this
discussion before the start of the
broadcast today do you think that Fabby
actually has been the best player in the
world in 2023 it's one of those
complicated questions that you I'm not
trying to get a cop out on the answer
but he has had the best performance
rating in classical chess I think that
speaks magnitude so there's definitely
the argument for Fabiano Magnus didn't
play oh so many classical events and you
could argue what are his Ambitions but I
think there is a good argument of fabbi
having been the best player in 2023 in
classical chess and he do start with a
draw against the world number one and
there we have our results from game one
of round three there is the final rapid
game coming up between these players
Wesley so has to win on demand to take
it to Armageddon Alaura needs to do the
same crazy crazy game between these two
players danis lavic Abdu satro was a
peaceful draw David what was the
highlight for you in this well fought
match well uh yeah I promised uh a
glimpse a highlight of the so versus
Maxim VRA finale there and just the
tactics that flowed in the Frenchman's
favor I want to highlight this one
moment it actually looked like Wesley so
had escaped the worst White's Rooks
lining up it looks like white actually
is the one on the attack some targets
including the F7 Pawn however Maxim
turned things in his favor by pushing
forward bypassing the white F Pawn G5
not only is this a good defensive move
but we see the attacking ideas after
Rook to E1 and now G4 opening up the
black queen on this diagonal if you take
this Pawn you'd walk into a devastating
double attack a check hitting this Rook
as well but not just this after Rook to
G3 a beautiful tactic a queen sacrifice
Queen to H4 and if Rook takes Pawn now
the black queen would have sacrificed
itself and a nasty Checkmate on the H
file because the bishop covers the G1
Square this tactic allowed Maxim to win
material and after Queen to D3 He simply
dropped back his Bishop now with Bishop
takes E5 double attack on the queen on
the rook and he won the game
that was so nice the the ability to see
that Queen Sacrifice from a distance the
domination of the dark squares Maxim
vrai every bit earned that game even
when things started to go to Wesley's
way Maxim never gave up he never caved
in and in fact he's the one who showed
that he had the upper
hand such a great fight that was and
we're seeing amazing chess all
throughout history he's being written in
Toronto for the fight to be the
Undisputed King of the Champions chesta
and you can own a digital a piece of
digital chess history and there it is it
is a beautiful displayed of the trophy
and all you got to do is go to chess
champs. to bid on this stunning stunning
artwork the champion of the tour will
receive one of these and you could be
the recipient of the only other displate
of this uh beautiful trophy in front so
go to chess champs. and make your bid on
this one and we got a big big game two
coming up off round three the final
rapid game between these two players
where Wesley so needs to beat this guy
Maxim V lra on fire in that game one on
the clock as well it's going to be
determination from both of these we will
be back with more action it doesn't look
like much but neither would a Sicilian
Defense to the untrained eye this is a
performance enhancer you don't see it
how about now manage your air quality
sharpen your performance change the game
with air
things this December they're back for
one more round chess GPT I'm already
liking this bot it's such a big troll
dead lost Grandpa Gambit decides to get
a bit crazy because he sacrifices the
queen Frank and Isa and everyone's
favorite Kitty mittens well if I go here
it's a fork if I go here it's a it's
another Fork so I guess the only safe
move is
[Music]
this I didn't even see that
oh oh that is so sick that's actually
sick oh there is 95 oh
my play them again while you can on
chess.com
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com connect your chess.com account
and Twitch account at go. chess.com
connect accounts and bang boom voila
you're done 100% adree Bliss forever
more when whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life Wesley so was qualified for the
first event as the reigning chess.com
Global championship winner but his road
to Toronto has not been without
challenges from tough matchups against
Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlson to
his remarkable comeback through the
losers bracket in the aim chess round
black is completely winning the race
even without Black's three pawns this is
still actually a draw so Hikaru he knows
he's got this in the bag he's smiling
he's got a Time advantage and he
clinches his fist Wesley resign fist
pump wow it's over hiar Nakamura makes
it through to the Grand Final but called
there Dan the Knight joins the attack he
takes the pawn and it's a big mistake is
there a finish here David I think it's
something to do with Knight D5 and the
B6 squares calling my name I'm freaking
out what is it it's over gets the draw I
think there was a draw offer that was
made and Wesley just accepts it nck
played Rook D7 it is a dead loss
situation but he just offered a draw in
the Grand Final he lost to Magnus
Carlson but Banks enough points to
qualify for the tour finals this could
be the last few moves of the a aess
rapid and he wins a bece the pawn on D3
it's going a
queen back the check meeting it's on the
board Simon there we go oh my God we
have a winner Magnus Carson checkmates
Wesley so and wins the a chess
[Music]
rapid
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
take
the official chess.com merch store is
back and bigger than ever we've got the
perfect gift for the chess lovers in
your life fresh new designs for t-shirts
socks hats and more at chess.com shop or
use the command merch in chat to shop
right now and we've got Ka with the
player who's been playing some big chess
well a big match here today for Fabiano
Carana against Magnus Carlson coming now
from a Jo in the first game is that a
good start for you yeah it's a good
start I was under pressure for most of
the game I think Magnus knew the line
better than I did uh the the opening he
got okay it should be an equal position
but he was more comfortable with the
position and in the end game it was
quite dangerous I think it should always
be a draw I don't think I was ever
losing or anything but of course I was
under pressure and low on time um
definitely was uh a a bit of a close
close call White pieces in game two will
we see a winner in this match or will we
see armag get on before that happens
well we'll see a winner in the match but
I don't know if there will be Armon or
not that's the that's the only question
but uh yeah of course it's going to be
tough uh one way or the other of course
it's a good start but it's only a draw
it's not you know uh it hasn't shaken up
the match uh in any real way it's just
um a normal start let's say so for how
long have you had the the opening ready
the plan for your white game here
against Magnus in the round
robin I don't think I've had I even have
it ready now okay interesting
interesting so you will now prepare and
find out what you're going to play I'll
think about what I'll play for sure yeah
right it's going to be interesting thank
you Fabby and good luck in that game all
right let's see what Fabiano Carana
opens with with the white pieces against
Magnus Carlson in game two that is uh
the big question what will be the
opening Choice the opening approach by
Fabby he mentioned that he felt the
pressure the pull in the game game one
after the opening but he managed to hold
it quite confidently and that's that has
to give you some boost when you're
playing against Magnus Carlson and you
hold a difficult end game you know
you're playing some of the best chess
it's how we described it in the studio
that Magnus wanted a slight pull tried
to play a position he was more
comfortable in but Fabiano played
Perfect Defense that was never an
opportunity for Magnus to get a win so
Fabby he should be feeling confident but
you don't want to get overconfident and
press too hard with the white p and I'm
going to get our body language expert in
David you've just been appointed that
you know Magnus well what is that
expression oh did he just hear
me it's quite possible he did look over
at the exact moment you said that Tanya
um to me he just looks very calm very
composed look very looks very Zen right
now Magnus Carson um just the way he's
approached this whole tournament so far
it's still early days of course but he's
playing all of his best openings uh no
freestyling no troll openings as we
sometimes see from the world number one
and uh yeah he looks in the zone can you
hear me Magnus smile if you can oh my
God I can see the smile I think he can
it's the telepathy right there between
David and Magnus he's ready to go with
the black pieces it's going to be quite
the battle will they go into Armageddon
or will we have a decisive result in
this one how ambitious is Fabby going to
be with white I don't think he will do
anything unusual by his own standards by
what his typical repertoire is but I've
been thinking this question that you
asked about Magnus and Magnus on day one
played Dennis lazic and nirc Abdus
satarov at least on paper the two lowest
rated players in the field the youngest
players in the field so Magnus got to
off to a great start with two match
victories but I do think that he
recognized that his toughest Road lays
ahead with Fabiano sitting across from
him with the rest of the opponents on
his slate I mean he knows that this is a
big match up against Fabby and it's
handshakes games are underway it's go
time and Fabby starts with one e four is
that Knight to C6 wow commentator's
curse I said all of his best openings
Magnus Carlson he has played this move
and In classical chess as well uh very
recently including in the European Team
Championship over the board uh just last
month but okay this is provocative stuff
white already sees as a space advantage
and Black's Knight on C6 slightly
misplaced it's like a bad carolan
because your C Pawn can't challenge for
the center in any way the Knight on C6
actually would like to have that pawn in
front of it if that PA if could jump
across you put pressure on White Center
all that being said even though white
has a spatial Advantage there are no
easy targets black is very solid out of
the gates and Fabiano showing that he's
willing to trade off pieces here and I
don't think that Magnus is much worse
despite the provocative opening is there
such a thing as a bad caroan Robert
that's my question one of the favorite
openings of a bunch of streamers Levy
Rosman you know Dina pound KY yeah but
the caroan they say in the Queen's
Gambit is all pawns no hope there are no
pawns going on here and I guess there
still is hope you're watching Magnus
Carlson play chess but the point is that
you're not challenging for the center so
I feel like black is not having the best
time at the board it looks like a mix
between a bad carakan but a good french
so this Pawn structure more reminiscent
of a French defense of course with white
seizing more space it's a bit locked at
least black does have the light Square
Bishop outside the pawn chain though and
uh even if it gets traded off these uh
pair of Bishops um yeah at least black
can breathe the S of relief no bad piece
there in the middle game and Fabby
starts with his non-standard sorry
Magnus starts with the non-standard one
Knight to C6 Fabby makes the most
natural moves gaining space in the
center offering a bishop trade to
Black's most active piece and Magnus
goes into a long T does that surprise
you it does um I think two surprises
firstly that Fabiana reacted so quickly
not being surprised by 19 196 is already
an achievement but yeah it's a bit odd
because Magnus didn't have too much
choice on that last move he could have
delayed The Exchange perhaps he could
have run away maybe pinned the White
Knight but okay Bishop's off the board
now White's Queen on D3 nice Square for
it and Magnus needs to somehow make
sense of his pieces he needs to decide
which side uh which flank to uh Castle
his King on and there there's no tension
right now there are no pawns staring at
one another no Pawn breaks in the
position maybe eventually we we will see
black push that F7 Pawn now that's the
golden Pawn whenever you push it you
have to be very very careful because it
can expose your king but if he does
choose at some moment to play F6 I was
about to say he will likely Castle to
the Queen side he gets his Queen out of
the way to start maybe we will see
Magnus go in that direction but if I'm
Fabby maybe I play a move like Pawn to
C3 say are you sure you want to Castle
in that direction because then I can
play B4 and start going after the black
king on that flank so this is a very big
moment for Fabby is he actually worried
about Magnus cast and queens side I
think the answer is no but how is he
going to deal with Black's impending
ideas yeah PA to C3 he's saying to
Magnus okay please commit your king and
I will go for Robert's plan throwing
pawns down the board porn storm there
Magnus delays that decision and uh I
think very wisely does chip away at the
White Center here fighting against the
head of the pawn chain white One Connect
Four white achieved this porn formation
so you need to break it down and uh yeah
nice move this one very much in the
balance right now and uh very much about
who Maneuvers who kind of understands
this type of Pawn structure better and
that black Bishop on f8 the dark scor
Bishop it doesn't really have a nice
space to go to because of White's
Connect Four as you called it so this
move it will help that Bishop get Dev
which will in turn help the Knight
that's next to it get developed which in
turn will help that Rook that's in the
corner so black has not been able to
develop yet but in the next few moves
will the eval bar is right there in the
center so Magnus gets away with another
dodgy opening it doesn't matter how
dubious it is if the opponent doesn't
know how to capitalize Magnus has proven
time and time again he knows how to get
out unscathed and F6 is this very
thematic French break and when you've
got the French without the light Squad
Bishop for black you've got to be a
happy uh happy camper with that uh the
biggest problem in Black's position in
all these uh in all these structures is
having that light Squad Bishop that's
been traded off Magnus gets the F6 break
in and it's really all about how quickly
he can develop the king side
pieces I am hoping for opposite side
castling but I don't believe it will
happen because it just feels like Fabby
will be faster with the attack on that
flank oh you never know it's Magnus
Carlson uh he does like to provoke his
opponents from time to time the black
king still needs a few turns to Castle
on the king side where it would like to
be need to get the black Bishop out the
way the Black Knight out the way first
so it might come down to a matter of
timing but yeah it would take a brave
player as you say Tanya to commit
Black's King on the queen side and we'd
love to see it yeah we would love to see
it oh it's not happening ever definitely
not if you Castle Queen side after this
I don't think madman is a sufficient
term to use against that decision but in
general that pawn on E5 it's both a
great piece because it restricts the
territory that blacks minor pieces can
occupy but it might be an overextended
Pawn so look at that pawn in the center
there for white it doesn't have a pawn
protecting it which means it can be
vulnerable to attack so it's going to be
an interesting battle as we see it
continue from here yeah Magnus just
taking this time out gaining space and
uh covering the B4 Square not allowing
white to push forward because the center
is blocked he does have that luxury of
time so this game now will take a slower
pace and uh I think we'll check back in
a bit later on well this one promises to
be a heated fight between the world
number one and the world number two
Fabby with that last move defending the
E5 Pawn freeing up his own Knight to
perhaps jump forward and while Magnus
has a think we are uh going to move to
the other big clash between Hikaru and
Ali Rea Hikaru did win their first
battle Ali Resa has to win on demand and
the moment the board came up in front of
me I was like one second this has to be
the royz and then I see white Bishop is
on G2 what just happened in the opening
yeah it looks like a distant relative
Tanya of the royalz of the Italian in
game uh the pawn structure in the center
very reminiscent of all of these one E4
E5 openings but yeah that light Square
Bishop does make a bit of an odd
impression um Black's Archer from afar
though Black's d square Bishop on A7 on
a nice long diagonal and Nakamura trying
to clarify the pawn structure on the
queen side but I think this is good
strategy from fuja all the pieces all
pawns still on the board at this early
stage in a must-win situation that's
step one achieved and uh in the mean
time Nakamura just maneuvering his kns
over and what one of the biggest
benefits David of the structure that
white has chosen with the fian ketto
bishop is the Pawn in front of it that
Knight that just land on G6 going
nowhere it's purely a defensive piece
while in the Italian game sometimes that
Knight hops into F4 and caus them
problems in fact with oliv had the black
pieces against Fabio Carana we saw that
knight jump into the F4 square with a
sacrifice helping to deliver a vicious
attack so right now I feel like Al does
have everything under control it's going
to be a longer battle and as you're
highlighting here the Knight can improve
then that dark score Bishop can develop
I prefer White's chances even though
black has no real weaknesses thus far
yeah it feels like he's got a
full-blooded fight ahead here ala he's
going to plant his Knight on the C4
Square most likely he can at some point
open the center uh or at least block out
this black Dart Square Bishop with a
move like D4 um he's got a bunch of
available plans and I like this kind of
space advantage on the queen side from
experience it's always slightly
uncomfortable knowing what to do with
black do you ever push the pawn to C6
maybe loosening up things a bit more do
you ever get the time to open the center
with D5 Black's Bishops um they can be
very good but they can also slightly
stened um right now fua yeah level on
the clock all the pieces on the board in
a must-win situation I think he's
achieved anything everything he could
hope for but of course still very early
days and for Ola the other good thing is
that the next few moves come way easier
than they do for black right White's
night on A3 can be headed to C4 or even
to C2 and then the center of the board
to E3 targeting some of the light
squares uh the break that you pointed
out of the dwn moving forward always in
the air the one idea that Hikaru as you
rightly mentioned David I at some point
you want to get that break in with black
as well you want to try to get C6
targeting that over ambitious play on
The Queen side opening up the files
right now development on both sides have
reasons to be I think pleased with the
opening outcome here yeah hiar is not
going to be upset but Ali Raza I think
is actually happy because he at least
has different ideas in the position he
may be symmetrical for now but once
white pushes that pawn in the center I
believe he should push the pawn to D4
right now uh he is creating some tension
on his own terms it's going to be a long
battle but it's one where ala he can say
if I'm playing the better chest today I
may be able to secure that point because
it's not a simple solution for Hikaru
yeah and Hikaru I mean talking of body
language looks so calm right now it
feels like he's really bounced back
recovered uh he's back in Boss mode uh
after his uh birthday Blues yesterday
and at least he has no weaknesses in
this position he's feeling confident
he's feeling solid and okay this one
will liven up but your move on the board
to Robert D4 white does does occupy the
center first on his terms most
importantly and uh some work still to be
done for Nakamura you don't want to sit
passively for too long often you're
looking for ways to concretely break out
trading off a set of Pawns fighting for
the central squares um otherwise you're
just simply cramped and suffering and
for black that pawn push that you were
advocating for Pawn C7 to C6 just trying
to uh put pressure on White's extended
B5 pawn it doesn't really carry a threat
behind it because black doesn't really
want to capture that pawn anyway with
that Knight on A3 sitting there so for
black there are ideas that I can see but
I I don't know the follow-ups exactly
and as I was point out if you take on B5
the White Knight will take back that's
actually a very good trade a positive
trade for white gaining space so yeah
you see the evaluation bar go very high
up in White's favor with all the
pressure on that flank so I I don't
really see more than one move at a time
for black and I feel like for white
there are several different
options all right well this one the
break has happened D4 on the board so
it's going to be fireworks really soon
and uh we're going to head to Toronto as
we've got James uh joining us as some of
the players are fighting to make a
comeback James can you feel the heat
coming from the playing Arena right
now not only do I see the heat but
they're bringing the heat Tanya David
Robert Bobby chess without Hess Hess
okay I'm feeling so great right now
guess why I'm feeling so great guys can
anyone tell me while I'm feeling so
great you had a lovely breakfast there
are chess players that you admire and
respect in the playing Hall you had a
great workout today man that's my twin
brother Robert S over there I can hear I
had a nice workout too as well what else
what else yeah no here it is I got you
Hikaru Nakamura played the Joe Bava jar
jar Banks London he played the London he
played the Joe Bava London and guess
what the course drops tomorrow I don't
know if it was promotion from iaro I
didn't talk to him maybe he just
telepathically cuz he is half man half
everything else somehow he just tried to
figure it out but the course drops
tomorrow and he played it and guess what
he won how you think I'm feeling over
here in joj Bava Joe Bava London land
how do you think we feeling so James
you're basically saying that you're
hikaru's secret second for this
event hey I didn't want to have to say
it David you said it not me buddy okay
you said it not me David come on
breaking news of course I feel great
over here in Toronto he's played it he
won and we see a reverse joa too
actually in magnus's game he just you
know he felt it and you can play the joa
sometimes both ways that shagor is can
be played in in reverse and of course
I'm going to go back and look at that
game and see how it's going but we just
got some joa landish stuff going on with
this chess course dropping tomorrow
James I'm with you there the openings
have been quite fun and they're using
one of your repertoire but I have a
question about the players mentality and
the attitude after Ali Raza and Wesley
lost did you have a chance to see them
during the break how do you think they
were
feeling yeah you know I didn't see
either one of I think Ali res actually
came out I think the way he's handling
games win loss draw uh it's very high
level I mean he's just you don't see any
really emotion from him he just kind of
it happened you know get get some he
grabbed a snack or two went back to play
and that was it didn't see Wesley on
this one um but I definitely saw Ali
razza every time in between rounds he
just gets up he walks around he's calm
you can tell he's in good spirits and
his psych I think his Psych is really
really good right
now all right well James uh exciting
exciting jababa London's happening with
the white and the black pieces we will
keep checking in with you and uh yeah
have fun in Toronto and there's a lot of
fun going on on the board as well we are
going to head over to Maxim vasher lra
against Wes liso Hikaru alza still
heating up alza has to win on demand and
uh Wes liso needs to do the same to take
it to
playoffs and there the players are Maxim
VRA with the white pieces needing only a
draw to take match Victory and he's got
an end game and I'm kind of liking
White's position already yeah f for
forward the flamboyant Frenchman
throwing the FB to F4 now and I mean
Queen's off Wesley's queenside pieces as
well a bit of sleep here especially that
black Rook on the corner on A8 I think
he's opening it up right at the correct
moment and Vash gra not playing for the
draw he's got the Queens off but this
last move shows he's playing the
position he's playing uh kind of
objective chess and there's some big
threats actually on the board Wesley has
to be really careful to survive let
alone try to win this game very
instructive moment right here because so
many players and all they need is a draw
they make passive moves Quiet Moves
instead of going two squares of the pawn
maybe they would have went one but Maxim
understands the position in all
practical terms calls for this push his
light Square Bishop is slicing across
the board towards the enemy King by
opening up the file his Rook next to his
King is about to see an open Line there
towards that very square and if black
takes on F4 he may be able to push this
Pawn up to E5 go forward and if that
Knight hops the side of the board to H5
I got an extra Pawn go me e E6 slams
down the board Rook takes Rook on D1 I'm
not going to take your Rook back at
least not yet I'm first going to take on
F7 intermo with Czech the king is forced
only legal move is sliding to the corner
and then after Rook takes Rook uh the
game is completely in White's favor your
pass Pawn the back rank issues it's all
going to lead to a Checkmate and a win
for white yeah beautiful tactics it just
works move by move and I don't think
Wesley saw this coming uh that
instructive moment just to mention again
Robert if white does nothing if white is
too slow if white just kind of takes
time out moves a rook for example this
would allow black to for example trade
off Dart Square bishops get rid of those
pieces B5 might come at the right moment
black has severe counterplay and
long-term Black's actually doing pretty
well but yeah just short-term
deficiencies and F4 takes uh this one
kind of one-off opportunity and I don't
even see a defense here I think Wesley
has to be really really resourceful a
two-minute Thing by Wesley saw in big
trouble already by move 17 and game one
also felt like a maxim show and this one
as well well we heard it from the
players earlier where they said that
Wesley the toughest toughest player to
crack but today just Maxim has been
getting his kind of positions and I'm
just wondering uh David if it's possible
to just do an action replay that how is
it possible in 17 moves Maxim gets this
incredible position out of the opening
even though the Queens are traded off
he's the one who's playing for the
initiative and Wesley in big trouble
yeah let's uh go back and show what has
happened in this game as we see Rooks
leave the board I just want highlight
here very tense position uh but Maxim
influenced by the match situation did
just trade off a set of Pawns in the
center looks very balanced very level
but now an active move Bishop to C4
landing on this diagonal that Robert
highlighted and if we fast forward it's
just about active play Pawn to A4
clamping down on the queen side and uh
now Landing a bishop on this beautiful
A3 square and it's all about the power
of these Bishops and this is how we saw
Queens leave the board uh the queens
were traded off in this really
convoluted way but a really accurate way
and if we catch up with the current
position Wesley's only defense now was
to tradeoff Rooks parting with the open
file a backwards knight move now holding
things together but black is totally
stuck black is paralyzed immobilized you
can you cannot move this Knight
otherwise the white Rook will infiltrate
you therefore you cannot move the bishop
which is stuck defending the Knight
therefore you cannot move the rook in
the corner these three pieces will not
play a role in the next few moves and
it's just about whether Maxim can profit
in the meantime I'm expecting him to
push forward you don't want to allow
this black Bishop to open up on the
diagonal but a position like this is
very one-sided and big Advantage for
white big Advantage Maxim with a
promising promising and game and he
needs only a draw to wrap up his match
Wesley in big trouble in this one we
will keep an eye out on this uh but we
have to head back to the Magnus board
because the world number one it looks
like uh has found himself in some
trouble also down on the clock we saw a
very different body language from Magnus
at the start of the game David this is a
concerned Magnus right now yeah this is
a Magnus who's focusing because he needs
to his back is up against the wall
Fabiano is going for the attack uh White
has actually won a pawn in the position
as well you see a white knight uh near
to the camera here uh deep in enemy
territory on the H7 Square it's grabbed
a pawn simply and magnus's King stuck in
the center uncared uh unfaced undon as
well but uh yeah Magnus in trouble
objectively but he voluntarily just
moved his King if we even go back a
single move you can see by the yellow
highlight on the board he played King to
d8 on his own bition and a move ago was
that Force I guess if we just can show
this that there was a huge idea for
White Knight F6 check was the threat so
if you play Knight takes E5 for black I
think white gets away oh I was going to
say I thought white would get away with
it but Knight F6 check oh this is funny
after Knight F6 you can play King to F
E7 and that way if Knight takes Queen
Knight takes Queen you lose your knight
but you gain the White Knight see this
is some really deep stuff of course
Magnus V be capable of seeing it but
instead Magnus says I don't want a part
of that let me slide my king over so I
guess the tactics can be misleading in
some extent you get afraid of them but
he could have successfully grabbed the
pawn in the center again we're going to
Deep dive into our live board but
because this is such a crazy position
David I want you to go back just a
couple of moves from where we left at L
to see how we actually got to this point
uh because this is getting uh very
intense yeah very intense position a
crazy position and uh we left it just
before this moment black has actually
just brought the bishop out to C5 white
has put the Knight on D2 just developing
here Magnus played A4 and Fabiano said
okay I don't care you're trying to clamp
down on my queen side but I don't trust
you I'm playing B4 anyway allowing on
passant and this is a very bad strategic
move from Fabiano but a very good
Dynamic move he's activating his pieces
with gain of tempo he gains time against
this bishop and now he trades off this
bishop bishop and uh look at how the
White Knight is about to pounce on C5
Whit's gained a bunch of time at the
cost of a couple of weak pawns but who
cares about weak pawns if you're going
for checkmate if you're going on the
attack and uh just beautiful energetic
play now another Knight lands on the
other side of the board Knight to G5
hitting this square with the Knight now
on H7 and uh we see greed being good
knight takes pawn and uh The Rook
defending this is how we got to the
current position a nasty night check
threatened as Robert pointed out and
discovered attack against this
undefended protected black Rook black
cannot Castle King side of course it's
illegal right now because the White
Knight covers one of the squares the
king wants to Castle through you cannot
Castle queenside because there would be
devastating tactics such as Knight to C5
a sacrifice attacking the queen if the
Knight is captured suddenly the B file
is open and first you land a check of
course and this would end in Devastation
this would soon be Checkmate uh so
Magnus he had no other option uh or at
least he felt he had no other option
than King d8 and now Fabiano says okay
your King's heading in that direction
I'm going to preempt uh that decision
and play A4 getting ready to attack if
the king continues but he is giving up
this Pawn on E5 so Faby says I don't
need this Pawn in the center of the
board black can take it with Tempo a
shot against the White Queen and I'm
guessing the White Queen would just step
back to a sore like E2 and the knight's
in trouble A5 is coming but this is
getting very dynamic in fact these moves
are on the board right now doesn't black
have the better long-term position
because White's Queen side pawns they're
split over there so if the Queens come
off the board suddenly is much better
and the Knight is attacked and if you go
back to the squad that it came from I
think the trick that you pointed out
earlier becomes a reality and the Knight
can jump back to F6 and The Rook is
hanging on h8 you're going to end up
losing material which means that now
Magnus has to retreat with the Knight
defending his Rook on h8 yeah he has to
be so careful Magnus Carlson maybe only
two moves to survive in the current
position as you say Tanya he has to
choose one of these two squares uh maybe
this one just to defend this rook in the
corner I like this one better because it
also creates a threat introduces a KN kn
Fork these Knights are dancing around
like nobody's business it's they're
dancing Like It's 1999 Knight F4
threatened with a nasty Fork uh but who
knows who's better at this point it's
chaotic question what are the chances
that if Magnus goes Knight G6 we see a
repetition with Queen G4 Knight E5 Queen
EO Knight G6 oh I think low ODS but it
would be a logical end to the game Tanya
a queen and Knight Tango to end the and
this one I could see that happening
because for Fabiano if he lets this game
continue and he doesn't have this
initiative that he was relying on we're
talking about he is worse longterm the
A4 and C3 Pawns in any end game they
will be the weakest link on this board
so and that repetition is a funny one we
sometimes joke that oh these super GMS
they may just find a way to to get the
game over with here it comes T maybe
you're the prophet after all wow hold
your BR if Magnus goes Knight E5 you do
have a check on G5 is that a dangerous
check I don't think so I think that
after the check you can uh even
interpose with the queen and and that's
not what what Fabby wants I think he is
going to bring his Queen back to E2
Armageddon perhaps here we come but look
at the clock times Fabiano is 4 and a
half minutes up right now Armageddon I
think would favor Magnus Magnus earlier
this year in Norway chess won seven
Armageddon in a row on consecutive days
he's the king of Armageddon chess Magnus
I don't think Fabby should repeat but
you know who he didn't play in
Armageddon Fabiana a Carana because
Fabby beat him head-to-head in the
classical game so they did not get that
experience against one another of course
they have played so many times online
here but for Fabby you don't look at
Magus time like oh he's in severe times
like he's Magnus Carlson how many times
has he won the world Blitz Championship
how many times has he been the world
champion how many times he won the world
rapid Championship he knows that even
with minimal time in the clock Magnus
can bring it and his position I think is
actually quite in danger of crumbling if
he continues this game and you know who
did win the two armag yesterday it was
Fabiano Carana so big question right now
will Fabby get more ambitious go ahead
with that check on G5 which as David
said can be easily blocked with the
queen coming to E7 and perhaps doesn't
give white much oh well Fabby just let
go of the clock situation play the
position on the board I don't really see
another good Square for the queen
Retreat to E2 will we see this
repetition happen and Armageddon Moment
of Truth is incoming Fabiano is reaching
out for a piece on he doesn't repeat the
position I think Magnus was hoping uh
maybe even expecting a repetition the
dance between the queen and Knight now
this attack means that the Knight
probably won't choose the square that it
was last on if it goes back to G6 then
white could land a check on G5 gaining
even more time uh where's Magnus going
to plant his Knight he goes back to F7
is said no more checks also Mo most
importantly as tan pointed out earlier
defending blacks rook in the corner uh
everything protected now for black and
uh yeah Robert White is kind of a bit
loose on both flanks right now White's
KN on H7 looks really oddly placed and
those pawns you mentioned on the queen
side longterm horrible horrible uh
horrible structure there and that's why
he pushed the pawn because I was going
to emphasize the point that he would
have liked to bring his Rook on A1
towards the center but that pawn a move
ago was under Threat by both the black
queen and the Rook so he goes A5 does it
really carry a big threat is white
really willing to trade off Rooks
White's back rank is actually quite
vulnerable so if that A1 Rook is traded
for the A8 Rook there could be some back
rank Checkmate ideas and you see the
eval bar it is going in magnus' favor he
is down the clock but 2 minutes from
Magnus is an eternity to me Fabiano
kirana sending a clear message to Magnus
by declining the repetition that was in
his hand that he is playing for more in
this game with the white pieces he feels
he's got the pressure on and it's
understandable you're about four minutes
up on the clock Magnus King not feeling
safe all the tricks and threats down the
H file it is uh incredible to see Fabby
fighting this out for the win yeah
that's why he has so many fans that's
why we all love Fabiano he very rely
takes quick draws he very rarely takes
the uh peaceful way out let's say uh
he's always up for a fight no matter
what color no matter what opponent and
um normally the chess Gods reward that
type of attitude that type of play but
this exact position is really still wild
and 5 minutes against just under 2
minutes it's anyone's game still but no
natural moves for white I'm starting to
worry about that back rank as soon as
you said it Robert I'm seeing all of
these tactics that end up in Black's
favor just because the white king is
slightly suffocated behind its own pawns
that's why he slid his King to the side
did Magnus he's saying please take my
Pawn on B6 there may be a back rank
check meting idea and I also want to
point out that look at how uncoordinated
discombobulated whes P are there's a
knight all the way up there on H7 a rook
down there on H3 then a knight across
the board on B3 and a rook there on the
corner a what are these pieces doing
there's no Harmony here and I feel like
in these types of positions it's so easy
to overlook a tactic in the back rank
problems that we were just talking about
a takes B6 a swap on a A1 white is not
losing just yet but you could see at
some point that Queen jumping into B5
and then the B1 Square everything is
loose and Magnus under 2 minutes but
looking extremely relaxed right now he
also has these ideas of starting to push
the Eon the central pawns up the board
this has happened to me I don't know how
many times and I want to ask you guys
where you have just declined a
repetition decline the draw offer and
then you just start regretting it
immediately yeah normally one of two
things happen either you reject the draw
offer and your opponent suddenly panics
and they think oh no they must be
believing in their position if they're
de uh declining a draw or as you say
Tanya you regret it immediately and
suddenly the opponent's like wait I was
happy with a draw a minute ago but
suddenly I want more and Rook to E1
instead I don't know Fabiano he's giving
up a pawn now uh the a pawn cannot be
snapped off I like Tanya's idea pushing
the Black Point to E5 in the near future
um feels like Magnus is the one with
options but still much much lower on the
clock Fabiano is he just hustling now
he's gone for it he's saying if you take
my Pawn A5 yes black gains material but
white gains that c E5 score access and
Magnus he's a go for it maybe there's
Queen up one square trading off those
Queens would of course be in Black's
favor and now he's up a pawn and it's
not just any pawn it's an outside pass
Pawn some of the most dangerous Pawns in
end games I'm worried for Fabiano right
now the time is actually evening Magnus
is gaining some confidence and he's now
gained an extra pass Pawn after winning
that A5 Pawn one thing's clear that
Fabby whatever he needs to do it has to
happen in the middle game end games are
completely busted for black even if the
M for white
even if the material gets level even if
you win that E6 Pawn the A5 Pawn in the
end game will decide the result Fabiano
has to go all out in this middle game
yeah and that's the problem he's got the
C5 Square for his Knight but if the
white knight had landed on C5 black
could have forced the queen exchange
immediately Queen D D6 that's why
Fabiana has to run away and look at that
eval bar it's been shifting shifting and
black simply has an extra Pawn now and
it's that powerful Pawn so strong
against Knights these Rook pawns yeah
it's all going wrong for Fabiano right
now and this queen Retreat it's not a go
in go all out kind of move it it does
signal that things have gone wrong for
Fabby they certainly have he is
retreating to stop that runaway passer
he couldn't play his knight jump forward
because a queen trade would have been
forced he can't afford that and it's not
like and I want to give a quick shout
out to lavic against abusar Dennis lazic
up a pawn trying to press in the end
game Magnus he's up a pawn but there's
so many pieces left on this board he
goes E5 the engine reacts at first
saying oh it's going back towards the
middle but then it with more depth it
realizes black is still in charge and
why not push those Pawns in Center
everything in this position is defended
for black every single piece save that
Rook on A8 next to the king over there
is defended so he's pushing his pawns
forward Magnus Carlson up a pawn but
with a minute on the clock Fabiano's kns
will be jumping in the Queens side
Knight coming on to C5 the kingside
Knight can come to G5 in certain
positions creating some tactical ideas
against that Rook on h8 yes Magnus with
the upper hand but with just a minute on
the clock and all the knights on the
board it's still a game for all two
results yeah still a game and uh great
chess quality here but also great air
quality out there in Toronto uh as we
see just below um just at the bottom of
your screens there uh CO2 levels uh not
ideal but uh everything else looking
perfect great conditions for the players
and that's why they're all bringing the
best chess right now it says air quality
is fair what would be a fair result in
this game Robert well for Fabiano I
think a decisive game would be the fair
result he's the one who chose to play on
I don't know in what ction but when you
make that choice that was a big moment
he could have forced the draw more or
less by repetition he chose to play on
and he may pay the price look at the
clock it's evening up here and that's
really bad news for Fabby because I feel
like magnus's moves are easier to play
Fabby just retreated his Queen backwards
he doesn't have an a natural followup
the knight jump to C5 no longer comes
with a threat against a pawn I think
that Fab's running out of steam running
out of options and well he may be
running out of time yeah he's put the
pressure on his own back here the burden
is on white to do do something you're
simply material down you have no
coordination I think it's the lack of
coordination that's really killing him
here um it's the hope that's killing him
as well that hope of trying to win
trying to play on rejecting that draw I
just don't see any ideas at All Black's
Central pawns Black's a pawn they're
just marching and okay The Rook lands
back where it came from on A1 it was
just here two moves ago indecision from
Fabiano he's changing his mind he's
regretting his uh life choices and I
don't see any reason for Magnus not to
push that pawn push the black aor you
can move the black queen as well to B5
to protect it everything's turning it's
just collapsing move by move and the one
hope is still the clock Magnus
uncharacteristically taking a long time
here he's already gained the advantage
he's done the hard work and normally
he's so good at stabilizing okay he
plays one of the best moves clearly uh
Queen to B5 but 30 seconds that was half
his time he spent on that one turn you
give Magnus like one opportunity just
one chance and he's just all over the
game uh Fabby declining that repetition
Magnus gets the A5 Pawn gets that E Pawn
rolling and now the queen is coming out
and it's him who's putting pressure on
White's pieces right now both players
under one minute it's going to take a
miracle for Faby to survive this and
it's easier for us we have the
evaluation bar we see what the
trajectory of the game is I don't think
Fabby understood uh some of the problems
he would face that their danger would
arise this quickly and you see that
night it was protecting The Rook it
needed to be there now it hops towards
the center into D6 is going to jump
forward some more and look at Fabby move
after move he's retreating pieces as
Magnus he presses forward there are no
issues in Black's camp this is looking
really tough for Fabiano the last few
moves Fabby has been making retreating
moves one after the other while all of
magnus's pieces are coming into Fabby
Camp here the a pawn is going to tie
down that Rook on A1 meanwhile the other
Rook on H3 and the Knight on H7 have
been stuck there forever not able to
create the Tactical tricks that Fabby
was relying on and that is desperation y
Des spiration G4 he had to do something
Fabiano he was just stuck you cannot
just wait for your opponent to slowly
improve and kind of get their pieces to
Ideal squares and slowly Crush you uh
now the white king is eternally weak the
whole idea was to kick back the Black
Knights and go for black Central pawns
but this is a beautiful Outpost Black's
Knight on C4 where it's just landed not
just defending the center but supporting
the advance of that a pawn again he's
just been playing with offside pieces
that White Knight on H7 it grabbed a
pawn but it's been stuck on that square
that useless Square for 10 15 moves now
and there's not even a check against the
black king it's safely situated on C8 he
goes finally moves one of his Knights
now he can move the other but the
knights are Superfluous here they're
stepping on each other's toes and that a
pawn it's about to become a queen I
wonder if Queen B2 is he there it's
played he's giving up a rook with check
in this position because he will get a
new Queen wow that is beautiful Robert
let's just show that variation if the
Queens had been exchanged then Magnus
Carson would have won on the spot with a
beautiful tactic here Queen to B2 would
have allowed a simple Rook sacrifice
this is a check the king can move
actually in either direction but King to
D7 and uh no way to prevent the pawn
from promoting uh to a queen this would
have been deadly let's catch up with the
current position Queen still on the
board here of course but look at this
Pawn on A2 it will decide the game
before too long white still dancing
around uh without any purpose as Magnus
tries to land the killer
blow and The Rook comes up just to
protect everything all of magnus' pieces
are doing something here and now files
are opening in front of Fab's King so he
stle a pawn but he opened a file so the
f file is open the G file as well and
maybe this Knight on E7 can go oh Queen
B1 instead that is stunning take my
queen and give me a new one please and
on the way give your Rook as well and
Fabby panicking there doesn't make his
move in time he just gives up he resigns
what happened there did he run out of
time it looks like his clock is on zero
Tanya he ran out of time but it was a l
position anyway busted for Fabby Magnus
Carlson he plays he wins and there he
takes his match against the world number
two without needing an Armageddon what a
game from Magnus Carlson and as you've
said on previous days David when you
poke the bear sometimes you unleash the
bear and Magnus Carlson he leapt all
over Fab's position he takes game two he
takes the match he's perfect three out
three Magnus Carlson will of course be
back on the board as he will play
against Hikaru in uh the UPC quite a day
it is for him starts with Fabby takes
him down and now he will fight it out
against takar Nakamura and this match is
still on as Wesley so is fighting to try
and take it into the Armageddon and the
players are blitzing out their moves
David wow Wesley two pawns up yeah
Wesley has worked his magic here his
endgame magic because last we left it
white was in control White had full
domination and now Wesley simply
converting he's got two extra pawns he's
forced Knights off the board and
and that's what happens with Wesley so
he is often criticized for making draws
but he had to win and he gets the job
done Wesley so wins with the black
pieces on demand against Maxim vasher
lra and Toronto continues to be magical
for Wesley so Wesley so now writing down
his Armageddon bid as he makes his
comeback win there both of them take a
little bit of a pause before giving the
bids in this one goes in into our magdon
we still have one more game remaining as
danis laic is fighting it against nbec
Abdus satro but Maxim is not happy he
knew that he had it in his hand
completely in control with the white
pieces but Wesley does Wesley things and
uh Strikes Back it continues to be quite
the run for him yeah quite the run and
just uh yeah instructive End Game Play
That's A Reason never to panic if you're
uh playing as black in these must-win
situations in the meantime time both
players with interest rushing over to
the other game that's still in progress
and Dennis lazovic against Abdu satov
also a rook game and also black with two
connected pass pawns Abdu satoro looks
like he should be winning this game oh
my gosh Dennis Lazar was up a pawn for
the majority of this game notbe could
only draw that was the best bet but no
he has turned it around because he is
the most determined player on the planet
he doesn't care who he's facing and you
can see that look on Dennis's face he
can't believe what's trans spired yeah
he kept pushing and pushing and it took
a risk to many Dennis lazik and this
might be his third unlucky defeat in a
match in a rook end game and uh lessons
for the youngster but Abdu satov can he
finish it off we'd love to get a look at
the clock to get an idea nag looks like
he's panicking right now he's got the
H&G connected passel but hasn't made
progress on them and there we have it it
is Dennis lawick who's playing on
seconds and NC with enough time on the
clock wow and a drawn position yet again
I think Abdu satov was completely
winning but now the black king is stuck
anytime the black king moves it will be
checked by the white Rook or the white
Rook will go behind the G pawn and uh
suddenly black cannot make progress oh
my goodness how instructive is this you
have the wrong Pawn remaining Rook pawns
are really bad in Rook end games without
other material and King and pawn games
you have to take this A7 Pawn Black's G6
Pawn will come off the board and this is
just a dead draw now he's just repeating
is he even going to try you take A7 G6
and he says no he knows this is uh done
it is a draw Dennis lavic secures a draw
from a lost position but he did have the
upper hand in the beginning yeah I feel
like that's a fair result because with
best play not Beck was proving he could
make a draw somehow Some Way Dennis lack
pushed too hard because he's showing
that he's also a fighter it's not just
nck and he was losing towards the
stretch down the stretch there he
survives he takes it to Armageddon you
got to be excited for him it's his first
Armageddon
it is uh we've got two Armageddon on our
hands right now with Dennis lazovic nbec
putting in their bids really exciting
stuff and Dennis just turns around he
say's no peeking there well actually
make it easier to peek because we can
almost see his bid uh so for noer Beck
he's strategizing he hasn't written
anything down yet and for Dennis well
I'm curious just how much time he'll put
on that board yeah and the players it is
NC who is thinking more on the bid
Dennis the first one to write down the
time that he's bidding for nck still
very
indecisive yeah both players both fast
both young one of them is going to get
off the scoreboard remember they need to
avoid finishing in the bottom two in the
round robin to stay alive in the
tournament so this next Armageddon for
them is crucial they both need to win
and uh therefore this bid gains in
importance it's so important at this
stage not to go 0 and three because if
not if when one of these players wins
this match suddenly you're right back
back in the thick of things have to
remind everybody that while the top two
sail through to the semi-finals 3
through six play a survival stage to see
which other two join the already
qualified semi-finalist so if you're one
wi match win out of three now all of a
sudden you're tied with a bunch of
people you're feeling much better about
your chances yeah because the bottom two
just get eliminated It's the End of the
Road in Toronto so it's so important to
start climbing up the leaderboard and
Dennis lavic he's just 17 years old he
is the underdog he's got a cross on his
back and this is his chance to show
everyone that he does belong in Toronto
in this tournament as he will be playing
the Armageddon against nbec abdat and
it's not the only one as we see there
Maxim V lra Wesley so also go into the
Armageddon meanwhile Magnus Carlson
Fabby did have the opportunity to take
it to repetition but declining that it
was all Magnus Carlson David too many
big moments to pick from what was your
big takeaway yeah I just want to
highlight one game we didn't get to pay
too much attention to and that was
Hikaru Nakamura getting his second win
of the day closing out that match
Victory against ala fua and he did it in
style Hikaru in really trademark style
here uh it is a chaotic position Hikaru
has the black pieces and he found the
clear-cut way to an advantage that
actually most of us would find difficult
in this position White's Bishop is
attacked it is pinned the Knight is
attacked but Hikaru calmly just traded
off the Queens he knows a draw is enough
but he wants more and in this position
black currently a piece up had to decide
uh what to do after this Knight which
was attacked jumped forward to B6 and
Hikaru actually caught this Knight in a
net after just moving his Rook the
beautiful move the calm move Rook to d8
the Knight is trapped on B6 this is
beautiful no way to exate this piece and
as we saw a few moves later a few moves
down the line Rook to D6 rounded up this
Knight and Hikaru did not look back in
the final position if we fast forward he
actually found a really beautiful
Checkmate as well uh in this position
the white King has just moved to H4 and
after Knight takes F5 check the king
finds itself pinned if it steps forward
this would have ended the game Bishop E8
Checkmate Hikaru classy game from start
to
finish just amazing stuff by Hikaru
Nakamura a wounded Beast is a dangerous
beast and that's what Hikari showed in
his match today against uh Ali ran and
of course you got two big Armageddon
coming up but before that twitch
subscribers stay with us as Toronto will
be bringing in all the action after this
break uh of round two the Armageddon
start but right now it's time for the
Champions chestor trivia for our twit
subscribers be the first to tweet the
correct answer and make sure to tag
champ chestor and use the hash CCD
finals for 3 months of the diamond
membership we'll be back with the armag
evons
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
chess kit is going live and in person at
the chess kid national festival bring
the whole family meet your favorite
Chess
[Music]
Masters solve
puzzles play kto five
tournaments compete for the chess kid
national championship title and so much
more this Festival is surely one for the
books from February 16th to 19th 2024 in
Charlotte North Carolina book your seats
now before they're
[Music]
gone Dennis lazovic has been the
youngest contender in division 1 this
season on the Champions chess tour the
now 17-year-old who got his GM title
only last year has proven that age and
experience is no bar to
Excellence lazic won division 2 in the
aim chess rapid to qualify to division 1
in the Julius bear generation cup he
knocked out both Wesley so and NOC Abdus
satarov on his way to the losers final
eventually losing a close match with
Alara fua this looks like it's suddenly
winning black cannot improve his
position white can meanwhile and uh
Simple Plan as you say Tanya the white
king will eventually cross over it's not
going to be cut off forever Dennis lawi
takes down Wesley so Wesley is out of
the tournament this is incredible Tech
technique by Dennis Las it's going to be
king versus King in the end the black
rook's going to give up give itself up
for the pawn and there it is Dennis laic
takes down nbec Abdus satra is on the
board this is oh I'm really happy to see
this that is it unbelievable
unbelievable chess here unfortunately
for Dennis laig after a fantastic run
and a big fight being so close to
Victory a couple of inaccuracies and it
is the end of the road for the
16-year-old banking 175 points
throughout the season has given lavic a
golden ticket to the tour finals can the
teenager known especially for his
strength in online chess cause more
upsets when the 2023 season concludes
over theboard in
Toronto
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're inspired with all all the
chess happening in Toronto find your
local group or take the lead at
meetup.com and grow the community and
for now we're going to Kaa who is on the
ground with the Wesley so and Maxim V
lra and they're about to reveal their
beds this is so exciting you guys we are
now going to reveal the Armageddon bids
for Wesley so and Maxim I'm going to
count to three and when I hit three you
guys turn your boards and we'll see
what's going to happen so one two three
there it is so Wesley so bids 857 is
that 57 Maxim
952 Wesley you go very low here what's
the thought behind that bit probably
made a big mistake I mean most players
bid 9 minutes and 30 seconds so I'm the
first one to bid low so we'll see if it
probably a big mistake but we'll see
we'll play with the black pieces uh any
any thoughts here mik um you know it
just three matches from myons we'll see
how it goes you guys I'll let you go I I
wan to get I want to get the players to
start beaing low so I started under nine
minutes starting a trend here Wesley
well this is going to be an exciting
game best of luck to both of you I'm
going to let you go prepare thank you
back to you guys wow Wesley's so
disappointed with his bed yeah you saw
it on his face at the end there he's
like why did I do that I think it's
because he won with the black pieces in
that second game he's feeling that
Rhythm but he did go under 9 minutes
which over the board is not a lot of
time yeah online which we have seen
throughout this entire season 8 minutes
57 would be a good bid but you saw the
immediate reaction I think uh sometimes
you make a move you realize it's a
blunder that's exactly what happened
with Wesley's H bit there did you think
Wesley just gave too much away with
Maxim he just looked so confident after
seeing that Wesley reaction yeah but as
James calls him Flex Le so I think that
Wesley he could be playing some tricks
himself I know he might be disappointed
but he also could be letting Maxim think
that's the case Wesley is a super quick
player he won the Fisher renom World
Championship we know that he has what it
takes to win the global Championship so
don't count Wesley out despite that
reaction I think he has very good
chances here and the Soul solid Wesley
needs only a draw with the black pieces
it is going to be an exciting one and
that's not the only Armageddon coming up
it is also the two youngsters who will
be taking it to the feier sudden death
nbec Abdus satov and Dennis lawick here
brought their
bids all right we're going to have
another Armageddon bid coming in here so
you guys I'm going to count to three and
when I hit three you guys turn your
boards towards the camera so here we go
one two three let's see the bids so I
have an order back 1058 for black and 10
minutes that means you're going to play
with the black pieces how do you feel
about winning the bid
Dennis I I don't
know we'll see we'll see we'll we see
and you go quite High there orderb so
you're happy with playing with the white
pieces yeah after yesterday uher
experience I I I choose to play with uh
with w wow another exciting Armageddon
coming up thank you guys for joining in
best of luck back to you
guys wow not a back alluding there to
his armagen against Magnus Carlson which
he did lose and he says he's happy with
the white pieces danis lawick 10 minutes
that's quite a smart big by the
17-year-old yeah it seemed like both
players are happy there because for
Dennis he bid low so he wanted black but
not says I actually wanted white heading
into this game he gets what he asked for
yeah so hard to pick a favorite both
players they've been kind of trading
blow for blow here and Dennis lazic if
he can maintain the level he's shown so
far today yeah I think he actually
choosing black there will be a master
stroke but the games are ready to go two
Armageddon we've got big action coming
up the players playing with the white
pieces have to win black gets resoled
odds and it is going to be handshakes
and we will be on
way here we go it's a porn push it's E4
from Abdu sattorov and wow G3 which has
really become fashionable today fuja
employing something very similar against
Nakamura earlier in the round and our
friend Daniel nitki often plays openings
like this online so you know when you
see this opening I think oh we're
playing online then I remember it's in
person and that's a different feel for
these positions you have to play quickly
and without any increment until move 60
these players have to move at a
lightning Pace especially those with the
black pieces but I think Dennis has done
a good job stabilizing defending his
Center there's no tension at the moment
I think that he's escaped the opening
and he should be on Happy Feet right now
yeah step one when you're black in an
Armageddon is don't react too slowly to
a surprise and clearly he cannot have
predicted this opening I don't think
I've ever seen Abdu satov employ this
opening before but Dennis lavic yeah
reacting instantly and continues to do
so brings his Bishop out now after a
trade of nights this is a pin and uh
yeah very solid position for black no
real weaknesses Dennis is the underdog
for NC he has to win this game he's got
to be the one feeling the pressure more
right now the pressure is definitely on
nck because I also feel like going
through those two games Dennis has
played the better between these two and
for nck everyone in this field is
looking at Dennis is that's the person
that I have to beat at minimum otherwise
there's no chance for me and Dennis is
like hey I'm a really strong Grand
Master look at my results over the board
in the world's rapid in Blitz a year ago
he plays the quiet move Rook B8
defending his Pawn not opening up the
full length of that light Square
diagonal the fian ketto bishop on G2
still has a ways to go I think he's
handled this perfectly thus far and
we'll see how Notre continues to press
yeah he's already eaten into that time
Advantage almost by a minute that aboro
started this game with still a very
level position actually a relatively
well-known type of position and uh we'll
check back in on this one later but
impressive start by lavic as he lashes
out with F5 not just content to play for
a draw playing active uh objectively
strong chess instead yeah all right this
one is going to be a fun fun battle
that's clear from the position that we
have and another fun Armageddon is on
Maxim vasher lra against Wesley so also
a non-standard outcome from the opening
and it is Maxim who has to win with the
white pieces Wesley needs only a draw
and what do we make of this position I
haven't seen this before chaos look at
the pawns both sides have six of them
but they're in different locations black
has B7 and C7 pawns white has those
Pawns in the center now you would think
that has to favor the player with
Central pawns we typically say control
the center but black will do that with
his minor pieces also the white King on
G1 without its faneto Bishop sitting in
front of it that can be dangerous so for
those of you thinking let me take that
Knight on C6 with my Bishop ruin Black's
Pawn structure think again you might
find your king in a world of her yeah
let's just show that Robert because it
looks like strategic Al you're winning
here this is just a horrible Pawn
structure uh for black but more
importantly it's all about this Square
Bishop will park itself there and
White's King I mean look at the white
pieces it's basically Fisher random
chess and uh uh you don't have any
activity at all yeah simply this would
be disastrous instead he pushes forward
E3 and he's going to try and build a
pawn center it's essentially uh these
middle pawns against the flank pawns
Black's pawns are maybe harder to push
uh personally I prefer White's chances
and still with a six-minute advantage on
the clock looks like a opening success
for Maxi Vash gra he's got a comp
position and uh Wesley still needs to
find some stability he moves his Knight
into the center asking for the pawn to
push forward to D4 with gain of time bit
odd that one I must say a bit mysterious
he's cleared his throat he said come
again I think that Wesley actually might
be in some semblance of I don't want to
say pure preparation but he has
understanding of this position because
95 is not a move you play I feel like
without a natural feel for the position
D4 is automatic but D4 doesn't actually
threaten the Knight on E5 there's a in
so will there he goes he pushes with C5
exploding that pin push your Pawn to D5
get a pass Pawn the center that's great
but you also hand me a pass Pawn along C
file and we saw Maxim in that first game
between the two use a pass C Pawn to his
uh success and we'll see if Wesley can
do the same and I'm just wondering did
Maxim forget about this idea of C5 or
that his Queen was pinned because
suddenly you've got questions to answer
you don't want to create a weakness in
the center of the board with the trades
that will happen on D4 Maxim does slow
down I'm still thinking about Wesley's
reaction at the start about his bid
starting with about 8 and a half minutes
but with the draw odds do you think he's
happy with the last few moves getting C5
in and feeling more pleased now the
Knight is attacked yeah I think Wesley
will be thrilled that he's trading off
pawns at least it's clearer what black
should be doing now uh the more pawns
pieces that disappear the clearer uh
Things become but yeah Maxim he did
react slightly I'm trying to read maybe
too much into the body language but uh
suddenly after C5 was played he's put
his hand on his face uh definitely a
missed one there and Wesley not actually
clarifying the tension in the center
first planting his Knight on a nice
Outpost threatening to remove white
start squ Bishop a very important piece
but not just threatening that if you
slide your Bishop back to the corner the
Knight goes to D2 with a fork of those
two Rooks I have not seen a tactic like
this at this early of a stage but Knight
D2 is a threat and I guess Maxim's
allowing can you take on D4 first and
then follow with Knight to D2 looks that
way why not this is a nasty Fork just to
highlight your point there Robert and
you're winning material he plays it this
must have been missed by Vash gra such a
rare pattern and you you see Max I mean
he hasn't reacted at all but I do think
he's flum mix he's like what just
happened here and now it's going to be
extra material for black a big blind
spot there a huge Miss Knight D2 coming
in um vesley about to win material
needing only a draw where does Maxim
finders Initiative for this exchange wow
it's crazy the evaluation bar is still
planted in the middle of the uh in the
center there still says 0.0 level but it
is onus on Maxi Vash gra burdens on him
to create some play he activates his
Rook very clever move and after Knight
takes Rook will he recapture no he hits
the black queen and suddenly a dilemma
for Wesley so what to do with the black
queen because you have to keep your
Bishop protected the black D Squared
Bishop as well slightly vulnerable and
Black's Knight is trapped you can take
that at will whenever convenient first
though you need to decide what to do
Maxim remember he needs to he cannot
just repeat with his rook and David that
was such a good option if you go Rook C5
black would have no option but to repeat
in this position but that just works to
Perfection for Wesley so Maxim has to
fight for more which means actually
getting into a worse position right now
the good news for Wesley I will excuse
me for maxim I will say the good news
for Wesley he's up material the good
news for maxim is that he has a lot of
pressure at least a lot of pieces aiming
towards that black king he can't afford
to make a draw that's the bad news but
that Bishop on D4 in particular if he
can aim at that G7 Square another time
he will have some chances and actually
evil bar still sitting in the middle
over here despite that extra material
for black yeah and uh okay Maxim needs
to find an attack first he hits that
black queen she is rather awkwardly
placed and a bit of indecision there for
the first time Wesley so and uh the
queen is dancing around finding a safe
Square for now because she is stared
down by White's light squared Bishop
White's Knight surely is going to move
in the next few turns you cannot right
now because Black's uh Queen is hitting
your dark Square Bishop in the center
the bishop
it's just hanging in the air for both
sides that pieces right now and a queen
A1 for white that speaks to me throw
that lady in the corner nobody puts baby
in the corner except for maxim when he's
aiming towards the black king on G8 and
that he plays it it looks really scary
all of a sudden because if I can steal
that pawn in front of your king I may
land a mating attack and if you push
your Pawn to F6 to blunt that diagonal I
might be sacrificing away you see the
evalar going up and up and I think that
Black's King is just devastated lacking
material in front of it and you maybe
the move order is something we can work
on but Maxim has the time to calculate
it Maxim VRA and his exchange sacrifice
I want to call it now and not a blunder
anymore with the way he's managed to
create play against black king the queen
and the bishop lined up a huge threat on
the board Wesley plays F6 this is a big
moment will we see Maxim go for the line
that you pointed out is he going to
sacrifice more material here it looks so
tempting either way there are options
here you don't need to sacrifice you can
keep the tension you can Retreat your
Bishop but uh there we go the we get a
helping hand from stockfish from the
computer just below at the bottom of our
screens that pawn to A4 gives white a
decisive advantage over plus two that
must be because the black queen she's
actually almost trapped it's the only
move that gives white the advantage
everything else is hovering towards the
middle but A4 the point is to kick the
queen away from its sights of that
Bishop on E5 because white would love
nothing more than to move the Knight and
expose the bishop on F1 to that Queen on
B5 but after A4 you force that Queen to
an awkward square and only then will you
move your knight it's such a big
opportunity huge moment here for maxim
rra he was the first to blunder but they
often say it's not the first mistake in
chess that often tells the tale it's who
makes the last one nicely put there
Robert and for maxim it is the moment
that you want to slow down and look at
your options it is without a doubt that
he's thinking about the sacrifice on F6
but black queen is ideally placed to
come to defense uh after Bishop takes
Pawn David I think you can just
recapture the bishop white jumps in with
the queen and Black's Queen will land on
F5 and it just feels that white will not
have enough power play he has gone for
it he's gone for it but as you say queen
to F5 holds everything together Maxim
missed a winning opportunity the black
queen was actually trapped uh that
variation pushing the pawn to A4 would
have won material but this one instead
allows the black queen to defend and I
think he's banking on Queen takes Pawn
here with an ongoing attack black king
is naked it's just forgot to get dressed
this morning it has no shelter around it
but black black is a whole Rook up and
should survive the black Bishop for
example can come into C3 and back to
defend so ma Maxim here he's bluffing 5
minutes on the clock for Wesley so if he
finds Bishop to C3 I think he's got an
advantage and he reached towards a piece
there which piece was he going for he
needs to slow down as well this is a
critical moment he needs to slow down
but I'm looking at his clock now dipping
under 5 minutes until he mov 27 so the
decisions don't look too easy even after
Bishop C great find great shout out by
you David uh that does shield the black
king but white has three pawns for the
sacrificed Rook there are four pawns on
the king side that Knight can come into
F4 Bishop to D3 things like that I just
feel like Wesley has a few things to
figure out and they're not always going
to be that easy yeah and Robert I'm
thinking about a tournament that you and
I called on the tataa steel chess India
where Maxim was down an entire Rook very
reminiscent of this one against vidit
Gujarati and he just created magic out
of nowhere an attack on his opponent's
king and that's what he's aiming for
right now if Wesley defends accurately
he's winning but how easy is it to
defend accurately in these kind of
positions with four minutes on the clock
and no increment he's such a good
Defender that's the thing Westley so
Wesley solid and look at this instantly
reacts to a tricky move Pawn to E4 was a
bit of a trap but uh the queen drops
back gaining time bullying away the
White Queen Queen exchange and it's game
over Black's extra Rook will count
suddenly Maxim has to retreat and as
soon as you start retreating you lose
all momentum lose all attack and Black's
Rook is actually going to come to the
eight trade-off White's active Rook I do
fear there are one or two traps but I do
fear for maxim if Wesley finds an
accurate uh kind of reply on just the
next two or three moves and in a way
there's something ironic about the fact
that the queen on H6 which looks
menacing in most attacking positions it
was actually kind of Trapped over there
and that's why Maxine played the move E4
so his Queen could slide back
unfortunately if he does slide back with
the queen as you mentioned the Rook can
come into play start offering some
trades and well the trade is now fully
offered that Bishop on F6 is loose so
wow look at Wesley he's like I got this
you take my Bishop I get a new Queen
thank you that's a good trade for me wow
he literally doesn't care about material
here uh suddenly is it level material on
the board but it's all about that a porn
as you mentioned Robert that uh
potential future Queen wow such a
practical decision there by Wesley saw
trading off giving back some material
but going into a safe end game and let's
not forget Wesley needs only a draw with
no attack against the king Maxim's only
hope is to start pushing the H Pawn as
quickly as he as as he can but it's also
the black a pawn that is about to
advance and it just feels like black
species will be able to stop the H Pawn
that Bishop from A2 can go back to G8
defending the 87 Square yeah we're going
to see this race and okay he drops back
attacking the white Rook instead the
black porn is now three squares away
from touchdown uh from promotion okay
what does white do does white try to pin
this bishop he needs to move his Rook
there we go landing on the f file a
threat white wants to play Bishop to C4
next move the black Bishop is pinned so
still not over still all three results
possible and look at West he slides his
King out of that pin now he's ready to
push his pawn and I think what white is
going to have to do is bring the Rook to
a passive square and sitting in front of
the passer and then there's a second one
that black will eventually push I just
think that Wesley has this one
completely under control I'm looking at
the move number 36 and he's got four
minutes on his clock and the position
actually is quite simple for him to play
yeah he's so good at just keeping things
simple keeping control uh kind of
minimizing tactics Wesley so there was
that mess for a while but sudden
suddenly as soon as he stabilized I mean
it's been straightforward and Rook to E7
that is calm I would have been just
itching to push the pawn throwing it
forward but why calculate when you can
uh stabilize like this and the problem
is Black's King is well within touching
distance of the White H Pawn no other
real counterplay did you see Wesley just
grab another piece he's doing that chess
player thing where you're nervously
fiddling with material but he's also
taking all the material he's up he's
like oh there's that Rook that you don't
have I've got two of those and let me
get a queen while we're at it because
I'm going to get a new one an H6 check
that's a single check his King is safely
tucked away in the corner now no
promotion for white but I do think that
there's one coming soon for black yeah
white Bishop just unable to join the
action he's basically playing without
that piece and um yeah Simple Plan for
black nothing to do for White and The
Time Advantage slipping away Wesley this
has been a master class just this uh
kind of defensive effort from him taking
the sting out of wh's wh's fun White's
play I wonder if the chess world has
made a mistake we know Magnus Carlson
the player in the world but maybe Wesley
so in Toronto is the best player in the
world he seems Unstoppable at this stage
and look at Maxim going for tactics and
Wesley says I'm not taking your free
pieces I'm just going to push this Pawn
to the other side but Wesley so
continues to thrive in Toronto there's
something about the Canadian Air that
makes him play his best possible chess
and also brings up the combative nature
that we often see dormant in him he
often is a bit more solid but now he's
spectacular wow look at the tricks from
Maxim V gra Bishop to A2 the bishop
still attacked but if you take it
there's a knight Fork White would land a
knight on G6 with a check and probably
still winning for black but uh at least
you have to think twice I think you can
do it I think you can take this bishop
he does it because at the end he's going
to play Bishop to B3 to block The Rook
the oh he goes to F7 I guess it's going
to be winning in this manner as well but
he also for you know to be fancy could
play Bishop B3 The Rook could not stop
the pass Pawn Yeah the A2 Pawn is coming
up anyway Wesley saw on the brink of
victory of this one still Maxim a very
very tricky player you've got to sort
these last minute problems the bishop is
attack can he actually ignore it can he
go for A2 or it's too dangerous you take
on F7 do you want to get into those
calculations Wesley slowing down he goes
for A2 who needs Bishop when you can get
a new Queen and uh Black's King can
survive all on its own a draw does favor
Wesley as well is he asking for the move
number because it's a 1 second increment
once the players reach move 60 and they
are allowed to ask the Arbiter West
calmly promotes to a queen I don't even
think he needs a move 60 here he's got
three minutes I'm surprised he's asking
about the move number uh even if there
weren't any increment I think he'd be
pretty confident of converting this
advantage and uh yeah what to play Queen
to E5 centralize what could be more
natural as long as you don't walk into
some kind of night Fork which happens
online all the time I think players they
see the board differently when they're
over the board here and he goes Rook E8
so centralization with the Rook instead
of the queen and here as long as he does
doesn't blund into a critical fork or a
Checkmate he can even make a draw at any
moment yeah and I think that was a
Checkmate if you go King to G5 you step
it up there is a pawn check a rook check
and so there are dangers with the rook
and Knight and Maxim continues to fight
yeah Knights are tricky and all the
pawns connect they defend each other o
bit of indecision there he drops his
Queen back and suddenly white can force
draw with just a bunch of Rook checks no
way to evade the Perpetual check
suddenly but that's good for Wesley and
that's the nature of Armageddon a draw
is a win for black so Wesley doesn't
need to end the game by delivering a
Checkmate he can end the game with the
draw and I think that white you know
Maxim knows that he has it but he can't
actually go for it because then he loses
the match anyway Maxim down a hole Queen
cannot go for a draw that is
heartbreaking and it almost feels that
Wesley set this position up he put that
Rook to E8 to take away all the Escape
squares of the king inviting
AET oh my goodness oh that would have
blundered and lost he walked into that
986 he was about to walk into it and
finds it at the last moment is Wesley
panicking what is happening right now
that was going to be an unbelievable
uncharacteristic blunder from Wesley so
now he can just do the repetition thing
but almost blundered a night Fork which
would have dropped his Queen and
dropping the queen for a knight in this
position whites up three pawns that
would have been an immediate win for
maxim he is human he does get nervous
Wesley so maybe he was just teasing his
opponent there he kept his hand on the
piece so the move was not completed he
was able to move it to a different
square if he had let go that would have
changed the game Maxim would have won on
the spot with a night Fork but wow what
a tense moment that was and uh he's back
to having things under control now he
gives a check from behind the white king
though marching up the board look at the
way Maxim just continues to play this
position he's down a queen and he's just
marched up the board with his own King
he's trying to set up some kind of
mating patterns dreaming for it and
Wesley just panicking he's so nervy
right now yeah but now he can just take
this Knight on F5 so he'll never get
checkmated and he can deliver a ton of
checks with his Queen so I feel like for
Wesley he's about to get checkmated if
that Knight goes to H6 right next to the
king that's actually a checkmating
pattern and he goes and gives a check
with his Queen so a good decision he has
many options here but I would probably
just snag that Knight with my rook and
then just try to make a draw after that
yeah he's still in control just get rid
of that Knight eradicate all Prospect of
a night Fork of a blunder and also look
at the counter move 60 they do gain
increment he's flexing here Flex liso
with the tactics you thought there was
another night Fork I did cuz there is a
night Fork night H6 check you might
think oh my gosh Wesley blundered his
Rook but the queen will sacrifice for
the Knight before The Rook wins the free
white rook and if you have to back up if
you're Maxim now it's at long last
Wesley is finally safe and it's the
white king that is going to be hunted
down the queen is coming on to G6 with a
check and another million checks to be
followed Wesley so he is very close to
wrapping this one up but just amazing
resistance and play by Max I never
thought I'd say this but it looks like
even at the very best at top level in
the chess well it's not easy to win a
queen up yeah I mean you can see how
experienced how practical uh Maxim is
with his play uh just posing problems
despite his lack of a queen but this one
ultimately should still be winning for
Wesley with the increment especially and
uh okay it go it goes on goes on David
just amazing he can jump in with the
queen a check to F2 but that just
invites White's King forward King G5
there are no checks yeah he's found a
formation a setup he's happy with Wesley
so why break from uh your comfort zone
the queen back forth back forth it's up
to White the pressure is on white here
to actually do something and it's just
impossible to do so unfortunately no way
forward it is heartbreaking for maxim
who really did try to do everything in
this game with white a must-win game
with white in the Armageddon and now it
is uh that is that looks like pretty
much about to be the end Maxim continues
to fight King to H4 no checks no checks
but I have a feeling someone's going to
blunder I mean we nearly saw it once
right but it feels so difficult for
black to blund this away unless you let
that g Pawn start running up the board
that Queen will always have checks to
deliver against the white king but now
if you check on F2 maybe the King goes
up to G5 and suddenly we're talking
about the makings of a checkmating net I
mean this is just unbelievable Wesley
still has over a minute on the clock and
he's getting increment all of a sudden
but it's just weird that this game
continues in a way that we're talking
about attacking chances for white I've
never seen anything like this I I mean a
knight a couple of pawns for a queen and
Maxim continues to fight he continues to
play on Wesley it just looks like he's
finding trying to find a way to just
finish the game on the spot to try to
find his draw but in the process he's
giving Maxim chances chances to improve
the position the pawn has moved up the
board the king is coming in now yeah
this really reminds me of game six of
That World Champ ship match between
Carson and Nomi apart from the fact
black has a rook for one of White's
pawns same material imbalance but
actually pieces they do fight and pawns
they do fight quite well against a queen
here White's King is surprisingly safe
but unfortunately no way to get to the
black king and Maxim keeps trying keeps
probing away a check the king side steps
getting nervous under control now maybe
Rook G8 is the move I would play because
I just want to deliver a Checkmate from
the black side the white king it's
trying to be used as a weapon with
limited mat here remaining whoa he gives
up his Rook cuz he's going to get the
Knight back that's actually very clever
I thought you know what is Wesley doing
but you could see the in that move he
grabbed that pawn and slammed it down ah
he knows now he knows psychologically
that's a killer blow a check the Knight
oh he doesn't even The
Rook wow a maxim continues to play but
now with the Rooks on the
board this is over this is over only
needing a draw uh it should be
straightforward now you can just give
all the checks in the world just don't
blunder a night Fork wh points will
never really push without okay that's
that's that dgt board just doing crazy
things to us and put the queen on a
square the Knight can take it but Wesley
he's not going to blunder the queen
Wesley can't believe that Maxim is still
playing that he hasn't resigned already
hey resignation is a loss getting checkm
as a loss so why resign you only have a
chance to take this match if you play on
oh my gosh on believable play by Maxum
there he is probably going to lose this
game but just full credit to the
Frenchman to fighting this out till the
very end and that is it Wesley saw does
it he finds the draw sacrifices the
queen and takes the match against the
Frenchman what an Armageddon what an
Armageddon so many twists and turns ups
and downs tactics Galore ultimately
Wesley just too solid and uh yeah having
black there he was able to take the arm
again but still one game ongoing between
Abdu satarov and lazic and Wesley so
checking that one out as well it's been
an end game in that one I've had my eye
on it I thought it's been a very
interesting situation where no deck has
had the advantage for a very long time
and now he is up a couple pawns but the
difficulty of this end game that we see
on screen here is that sometimes there's
actually when you have a bishop pawn and
a rook Pawn with the Rooks on the board
it could still be a draw but not now
because look at this Brilliance from nck
David youve made the video on him he
just is dominant in the end game so
strong in the end game there was a
Checkmate threat their Black's King cut
off another Checkmate threat if the
white Rook ever lands on A8 the problem
is you cannot fend this off you have to
allow a trade of Rooks if the black king
kept Marching In A handshake lavic does
resign Abdu satov too strong in that
Rook end game really really nice
technique there by nbec in the end using
tactics in The Rook Pawn ending to
simplify the position uh and nbec gets
moving on uh the leaderboard right there
with that win against Dennis lazovic two
really impressive Armageddon you have to
be heartbroken for Dennis lvic because
in this game he had opportunities to
survive and his three match losses have
all come down to almost individual moves
against Magnus that Rook end game he
slipped up in time travel against Wesley
he blundered a pawn in a position that
was quite level and then here against
narbeck okay was 60 plus moves into
armag again nerves are there but it's
been a case of one move itis for him in
this event wow yeah he's he's going to
learn so much though 17 years old it's
always just these Rook games just these
small details small margins as you
mentioned there Robert and uh he will
bounce back Laz he will uh he had he did
hold Magnus to a draw as well for Dennis
lazovic he goes down to Abdus satov in
the Armageddon and Wesley so after being
disappointed with his own bid takes it
takes it in the Armageddon against
maximan what an Armageddon that was aaya
is in Toronto with the winner Wesley
so Wesley so is here after such a
dramatic arm get on game congratulations
on winning the match Wesley yeah fual
yeah thank God all WIS come from him but
I it seems I I mean the last game went
very well but it seems that based on
history I just can't play chess against
Maxim well I I would disagree I don't
want to play him
again you might have to in the finals
actually yeah I hope I don't F him I
just have such a terrible result against
against Maxim like also in the grand
chest tour played and like in Norway he
beat me so it's just very very difficult
opponent I'm just so relieved to get out
of it alive well okay let's dig into the
armag get on here though maybe next time
like if I'm white and I play him I'll
just like make a draw in in five moves
or something you know well so first of
all you were you were regretting your
bit you went under 9 minutes for your
bid so you did have uh yeah yeah but it
worked very well because I didn't get
much problems from the opening like I I
was regretting it because I found out
what Maxim bid and so I should have bid
9 and a half minutes but it worked well
I was a bit surprised because hiar would
bid very low online but here everyone's
bidding super high so I'm like really
confused and then let's dig into the
armagedon game as well there were a ton
of Moments One Moment you touched your
queen you were about to move it into a
night Fork you were able to move it back
to a more sensible Square I mean take us
through that moment yeah that's really
crazy uh no actually I saw the night for
it's just you I'm giving him some false
hopes I wanted to move it to H7 but
somehow my hands sto on F7 of course I
saw the night Fork but I was like you
know trolling not trolling I would only
troll Anish but I was like duping Maxim
but I was thinking where to put H7 or C7
but it's really crazy because I thought
I played really well like I mix up the
opening so I wasn't sure what was
happening at all like was so complex but
I think I played very well defended that
maybe he had some chances like after I
played F6 I was really worried about A4
I wasn't sure if he saw that maybe
doesn't work I'm not sure but I thought
I played really well and uh just when I
was happy with my position I got my
queen I realized that I still have the
work for it wow Wesley and it is a great
start to the tournament now for you how
are you feeling perfect start yeah I
like like when I lost the white game
against Maxim I had literally sear hopes
to come back in the match and somehow
Miracle so thank Jesus and H another
match coming up today round four against
Ali Resa rja will we see some more Mind
Games there
then like you touch the C Pion you play
you play C6 and then you play C5 please
do that maybe when he plays E4 I'll go
like E6 and then move it E5 yeah like
what Mikel T against did against Bobby
Fisher like he played C6 and then he
went C5 and then he looked at
Bob just in a great mood here Westley
it's so good to see so what should we
expect from your final match here today
on day two in the finals well hopefully
I can play very well and not lose the
white pieces this time that was a big
that's a big
mistake well congratulations on a great
star Wesley and thank you for joining us
and so good to see you in a great mood
yeah for sure I mean uh probably lose to
Maxim like eight times out of 10 so
today is definitely special good day for
you so far thank you for joining us
Wesley he is just in a great mood
playing some Mind Games here Wesley so
back to you guys wow such a special day
for for Wesley right there mind games
from start to finish and what a time we
live in when the nicest guy on the
circuit starts trolling his opponents
Queen to F7 seeing that FK was never the
plan to fall into the blunder what's
going on is this where we start blaming
Anish Gir for getting all the top
players into their Twitter troll senses
but you Wesley it's good to see him that
relaxed because often times players can
they can just get this pressure on
themselves where they're just not
letting loose at all they feel like they
can't joke around but Wesley he's in
great spirits right now after being
disappointed in his initial bid yeah wow
Wesley so clearly in great spirits great
mood and playing some great chess David
yeah we saw Wesley's uh Victory there in
the Armageddon earlier but I wanted to
highlight a few key moments in the other
game that we didn't get to follow too
much between the two teenagers the two
youngsters Abdu satov and Dennis lazic
and it was a fascinating Rook end game
even end games can be full of tactics
and it was at this moment Abdu satov
pounced with a really nice trick he
played Pawn to E5 check with white being
a pawn up he threw one of the pawns away
because if King takes Pawn suddenly the
king is outside the box and no way to
catch this Runner the the white awn and
about to become a queen if the black
king tries to chase back it is just too
slow and White's Rook now can just move
out the way the queen will land next
turn instead Black's King did correctly
step to the side but if we fast forward
all the way to the end a nice couple of
tricks to finish this game white here
giving a check forcing the black king to
take this Pawn on A5 a nice drop back
threatening a Checkmate and when the
king marched forward another Checkmate
threat forced resignation the only way
to avoid this is to March forward with
the King but a rook trade would have
ended this battle and the white seor now
free to run beautiful T tactics
beautiful technique from Abdu satov who
took the win I think even more
impressive than the technique was the
speed with which he saw it you have made
that video on Abdu satarov and how
strong he is in the end game and he's
proving it time and time again and that
game is no exception there were some
mistakes there some slips it's the
nature of Armageddon where all is on the
line but he continues to impress and now
he's on the scoreboard with a legitimate
shot to make his way to at least the
survival stage it's been such a dramatic
day of Chess and the action continues as
we will be having round four including a
match up between Magnus gson and Hikaru
Nakamura coming up and Magnus has got to
be feeling good about his chess too as
Kaa caught up with him after his win
against
Fabby here with Magnus cson winning his
match against Fabiano caran first Magnus
a little bit of inside information here
you've been watching the Norwegian what
do we call it even soccer yeah
qualification for the first League so um
that was was a lot of fun and you're
happy with the result voring the and
Oslo team going down yeah uh I think
they will back stronger but um um yeah
it's always fun so happy that about that
happy about your match win with Fabiano
what happened there I think um I
probably well I I decided you know to
play somewhat unusual opening going for
a fight um and um I mean he was he was
for it so we had this really complicated
position where I gave up a pawn
initially for um some positional
compensation I suspect that I was I was
worse probably considerably worse uh for
a brief moment and then I at some point
I started to take over um I was down on
time but he didn't really find the plan
and suddenly you know everything was
working out for me he's been on fire
lately everyone talking about that so do
you get some extra Joy from winning a
match against
him yeah I mean I've played with him
many years so I don't think um I don't
like think he magically gets much better
or much worse in um in a few weeks span
and then he car Nakamura it's a big day
for you hiar nakamuro is coming up in
the next match what can we expect from
that one um I don't know I haven't
thought too much about it yet but um I I
mean I guess he won a fairly convincing
match now so at least is showing um
showing some signs of improvement thank
you for joining us Magnus good luck in
the next match thank you all right
Magnus Carlson getting ready for his
match against Hikaru
Nakamura and there isn't much time to
get ready as in just a few moments we
will have the first moves of this uh of
the next big Clash coming up against
Hikaru and this was these are the match
stats coming in against Fabby a almost a
93% accuracy by Magnus Carlson 90 % for
Fabiano Caro what stands out to you in
this one Robert well it's interesting
because there were no blunders but it
was consecutive moves where Fabby went
wrong he didn't drop a queen it wasn't
anything of that sort but he went in One
Direction and then immediately came back
so there was that indecision there
wasn't the cohesiveness of his pieces I
think Magnus play a better overall match
yeah Magnus his strategy was interesting
with white very solid with black
provocative he was basically saying come
at me and when he got his chance he
counterattacked it was really impressive
stuff from Magnus small margins at this
level of course both players kind of
avoiding those big mistakes but in the
end Magnus just too strong and this next
Clash against n Nakamura I'm expecting
more of the same it's going to be
decided by one or two moves here and
there it's about who's fastest who's
strongest who's sharpest and I cannot
wait likeu has made a bit of recovery
with that win against ala uh but David
you might need to make a little bit of
recovery as well I saw your reaction
with the whole Norwegian soccer league
Magnus was smiling you couldn't believe
it what happened where's the loyalty
from Magnus he used to play for voler
chess club and now he's supporting the
fact that voler football club have gone
down got
relegated it's my team as well I'm
disappointed say David was a little
heartbroken with that news but it is uh
back to chess as the next round four is
about to start and this is where we are
going into the final round of the day at
the top of the leaderboard no surprises
there it is world number one Magnus
Carlson with three wins and Wesley so
after a dramatic dramatic Armageddon
against Maxim vasher lra Fabby with two
points there Maxim Hikaru alira and nbec
get up on the leaderboard Dennis yet to
score what can we expect from this final
round of the day coming up you see how
tight the pack is with one point all
those players down there they have a
real shot of leap frogging others and
heading at minimum to the survival stage
so Magnus and Westley they're pretty
much in the clear they know at minimum
to make survival stage they want to keep
on going and get straight through the
semis but for those other players
including Dennis L he if he gets a match
Victory here he still has a shot too
yeah I'm expecting players to fight even
harder for their lives now as you
mentioned Rob it's so packed in the
middle I mean that match between Magnus
cars and Nakamura it's mouthwatering I'm
hoping for Armageddon somewhere if that
if not in that match I think elsewhere
we'll see them and that has guaranteed
enjoyment and excitement a lot uh so far
in the event expecting more of the same
it is indeed going to be a lot of
exciting chest coming up it is Magnus
taking on Fabby and not not just that
one we've also got alira who will be
fighting against the Wesley so and this
is also a really really big Clash Wesley
looking
Unstoppable right now ala's got to do
his best and we will be back with more
[Music]
chess I'm International Master Alex
banza and I'll be presenting you
silman's complete endgame course from
beginner to master besides what you will
see from Mr Silman I'm going to try to
do my best and share with you some of
the insights that uh I managed to steal
from my coach trust me you have never
really imagined something like this
could be compared to chess you will
notice that the difficulty of these
positions will kind of uh increase
exponentially as long as we uh progress
with the series let the games begin
Knight takes on A3 Bishop takes on A3
Knight B5 targeting your Bishop
targeting the pawn you have to keep the
bishop on the diagonal Knight takes on
C3 defending my Pawn Knight E2 but now
after the stunning Knight to B1
threatening Pawn to A3 Pawn to C3
threatening B2 threatening A2 there is
just no way to stop improve your end
games and start crashing your opponents
with this very evil play
[Music]
style Magnus Carlson was qualified for
this season's first event as the
reigning CCT champion and so he began
his journey with a Target on his back
Unstoppable from the start his dominance
has been
Undisputed winning half of the regular
events and sealing his spot in the tour
finals already in the air things Masters
that is beautiful tactical awareness
from Magnus Carlson he is really earning
this Championship it's over we have a
winner Magnus Carlson takes it he wins
the air things Monsters the check
meeting it's on the board Simon there we
go oh my God and we have a winner hnus
Carlson checkmates Wesley so and wins
the a chess
rapid L Queen on the board now is going
to win this game Magnus he's got it he's
got it in the end wow what a fight that
was amazing over Magnus Carlson he takes
it this is the winner of the Julius bear
generation Cup on his way Carlson has
played some epic matches and proved his
strategic Brilliance in the Armageddon
bidding Armageddon is coming up and
let's reveal the bids from Hikaru and
Magnus look at that Hikaru has been 8
minutes and 59 seconds beat by 1 second
Magnus Carlson bidding 8 minutes and 58
seconds oh no more
checks oh and what's happened there what
happened we see a reaction
Magnus oh no Magnus Mouse slipped
blundering into that Queen Magnus with
his unique ability to just have all his
pieces at the right squares to execute
an attack and finish the game I don't
know how he does it but it seems to
happen time and time
again when did the pineapple thing start
none of you fans get to see this this
was an awesome little streamer tutorial
here for any streamers looking to
improve their
setup this seems like a beautiful place
to set up the headquarters of the most
watched chest streams ever let's go see
how it happens hello hello is hikaro
here wrong
address
[Music]
just
kidding all right we're in we're here
with aaru and there he is there how's it
going Danny I was just in town wow
that's surprising yeah I guess but why
are you at my house I just wanted to see
where the uh where it all goes down yeah
well why not let's take a look at where
the magic happens man this is the uh
where the magic happens I've got my
camera on I've got my whole setup here
of course classic puzzle Rush everything
else I've never seen this shelf over
here this has not been opened it's a 4x4
Rubik's Cube I don't know who gifted it
to me I think my mom did or maybe my
brother did years ago um that of course
is a twitch plugin it lights up if you
plug it in I have this little Cube which
actually uh is from December 9th 1993
you can actually see right there so uh
it was actually carved I think by my
biological father and this of course is
my name so that's pretty cool pretty
cool stuff then of course we got this
nice controller to be used obviously and
anybody who streams has to be a game or
just be playing chess that's just not
fun this is ridiculous this shelf of
course is the uh special one this is the
one that everyone gets to see yes
exactly this has some pretty special
stuff first of all I have this Grand
chest tour thing which I won when I won
the Paris Grand Chester event in 2018
okay as is Valen care the the winner
this was a gift from the um from a fan I
think during the Fay candidas in U
Madrid someone bought me this like it's
like a hologram of uh of the stadium the
Real Madrid stadium kind of cool but
this is from the uh millionaire chest
2015 when ion oh my gosh yeah that's
epic that's a play button for my second
Channel more GM hikaro for 100,000 then
otherwise it's all you got a little
green pond here little chest. yes a
little chess.com Pond that nobody gets
to sees it's like the smallest thing
here the out of all the things kind of
kind of random yeah yeah this was
actually my parents bought this for me
in Hawaii I think last year just a nice
little Hawaiian pineapple trinket and
this I've never really used but that
actually lights up if you plug it in so
it's a big pineapple when did the
pineapple thing start chess teacher and
this guy comes with a pineapple shirt to
teach you a medal and he says yeah a GM
in chess I would say go back to bikini
bottom that started in the middle of
2020 during the pandemic specifically
there was a foron stream on Twitch where
his community made a joke out of me
watching it I was wearing actually this
pineapple shirt that I'm wearing now so
they started making the joke about the
pineapple man in the pineapple house
under the sea and it just stuck so I I
keep with it and also even beyond that I
mean pineapple I think is the main fruit
in Hawaii and I've gone there many many
times so we have a chess.com logo there
thank you thank you this is amazing well
and then we've got this angle here we're
not going to show anything incriminating
on screen there's there's nothing
incriminating I mean I can obviously
just show you guys go pretty
straightforward yeah so I was going to
like what I do normally is my setup is
pretty straightforward if I'm streaming
on Twitch I'll have the chat basically
popped out right up here extend this I
have my dashboard via streamlabs click
on recent events normally I'll have like
OBS open as well so I'll just have like
OBS just one second I have OBS over here
and then on this monitor is where I do
it so I guess just for fun we'll do one
let's do it I love one puzzle Rush see
how many I can get let's go check and
for the record I am standing in the fair
play cam position exactly none of you
fans get to see this except for when
Anish giri inappropriately leaks things
on Twitter we're going to talk to you
about that an um
but this is where the fair play cam
would sit right here looking at Hikaru
his Mouse his monitor so for anyone
who's ever wondering what it looks like
we got to keep watching him over here
he's crush he's crushing this puzzle
Rush all pretty good actually there we
go I I got to speed up though I'm a
little bit too slow right now should be
checking bishop4 takes oops oh that that
was a mouse flip because I I thought it
was going to play another move in the
puzzle oh darn I should have gotten 54
53 was pretty good though 53 was good
yeah that was pretty good I should
gotten 54 if I played Rook H1 quicker
but was pretty awesome and this was an
awesome little streamer tutorial here
for any streamers looking to improve
their setup exactly yes welcome to
hikaro world yeah and then I have my
drinks always which everyone always
everyone always sees my my glass and of
course my my coffee mug I i' I rotate a
few of these mugs but this is the one
I'm using right now so so fans watching
this video are lucky they've seen
everything now yeah yeah that's true yep
thanks for having me yeah no problem I I
hope you enjoy the tour and bye
everybody and car Nakamura streaming
cribs I don't know how to unlock door
hold on I have to get out of here okay
bye everybody thank you bye
[Music]
bye this is the 1hour chess lesson you
could take to make sure that you have
all the starting tips strategies and
basic understanding to really be
ready by owning the dile white can do
anything that he or she
wants if you don't understand what to do
here you might move the queen to safety
on C6 and immediately lose the first
lady to Bishop to
B5 King on the 6th Pawn on the fifth is
a winning King in Pawn ending where no
matter what black does we are going to
be able to bring a new Queen to the
[Music]
board you can also skip the parts that
maybe you already know how to move the
pieces or the language uh and jump in at
a level that's appropriate to
[Applause]
[Music]
you with chess kids new live classroom
feature coaches can do so much more
easily create or preload games from your
library and invite your class in seconds
teach face tof face interactive lessons
without having to leave the site
teaching chess online has never been
[Music]
easier it's round four of the 2023
Champions chess tour in Toronto and it's
the matchup that so many people have had
circled in our round robin stage that's
right you see him squaring off right
there it's AAR Nakamura versus Magnus
Carlson and it's coming up in just a
moment we are here back in the playing
Hall along along side James KY I am
Danny wrench and well let's before we
talk about the big matchup we see the
highest rated player in history already
sitting in his chair behind me let's
talk about what we just saw in round
three KY the result that stuck out to
you most that's a good one there oh
definitely that Armageddon at the end
wow that was crazy with Wesley so just
clinching that one that was very very
strong and it was also very crazy match
we all were out there just watching it
happen it's crazy it's funny cuz I agree
I think so kind of stole the drama
because he lost the first game comes
back to winning Armageddon but it's
funny hiara was so dominant that we
didn't even really have a chance to talk
about it right talk about a turnaround
from a birthday that didn't go his way
yesterday he takes down all the Reser
fuja by a score of 20 didn't even need
Armageddon to get it done and uh yeah I
mean that I guess it gets him poised as
we head into the next round abaturov one
in Armageddon as we already saw as well
but all right we uh we want to talk a
little we want to talk now about what
that means as far as where the players
sit in terms of standings you saw the
results you probably watched it live
let's be honest you've been here all day
you've got nothing better to do of
course Magnus Carlson and Wesley so are
tied at top the leaderboard have won all
three of their matches Fabiano now with
two after losing to Magnus Carlson you
see Notre baburov and Dennis lavic not
where they want to be if we ended the
round robin stage today the two youngest
players would indeed go
home so where does that put us well
we're back here uh in the studio I think
we're we're looking ahead a little bit
to this matchup that a lot of people
want to talk about Magnus Carlson and H
car nakam will be facing off yeah big
dogs going at it I mean of course like
when they're in good form especially
Magnus being the form that he he's in
Nakamura if it was yesterday it may have
been a different story just birthday not
working out but today's a new day he's
won his match today now he's got to face
Magnus yeah you got to face Magnus I
think if you're hikaro maybe you want
that in terms of building on a match you
just had with fuja right you might as
well give me the biggest dog here while
I'm feeling and see what can happen so I
can't wait to see it of course yesterday
on hikaru's birthday we premiered a
video where we gave Magnus some trivia
on hikara Nakamura to see how much he
knew a couple weeks earlier we actually
had a video released in terms of how
much Hikaru knew about Magnus and we're
going to replay that one for you right
now what better way to get you excited
about the matchup here than to remind
yourself of a video that broke the
internet a couple weeks ago just how
much does hikaro know about Magnus watch
this and find out let's see you ready
for some Magnus Carl trivia I'll do
pretty badly but sure let's go what is
Magnus Carlson's birthday his birthday
is November I believe November 30th it's
is it 208th or 30th I think it's the
30th it's November 30th yeah you know
the year well I'm 87 and he's part yeah
he's part of that next Generation so it
should be 1990 nailed it where was
Magnus Carlson born now this one is
tricky because I I get these cities
confused uh it's with a t but the
problem is in my mind I always want to
say it's Tron high but that's not the
right one it's a it's um it's tons right
it's tburg that's what it is there's a
lot of T tromo but you got a tburg but I
always confus that with Tron and
actually there's a picture of like the
hospital room on the Wikipedia P I
thought it was kind of strange there is
it's like there's a picture of like the
window or the hospital itself and I just
thought it was kind of weird that they
moralized that but anyway whatever
beside the point all right at what age
did Magnus Carlson become a Grandmaster
it's getting younger that should be it's
13 or 14 I'm pretty sure it was at 13
years old I don't I don't remember
exactly how many days correct 13 years
148 days
what is magnus's favorite opening move
in over theboard games I'm going to
assume it's E4 but I honestly don't know
correct he's played E4 762 times and D4
555 times okay on chess.com
specifically under his Magnus Carlson
account what is magnus's favorite
opening move for online what's his
favorite move uh it's probably not E4
I'm going to guess that it's um let me
think about this I'm going to guess it
is Knight F3 it's E4 it is E4 okay who
did Magnus play in his first fed World
Championship oh this I remember very
well th this was actually cuz magnus's
rise was very quick and I I remember
this very well he played I think he
played the World Cup and then he played
IC and those were two very very critical
moments for him in the World Cup I
remember was very well he played leavon
aronian in 2004 and in triple and I
remember this also because um like I was
playing the first round too against a
Russian player I won in won in like the
first two TI games but magnus's match
against leavon went very deep I think
went to like six games I think in the
tie break if I'm not mistaken um and
everyone was watching that match very
closely cuz leavon was considered one of
the big favorites to win the World Cup
so it was against leavon Aron triple
that was great we thought we were going
to get you with that trick question but
I remember that very well you nailed it
okay what do you Genny BV gakamsky
buhang XI and Yan shisto Duda all have
in common oh they've they've all um I'm
I think it's pretty obvious they've all
beaten Magnus in the World Cup nailed it
okay how many candidates Tournaments has
Magnus Carlson qualified for so it would
have been 9 11 13 so I'm going to guess
it's it's three it's my guess
four 2007 2011
2013 and then eventually 2024 oh so
you're counting this I wasn't sure
you're counting this one but that's the
part of the trick question right all
right let's see how many tries did it
take for Magnus to win the main event
not the blitz of Norway chess I feel he
didn't I feel like the first time he won
was actually a year that I was not there
for some reason so I'm going to guess
that it he played 13 14 15 I'm going to
guess that it was the fourth try of 2016
very good wow I was right yeah took his
fourth try
okay what happened first you playing a
classical game versus Magnus or him
winning the Norwegian Championship so
that that game and Bill would have been
July of 2005 so I'm going to I'm going
to assume that probably my game against
Magnus happened first correct okay
Magnus recently co-authored a chess book
who did he co-author it with and what is
the title I don't know the title but
it's it's a book with um it's a book
with like David Howell mhm grind like a
Grandmaster grind like a Grandmaster
okay one of magnus's first sponsors was
a clothing company what was that company
those are the very early days I remember
chess.com was at that event in New York
City um but yeah the company would be
gar raw nice which of these has Carlson
won five of classical World Champs Blitz
World Champs rapid World Champs uh
classical nailed it what is the name of
Magnus Carlson's twitch Channel and do
you know how to pronounce it I mean the
the name is well I mean I I know what
how you spell it I probably mispronounce
but I think it's masinis correct will we
see more from the ma maskinen uh Twitch
in the future well I have to say that
your um pronunciation is abysmo mosis
mosan
how I do mus yeah Magnus Carlson trivia
wrapped I obviously mispronounced
the it was really bad it was pretty bad
it was the first time saying it under
pressure but all right hi Caro answered
those questions pretty well under
pressure were you surprised by how much
he knows yeah actually he knew a lot but
I mean I see that with you know Magnus
did the same thing with iaro of like how
just how many questions they knew about
each other man it's really cool they're
uh they foes their Rivals they're
shaking hands behind as we know it and
we're going to we're going to dive in
now to really just get the hype going
right no more pleasantries no more
trivia about how much we know let's
check out this hype video if the fans
were not more ready could they get more
ready check out this hype video we
prepared for this particular matchup
when we knew it would come before we
dive into
predictions Magnus and I have been
around for a long time and I think
Magnus is clearly the best player who's
ever played chess hiar is obviously one
of the very best players in the world
certainly he has the best results he's
the highest rating in
history what is maybe the most
challenging about his style is his
resilience and also his ability to
calculate his end games are better than
anyone else in the world I don't think
it's even closed he does have a
psychological Edge as well like people
have to do something special to beat him
you know with Magnus will be a fo fought
game from start to
finish that's one of the challenges that
motivates me whenever I play him he is
the world champion he is the best player
in the world and I really do enjoy the
challenge I have beaten Magnus and I
think I have very good chances to win
there may come a time when I don't
consider myself the favorite for a
tournament but that time is left
[Music]
now we are ready we are getting set the
players are getting set and there's no
more waiting it's time for them to throw
down I think they're anxious and want us
out of here so let's just dive into it
KY it's Nakamura Carlson who you got got
to go my boy
all right it's gotaru I'll say Magnus
Carlson then wow this is a this is one
that I think I speak for every fan in
the world that I'm hoping it goes the
distance to Armageddon I'm going to take
Magnus in a closest of close matches
let's move on to mvl versus lvic who you
got mvl okay MVP MV yeah we'll agree MV
I'm also going to take Maxim obviously
it's it's a hard one here but I do agree
with Robert's comments that I feel like
lvic is this close to a breakthrough
despite the fact that I'm taking the
Frenchman so all right next matchup
we're moving on
Wesley so Ali RZA fua who we got here so
is just so solid right now he's playing
good great chess gotta go with so and
it's also in such a good mood you know
his face is just a big big smile so I
will say Wesley so I'm also going with
so uh and just double checking my
prediction I think I took so who did I
take I did take so sorry it's a long day
Levy's glasses getting to me I was
looking at Levy's prediction I think
Levy's prediction was going to be Peruan
but he's not here by the way we got two
pairs of glass today Inon of the second
day that has defeated Levy Levy we're
waiting for you and the glasses will
continue to mount until you're here but
all right we got we all got Wesley so
there I think unfortunately might be a
tough day for fuia if that holds up our
last matchup to predict Carana against
abduc Aura definely gotta go with Fabby
there big Fabby gotta go with fobs yeah
I will agree Fabiano carono okay it's
it's content ol Resa it's content I feel
so
bad
I'm sorry about that we we'll we'll
we'll we'll talk about it all right last
match up we have here is Abdus turov
Carana who' you take fobby Bobby I think
I also took Fabby there you go that's
what we got we got the games and they're
ready to start we're going to throw back
to the
studio and uh with it we have Oslo
waiting we have the studio ready to take
the games away let the content roll let
the commentary go Tanya and the guys
take it
away d you've got to watch out for your
predictions everyone can hear you at the
back and what's happening that's a lot
of fun and there's more fun coming up on
the chess board as in just a few moments
the players will be off and of course
our Mary match up Magnus Carlson taking
on Hikaru Nakamura that is going to be a
fun battle it's always fun when mags and
Hikaru playing I think Hikaru is going
to have a little bit more fun now that
he won his match earlier today uh but we
heard from the players themselves they
always have an epic rivalry but hikaro
believes in himself even though Magnus
has to be the favorite every time he
sits down on the board when you're about
to face Magnus beating Ali Resa the kind
of confidence boost you need that's a
decent warm-up I mean you need all the
confidence you can get when you play
these top players in the world and I
mean we've seen their battles throughout
the last year throughout the last two
years and it's always tiny margins so
close I'm expecting an Armageddon and oo
I'm expecting a lot of fireworks will we
have an Armageddon in this one on two
mini rapid Games first it is handshakes
and we're off we're off Magnus pushes
the pawn Hikaru does likewise I believe
that is D4 D5 and uh Queen's Gambit a
double Queen Gambit but hiar he's been
doing this right he's been playing some
offbeat openings he against Maxim vasra
chose a pet variation That You Don't See
very often so he car is showing I'm
going to think outside the box hope my
opponents can't prepare for me yeah this
one as you mentioned it's uh a bit rare
at the top level it had a bad reputation
years ago um it was thought that you
simply could not play copycat chess you
could not bring your queen out uh like
this so early but um yeah in recent
times computers make everything viable
and black does have a solid position the
idea is just to eliminate all of the
central pawns and get Symmetry and uh
yeah Nakamura looking confident yeah
looking really conf confident some Mind
Games there he plays Queen takes Pawn
immediately gets up and leaves the board
Magnus after a thing velops the other
Knight first defending the Central Pawn
he can delay taking it back because the
D4 Pawn is pinned so the knight from B1
can still jump on to C3 targeting that
Queen uh that's out quite early on in
the game yeah it seems like white can
gain another Tempo by playing this
Knight C3 move and I believe that Hikaru
he moves instantly he's analyzed that
with the center the C and D pawns
they're disappearing that maybe this
isn't actually that difficult to play
and perhaps white needs to find a fine
string of moves just to keep the
advantage otherwise we may see equality
yeah we see the evaluation bar slightly
on white side but nothing significant
and equality will be the name of the
game if white isn't energetic enough and
I think he's relying on surprise value
Hikaru Nakamura again getting up for the
second time within the first minute of
this of this game this Clash wow
impressive stuff he has landed the first
psychological blow against Magnus it
does look like AAR Nakamura has manage
to get that surprise in as Magnus slows
down and then Retreats with the Knight
continues to put pressure on the queen
traditional chess wisdom don't get your
queen out early on in the game because
it can be pursued by the pieces allowing
them to develop to the right squares and
we can also see Magnus now he has to
decide where to take out that light
Squad bishop and that's the next move uh
that is coming up yep he puts a Pawn on
e4 what could be more natural uh we
heard that uh that quiz with Dany and
Hikaru about Magnus he likes to put a PA
on e4 and move one he forgot to do it so
seven moves later better late than never
but occupying the center bringing the
light Square Bishop out as you say Tanya
and black has wasted three Tempe with
the queen is Magnus looking amused right
now with what's going on over the board
well Hikaru certainly isn't so I can
read his expression and this could be a
bad sign because sometimes players play
these offbeat openings there's not well
trodden territory and then when they're
out of preparation things can backfire
and hikara can't tell and I won't try
again because Danny already chastised me
is he thinking looking aside relying on
his preparation or is everything played
from this point on his own over theboard
findings he brings this KN out when in
doubt develop a piece um yeah I'm
intrigued I think we need Danny to tell
us what face number this is uh but
Magnus he will just get developed as
well normally when you're surprised you
don't want to take too many risks there
we go Bishop to E2 he'll get the white
king to safety next turn and um very
stable position for both sides
symmetrical Pawn structure the central
pawns have been traded off the players
continue develop and now very
symmetrical Pawn structure with that
last move black also aiming at
developing the dark Squad Bishop getting
the king to uh the castling safety but
it just feels as if white with that
extra move might be the one who makes
the jump first the Knight can land onto
D5 First Once of course you get your
king to safety and these positions are
not without poison there's always
chances for this position to change from
quiet to Tactical as you said a knight
D5 jump at any moment can be in the
cards for white and for Magnus these
little decisions that he's made he puts
Bishop on E2 rather than on C4 if this
bishop were on C4 right now it'd be a
more Dynamic aggressive position but I
think he's just going to get his King
castled and then try to figure out the
aftermath because for black where is
that dark squore Bishop going these are
not easy questions to answer and I feel
like both players they are now on their
own and it's about who plays the better
chess yeah I'm expecting Magnus to
Castle you don't want to dally with uh
too many tactics uh especially with your
king in the central of the board Maybe
is contemplating whether to put a bishop
on G5 as well trying to eliminate this
defender of the D5 Square then he has
full access to this Outpost in the
center but maybe Hikaru would do the
same maybe bishop out to B4 and yes it
might come at the cost of wrecking your
own Pawn structure but taking this
Knight off the board could be a priority
uh Magnus just weighing up whether to
get tactical whether to get spicy or to
just take the calm way out and Castle
his King when in doubt I think that
should be the default setting butar
looking confident still Barely Used any
time on the clock start for him yeah
Magnus has some very natural moves as
you see Castle King side first develop
your dark swore Bishop either all the
way to G5 or a little bit more quietly
on E3 Rook to C1 after so you have these
simple straightforward moves the
question really is how big will the
advantage be we see the Evo bar slightly
in White's favor as we all know from
experience that sometimes your slight
Advantage it dissipates in a hurry and
you're left with just pure equality yeah
that's why he's kind of highlighted this
he's identified this Magnus Carson as a
key moment despite how early it is in
the game because he knows he needs to be
accurate to pose any problems whatsoever
to a strong opponent like Hikaru if he's
too slow if he's lethargic about things
then it could fizzle very quickly he
does Castle and how will Hikaru react I
think the speed of this next move will
kind of show us how confident he is and
how deep he is in his preparation he's
already there he plays Bishop to E6 this
shows that he still is within his
preparation uh because his King remains
in the center he's not castling at least
not yet and here comes Knight D5 so now
we're going to have some fireworks there
might be some pins there will be some
options for both sides but it is getting
spicier as Hikaru frowns looks off to
the side I'm not sure what face number
that one is but he's surprised confused
by magnus's
choice wow this one is heating up with a
night jump Magnus getting that one in
and now we are going to see some
structural changes of course we will
come back to our Marquee match up as we
see head in hand Hikaru has his first
think but another board where think is
perhaps required is Fabiana Karana with
the black pieces taking on nbec Abdu
satov and my guess David would be that
this came out of uh the Spanish and that
strange Rook that was on A2 perhaps the
light Square Bishops got traded there
maybe we can back up take it from the
start and then do a deep dive into this
position yeah you're right uh you called
it correctly there Tanya the opening was
a royal Lopez or Spanish and uh it did
begin with E4 E5 and this variation uh
with the bishop coming out and getting
kicked back and uh let's just fast
forward to one of the critical moments
you mentioned the white Rook on A2 it
became a bit of an odd piece in this
position after black developed to E6
still welln well-known territory
well-known opening Theory but now after
Bishop takes Bishop the rook recaptures
and it is left on a vulnerable square
and we'll see how that plays into uh
proceedings later on the knights simply
retreated and black broke out with D5
and this isn't the most uh kind of
popular move as far as I'm aware I
haven't looked at this for a while but
uh it did turn out well for Fabiano
because suddenly the White Knight gets
kicked around look at these black pawns
really strong in the center and not just
that but after the Knight Retreats Queen
to D5 a Tempo gaining move hitting the
Rook defending the center to me in the
current position if we catch up Fabiano
looks in control simply with black
already I would say Advantage black just
due to how much space you have how
strong these pawns are but look at nb's
last move Rook coming to C1 he says your
Center looks very good but I'm about to
strike with C4 Dynamite move move myself
hitting your queen gaining some space
and opening up the queen side here the
E5 Pawn is a bit tender sometimes in
these positions your best option would
be can I actually push my Pawn backwards
one scare put it back to F6 to protect
that pawn E5 a Pawn's best friend is
another Pawn we love our Pawn chains but
I think that right now it is not re who
trying to break free from the chains and
throw those pawns C4 and cause chaos
yeah I'm still liking Black's position
here it just looks like there's so much
Harmony in Black's pieces you
centralized everything gained space in
the center I hear you Robert C4 is uh
always in the air creating problems for
black but just with the peace activity
even a move like retreating with the
bishop to d8 and I'm scared how the
evalar might react to it but Bishop d8
it doesn't love it but it just feels as
if you've got your own pawns uh moving
forward and the Rooks are nicely placed
on the central lines yeah I think black
is uh at some uh well urgency needs to
put the king in the corner as well there
might be some tactics I'm liking
Robert's idea for example uh if Bishop
d8 Pawn to C4 um of course black
shouldn't get too greedy here but if you
do take this Pawn for a second time
suddenly Queen to B3 would be a deadly
pin on the diagonal not just that but
Black's Knights are so loose along the
SE file that something will drop off for
example if you drop back a simple Queen
trade and the Knight on C6 is undefended
so there are some tactics um I like your
idea Tanya moving the bishop out of the
way protecting this Pawn with your Rook
but uh maybe first you Shuffle the king
into the corner or or other moves
dealing with with this semi- threat of
Pawn to C4 would love to get E4 in but
it just looks like white might be the
one getting C4 in before black gets that
Central break and Fabby he slows down
the clocks are leveling out this whole
Rook maneuver that we saw by nbec first
The Rook goes to A2 recaptures the
bishop then comes back to A1 then to C1
with this idea that's some high class
chess right there yeah it's rerouting a
piece it may take some time but he
understands that black cannot crash
through the center yet and I just want
to note that not not he does pretty well
against Fabiano especially online notb
he qualified for these finals by winning
the chess kid Cup who did he beat in the
final none other than Fabiano caruana so
their head-to-head is quite combative
these are two of the most determined
fighting players in the entire chess
circuit no debeck despite being just a
teenager he's shown that he can keep
Pace with some of the best Veterans of
the game yeah and uh I do actually like
his approach despite the fact originally
kind of optically it looks great for
black white is provoking the opponent
forward he's trying to probe for
weaknesses later on Fabby maybe
overextended and Fighting Chess you
mentioned it Robert um Abu satov just
always fighting always provoking um also
did he uh did he take down Fabby when he
won the 2021 World Championship um
either way he's got yeah just this
fantastic style and um so great to watch
this one is guaranteed to be a proper
fight right now and uh okay he's in the
tank Fabiano he realizes now that C4
massive massive idea hard to stop and
it's so strange because visually this
position looks like a beautiful outcome
uh for the black pieces out of the
Spanish right you've got so much control
and peace Harmony but very often it's so
Concrete in chess and now with modern
chess especially C4 is a big threat
using the tactics and fabby's taken
about what it's been a almost a four
minute think looks can be deceiving he
has all of these pawns centralized on
his own fourth the fifth ranked of the
board but then when you push your pawns
sometimes they go a little bit too far
they're overextended and it's easier for
your opponent to land a counter punch
and that C4 move is really available
because black has thrown that pawn up to
B5 the E5 Pawn needs the Queen's defense
it just seems like white is about to
have some fun it's a bit of retaliation
but it's coming at the exact needed
moment yeah and Fabiana continues to
freeze 4 and a half minutes now he needs
to speed up it's one of those positions
where actually the critical moments will
also be ahead so uh at some point you
need to decide just drop the queen back
drop your knight into D4 move the black
bishop move the king into the corner
something but you need to uh decide fast
make a move Fabby this is just way too
long and what you just pointed out is
opening success by Wyatt making Fabby
think at this moment when many critical
decisions lie ahead of him it's uh it is
success to get an opponent like Faby
who's so well prepared to let him burn
the clock right now and I'm getting
worried he's touching the five he's
crossed five minutes just over this
position one can feel that Fab is
feeling the pressure on this one another
player and he finally does make a
decision it's not the king uh move to h8
but another quiet move to H6 we will
come back to uh the N back board but
another player who is perhaps feeling a
little bit of uh the pressure and the
heat Wesley so take a look at that ala
with the black pieces he's going all out
he's got his pieces forward but is this
Brave or stupid what is happening here
my French is far from perfect but I'm
getting some Deja Vu here from the
French number one Ali of fuja he's
thrown a knight on F4 he completely
blitzed Fabiano car's queen king side
yesterday and that was a peace sacrifice
nothing has been sacrificed thus far
Black's pieces look like they're
storming around the white king in
particular that pawn on G5 which can be
joined by another Pawn if the H Pawn
decides to go up the board but this is
again one of these positions where you
have to be super precise because one
inaccurate move suddenly white regains
his footing and then it's black who
might be on the back foot yeah this King
could be very just very very weak uh if
you aren't able to play energetically if
for example this beautiful Knight on F4
gets traded off just as I say it the
king moves I'm expecting the black queen
to land on this uh promising this
flexible F6 square and your idea Robert
I think he might even back it up by a
rook sliding uh and some point later on
and white needs counterplay white is
really stuck this Bish G3 is especially
bad if you have a take this KN uh I
think black could actually take either
way but uh even with a G pawn and later
you have the semi-open G file to play
with and white has to contort uh rotate
the Knight back to E1 this is odd odd
stuff I was going to say you should
break in the center you should push a
pawn to D4 but where is this Knight
going this is mysterious I don't care
what the Valar is I'm loving what alira
has done here with the black pieces you
know it's his King on the king side but
he's gone 86 G5 he's making his
intentions very clear he's playing for
for the attack the you're pointing out
for the queen queen coming to F6 H5 H4
ideas opening of the hline the Knight is
already on F4 um Wesley cannot be too
happy and it is good advice there David
that when your opponent is playing on
the flank with that idea you want to try
to open the center it looks like that is
the only break that Wesley has I'm
taking black in this one well it's also
a break that Ali Raza has he brought his
King up he escapes a pin that pawn on F7
was previously pinned now he can thrust
his own Pawn forward opening up The Rook
staring down towards the white king so
this is going to be a messy situation
Wesley he's typically prefer solid play
we saw what happened in game one against
Maxim vashir lra Maxim brought the
action to him Wesley was not able to
withstand the pressure Aliza he's
playing in a similar way yeah Messi and
that suits ala's style Wesley wants the
control of course Wesley can do anything
he navigated that Armageddon very well
against Maxim Vash de gra earlier today
but um yeah this exact position I think
he won't won't be feeling too
comfortable right now I think we're
going to see H5 on the board um it feels
like such a natural followup and so much
uh up Ali rzza style of play and it is
on the board really nice plan there H4
you really want to force White's Bishop
to take the decision to trade on F4 so
that the G Line opens up uh vesley he
can't be too happy with the way things
have turned out with the white pieces
here yeah H4 for the score it's coming
and Wesley needs to do something he
pushes a pawn to F3 kicking back Black's
Bishop at least some breathing space for
his own Bishop that dark Square Bishop
on G3 but yeah these exchanges these
potential trades of minor pieces do not
help white whatsoever totally different
position but it sort of reminds me of
his game against Dennis lazic from
yesterday where Wesley he ended up
winning that game but early on it looked
like Dennis was having all the fun with
pressure down the king side maybe
Wesley's saying I have the pair of
Bishops for now one may get traded I
still have one remaining this Knight on
C2 after Rook e w it may go to E3 and
watch out for Knight F5 or D5 so there
are some holes in Black's position and
Wesley he is down a little bit of time
but he's starting to speed up because
he's found himself a plan I just loved
Wesley's interview earlier it was just
the Joy on his face just the the
Innocence the way he's loving chess
right now it's just seems to have freed
him up to place just fantastic chess and
he's playing fantastic chess here
despite the fact he's on the defensive
he's playing calmly he's just retreating
his Rook creating squares for his KN
everything's flowing and uh this is the
Wes Wesley we know and love yeah three
match victories Wesley's got reasons to
be pleased with his play so far in
Toronto perhaps becoming his favorite
City to play chess in so rookie one he's
trying to activate his Knight Ali Resa
making his intentions very clear he
wants to go for uh the white king if
black was to push that pawn forward
Bishop retreating back to F2 trying to
keep the files closed on the king side I
think you can you can get away with it
retreating isn't always a bad thing to
do um you know taking on a four it looks
like it's playing into Black's hand G
takes F4 opening up that g file it just
seems too risky so that was why Wesley
played KN back D1 Pawn F3 he wanted to
vacate that square and that diagonal so
the bishop could Retreat and yeah he
then can control even more squares when
the Knight comes in E3 you're you're
just completely handling white the light
squares over there on the center on the
king side yeah I don't know if you
should push for fua but if not that then
what else suddenly uh the moves that
were so natural so obvious so temp in uh
he's going to be pausing he's he's
certainly hesitating right now I'm not
sure how to build up the question is
whether to take this bishop it looks
like you ruin White's Pawn structure but
then Robert's Point these light squares
suddenly juicy White's Knight is coming
in yes you can put a Black Knight on E7
passively to kind of block the white
Knights advance but I'm not sure that's
something you really want to rush into
and uh therefore fua pausing for the
first time in a long time since we
actually jumped into this game and uh
yeah the more I look at it the more I
think this is just chances for both
sides it's becoming a position that
first looked Dynamic now is looking
strategic which is Wesley's Forte so
Wesley is handling is very well no
surprise given his three out of three
start he is playing Amazing chess in
Toronto year after year this seems to be
his City his type of tournament and in
match play in only two games you can't
afford to make any misstep especially in
a position like this yeah and I think uh
that's the whole point Wesley needs to
be so precise here it's hard to bet
against Wesley these days with the chest
that he's showing but again I really
like what Ali RZA has done his uh his
creativity attack I would take black
here he's managed to make his chances on
the board it's the kind of position he
likes to play but he's going down on the
clock right now so Ali Rea we are
waiting for uh his uh decision playing
aggressive playing Brave right
now what are you what are you predicting
in this one do you think this matchup
given their Clash of styles there's a
chance this goes into Armageddon or do
you think it will be decided with
decisive games in the
rapid tough to predict I'm going to say
it's going to be decis uh decisive
actually even just this game uh just
because the way fuia has started the way
he's kind of set out his stall and said
I'm going to attack uh no real way back
from there but um you never know it's
early days and they're both extremely
strong of course both on form today yeah
well while Ali RAR has a think on how to
continue this attack that he's created
and he just as I was about to say he
does make a move H4 is on the board we
will jump in we saw Wesley move back
with the bishop so the G file remains
blocked in that one let's head back to
our Marquee match up Magnus Carlson also
reaching out to make a move on his board
I see that's a retreating one Hikaru
with the think here he was the one who
surprised Magnus early on in the opening
what is uh the current position uh David
well first of all I'm looking at
magnus's pieces and nearly none of them
have crossed his uh first rank it look
again it looks like Fisher random chess
and wow tactics from Hikaru not winning
nothing too spectacular just a double
attack on the White Queen White now has
to move uh her majesty there Black's
Rook on the dile attacking the White
Queen Black's Knight attacking the queen
and uh I think the idea from Hikaru is
just very simply to trade off White's
light squar Bishop o the board tested us
teas us there the queen did land on a
safe Square on F3 and Knight takes
Bishop would guide the game towards
equality just too sterile here total
symmetry I typically don't like calling
a game a draw you say level even just
one of those words this looks very very
draw there are only five PS per side
equal material no weaknesses to speak of
so Magnus he looks displeased it was a
shady opening from hikaro perhaps one he
won't use again just because if your
opponent's ready for it they may be able
to take advantage but this is completely
equal there's really not much to speak
of about the position itself it's just
completely dead yeah a picture paints a
thousand words and look at Magnus on the
camera there does not look too excited
tooo interested in this position um he
knows this one with high likelihood is
going to be a draw uh Hikaru just great
opening preparation he's neutralized
Magnus osly here yeah and we saw the
same narrative in magnus's game against
Fabby in round three starting with the
white pieces Magnus really did not get
anything out of the opening Fabby
neutralized all pressure and it looks
like hikaru's managed to do that as well
getting that early early surprise in
with his opening approach it has worked
to Perfection uh and we will move on to
the world number two from World number
one to world number two natural
progression there Fabby starts with the
black pieces wow that looks like deep
deep pressure on the black king
especially with that last move that has
arri that has just arrived on the board
H5 shattering down Black's kingside Pawn
structure look at the eval bar is Fabby
in big trouble yeah look at the death St
that Abdu satoro was giving Fabiano a
minute a moment ago as well he's
actually down a pawn here with white but
it is that on the black king black is
simply overextended Black's pieces are
loose Black's Queen slightly vulnerable
Black's Knight on C6 undefended Black's
Rooks don't coordinate and yeah those
kingside pawns he's allowing them to be
fractured kind of broken here but he's
just trying to defend with his Rooks
he's got double the amount of time on
the clock as well Robert yeah the second
game in a row where we look at Fabiano's
pieces and they're all scattered across
the board which is not typical of a
Fabian Carana game and wow that is a
very surprising move to me from nck
abatar who is super confident playing
quickly but trading Queens when the
black king looks like it's in danger
that may let Fabby off the hook white
remains with the advantage it's easier
to play but black is a pawn ahead in the
current position so if one Pawn Falls
maybe even two it might only be a one
Pawn lead for white and that gives
drawing chances yeah he's banking on a
favorable end game here but maybe he
should have been playing for checkmate
or playing for uh kind of higher
purposes there let's just show what's
likely to happen this last Bishop
Retreat just to highlight some
Alternatives he could have maybe moved
the queen out the way for example lining
up some discovered attacks against the
black queen but now the Queens have been
traded Bishop to A1 forces that to
happen and now the pressure on this
undefended Knight that we mentioned
earlier does force Fabiano to give up
this E5 Pawn no way to defend it if you
move the Knight backwards this would be
disastrous white could for example take
on E5 with a knight maybe even with the
bishop and Black's position collapses
attack against The Rook against the
bishop and the C7 seven Pawn falling
Fabiano drops his Knight into D4 giving
up the pawn on his terms giving back the
pawn I should say and this position
still Advantage white look at those weak
pawns on the queen side and on the king
side too in a moment actually all four
pawns for black will be isolated and uh
big Advantage but not much material
remaining that is the one major downside
is now Fabi to worry about his King
getting checkmated and if he can keep
initiating some trades that does
increase his chances to survive yeah so
Fabiano Maybe breathing a s relief but
not out of the woods yet objectively
still a Advantage for Abdu satov he just
needs to make the time Advantage count
now Rook F7 I would just take that pawn
take on G6 break the structure and then
think later it does look very very
pleasant for white any a player would
prefer to have the white pieces in this
position but I just feel like with for
Fabiano it was the right thing to do at
that moment give back the pawn in the
center now try to trade as much as
possible and that could put some fear
into notbe who knows he's better he like
can I really keep trading even if I win
a pawn a rook endgame a pawn up that may
not be winning so I'm liking the
position I love the way that nck plays
chess but it's critical for him to keep
it up right now keep that pressure going
against fabbi he's got a great position
but will it be enough and we just as
we're moving away we saw a trade that
Robert takes you by surprise some really
surprising decisions there by nck in a
better position trading off the queen
trading off that strong Bishop when
there was no rush to do that we will
check check in and see on that end game
but there is no end game on this one as
uh the attack does continue and Ali are
asking more questions forcing Wesley now
to take a decision you really don't want
to fix the center with white right if
you go D5 you give black a free hand on
the king side to continue with the
attack but is there an alternative well
I'm also knowing the A5 Pawn that one is
loose so for Wesley he can play D5 or
Pawn takes C5 first which is what I
would go for and and then maybe just
steal the A5 Pawn black is hoping for
counterplay thanks to some control the
light squares the dark Square Bishop for
white oh and we got a queen sack for two
Rooks the engine saying that maybe black
is doing okay here David take it away
what's going on yeah it's a hard one to
evaluate two Rooks do mathematically
outow a queen and if white gets time to
bring the second Rook into the game kind
of team up with the two Rooks white of
course will be better that's what
Wesley's banking on but maybe there's an
attack some counterplay against the
white king later on I'm looking for
example if black just waits as soon as
the white Rook moves I'm looking at
checks there might be this nasty check
on E2 and uh the Black Knight Will plant
itself on a nice blocking Square on D4
watch out for H3 coming watch out for G4
or F5 blowing open the king side later
instead Alara plays Queen to B6 a double
attack another one maybe W Wesley had
missed Robert I just want to backtrack
and ask what was the downside why could
he not have just snagged a pawn for free
it looks like he could have taken that
pawn without really huge risk maybe he
was worried about some of the Knight D3
ideas or something of that nature but
that's really a one move threat and it
actually doesn't threaten anything
because the Rook on d8 is also loose so
it's a a bit of a strange decision
coming from Wesley so who worked his way
out of some initial danger into a
positionally healthy position and now
he's like oh wait a second tactics once
more my rook's hanging my pawns hanging
knight2 check at some moment Pawn to H3
for black all these different ideas are
in the air and I'm starting to like
other Ra's position more and more yeah
and with giving up that Queen for two
Rooks the last thing you want to do is
get into a passive position trying to
defend the B2 Pawn you don't want to
come back with that Rook on d8 to D2 it
just allows black extra tempos to get
the queen in and Meanwhile we're getting
our first result Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura as predicted ended in a draw uh
this game just heating up Wesley attacks
the Knight ala steps back with the King
wow this one is definitely getting spicy
and I want to give a shout out to Dennis
lvic who secured a draw with the black
pieces against Maxim vasher lra so
Dennis continues to impress I know he's
got zero match points on the scoreboard
but he has held his own against some of
the best players in the world a
17-year-old continues to impress yeah he
hasn't lost uh two Z to anyone so far
he's been very close just small margins
uh great result there with black I mean
against vashy lra that's a fantastic
result he's one of the best with white
these days and G3 provokes a decision
from the Black Knight or do you
Counterattack do you hit the white Rook
I mean I'm looking where to jump I want
to plant that black knight into the D4
square but there will be tactics if you
Retreat and uh I think actually a bit of
a trap from Wesley so he's relying on a
trick uh the most natural move to me
would be to drop the Knight back and to
bring it into D4 but Rook takes E7 would
set up a nasty night Fork that's been
the theme of the day all these nasty
night forks and this is a royal Fork of
course of king and queen so uh what else
to do
uh maybe even in this position there are
tactics after Rook takes C7 I realized
Knight to D4 would actually threaten the
F3 pawn and this is one to calculate but
if in doubt maybe you flick in a check
and take this bishop and uh the game
goes on that's what he's going for these
tricky tricky nights and uh what to do
now you can take this bishop take this
pawn it is chaotic well the chaos in
this one continues we will check in uh
what happens here in just a moment but
first let's take a look at this one
because Fabby is in trouble as NC's
Rooks are sweeping the pawns that black
has on the sixth rank but Fabby going
for counterplay on the G line is this
closer to a NB back win or a draw look
at the clock Fabiano under 10 seconds
with that in mind I think it's going to
be a win for white two protected uh pass
pawns as well connected pass pawns on
the queen side if somehow he can trade
off one set of Rooks it's game over
that's Abdu soro's goal right now he can
take another Pawn on H5 two pawns up and
Fab's trying to get a Counterattack he's
is using his Rook that's in front of the
white king trying to bring the other
Rook down but the problem is Fab's own
King is very exposed so there could be a
ladder Checkmate where the Rook on A6
cuts that King off you see it won't get
access to go up the board and so if the
second Rook slides on over to the queen
side maybe we will see a latter
Checkmate so I don't believe in Fab's
chances here and it's going to be a
shame for him but no de Beck he's earned
this point if he's able to get it yeah
fantastic play so far by nbec can he put
the finishing touches to this end game
and he go with the idea that Robert you
were pointing out sliding The Rook to C5
so that if the black Rook jumps in
there's a check on C7 followed by a mate
on A8 so Fabby forced to keep one of his
Rooks on the seventh rank defense let's
just show that idea if Fabian had
brought his Rook down it looks like
severe counterplay but a check and this
is the Checkmate that everyone needs to
know uh Rook end game 101 this is a
checkmating pattern the latter ladder
Checkmate even and uh the lawnmower
Checkmate sometimes but Fabiano he's
just stuck what to do white can simply
just push these pawns forward now this
black Rook is stuck stuck defending the
seventh rank zero counter playay this
should be a win and ample time 3 minutes
left Abu satoro big favorite to take
this Fabby with just 7 seconds on the
clock in a position that looks close to
losing right now it's the only thing
that he can rely on is trying to get
counterplay with those two Rooks somehow
getting them either to double up on the
G file or The Rook jumping onto the
second rank is there any hope for Faby
to put pressure on that G2 Pawn here I
don't think there's any realistic hope
as long as dorov doesn't panic um he's
trying to force the issue potentially
but okay he drops back with his Rook
still same idea persists you cannot move
the Rook from D7 but the white king does
get checked around a bit and uh still
yet to decide upon a winning plan clever
play by Fabiano here because he wants to
deliver a check but even better play
from nybeck a check the King goes up you
are allowing that latter Checkmate but
now with the King sliding over to H7
there won't be the same ladder check
because the black Rook can backtrack and
stop it but two extra pawns or two extra
pawns but he does have a threat he wants
to either give a check from the second
rank or double up on the G file so
putting pressure on G2 and nag doesn't
have the time just yet to start
advancing the queenside pawns yeah not
quite yet but if he removes the black F
Pawn from the board then he can always
uh bully the bully Carana here with the
the uh thought of a trade of one set of
Rooks if one set of Rooks comes off it's
just game over Black's King is so far
away the white pawns will simply advance
but okay count at least one small threat
maybe takes Pawn Che you really don't
want to lose the A3 Pawn because two on
none that's a very clear win but one on
zero and one on zero on separate sides
of the board kind of got a split like in
bowling and that may not be the best for
notb winning chances and you can see him
he seems shaky and the eval bar also
shaking but it's going back down towards
the center yeah the nerves are jangling
here Fabiano going for this type of idea
potentially you could imagine the black
Rook on G7 somehow landing on the first
rank again another L Checkmate uh
suddenly C play the A3 porn attack he's
retreating going passive suddenly big
threats on the board Rook to C1 it's not
Checkmate yet white can block but it's
certainly in the air the momentum has
certainly turned Fabby getting his
chances with just seconds on the clock
not back he needs to slow down right now
he's got about a minute and a half and
he needs to use that time uh judiciously
to try to find the right way forward and
I think he's done just that freeing up
his King from that last rank yeah was
there's a couple checks for black but as
you say Rook F2 was such a great
defensive try yeah just getting the
white king breaking it out of jail out
of prison there and again just just
floating this idea of a rook trade but
still some work to be done Black's King
isn't quite checkmated both Kings
actually in a bit of trouble in this end
game but uh yeah still some work to do
to convert this Advantage maybe the
white king should go up to H3 you slide
The Rook behind the king he goes to H2
instead but he's just going to bring one
Rook to the G file now the F2 Rook over
and try to Rook H3 but look at Fabby
he's being clever he's saying please
bring your Rook on over to G2 because if
you do that I force a rook trade but I
win one your pawns and that may give him
chances to survive tricky Fabby with
that last move Rook to C4 threatening a
check on the hline so still not giving
nbak the position that he's aiming for
nbak is trying to trade off a pair of
Rooks keeping both pawns alive if he
achieves that it's game over Fabby has
to get counterplay with both these Rooks
on the board he's visibly nervous though
nck he's got over a minute why is he
behaving like this he was fiddling with
a piece he's kind of panicking every
move and yeah he's repeated the position
now this is the second time we've seen
this he cannot give another check and uh
yeah he feels like he's just yet to find
the plan and Fabby defending so
tenaciously here threatening some checks
from behind now far from over this one I
think King H3 I think if now is the time
he brings his Rook to E3 instead the
eval bar is going right back towards the
center and the black king this is a
checkmating net if he did not check the
king back black would have had a
Checkmate by Forest let's just show that
there was a massive threat on the board
if White had been careless and for
example pushed his B Pawn forward what
could be more natural push past pawns
check check and mate this white king
could have been caught watch out for
this theme to persist um yeah this
recurring idea of checking the white
king is causing him real issues right
now abov and he looks nervous he's
fiddling with the pieces he's getting
low on the clock he still is ahead on
time but Fabiano's task is easier
because even if both players think that
white is winning winning a one position
they say is the hardest thing to do in
chess and Fabby keeps bringing the king
forward trying to get white in that
mating net and not back he's shaking his
head he knows that he hasn't been able
to find a way to free up his pieces or
trade those Rooks he hasn't made any
progress meanwhile Fab he is putting on
great resistance and we might see a
three time repetition if n brings that
Rook back we have seen that position
numerous times at this stage but now the
white a porn is suddenly hanging there's
still some threats of checks
kind wow Fabby he repeats and I think
Fabby is he about he almost I think he
was about to claim could he have claims
but this is the big difference between
online and iners OTB events it doesn't
automatically get a draw you have to
make the claim it's tough when you're
not taking notation down uh the Arbiters
will step in if it happens enough times
but right now Notre he's seems like he's
lost his entire Advantage look at the
Evo bar it's at zeros which means that
it might be now a three-time repetition
yeah those threats of those checkmating
and threats against the white pawns
combined just too much white cannot fend
off both of those ideas and I did check
I don't think it was a three move
repetition so it's a good call not to
claim there Fabiano but uh he's
defending he's focusing on those moves
and playing Perfect Defense here amazing
amazing resistance here by fabibi
playing for that piece activity the king
participating in it and nbak just unable
to make progress with two extra pawns
and it's something all the players
compliment and Magnus about how
resilient he is that he doesn't lose
when he even should be lost and Fab's
doing much the same he's improving his
defensive tenacity his resourcefulness
and right now he just keeps chasing the
white Rook yeah what to do with white
now he's really in danger of repeating
the position all these checks won't help
the black king will not get checkmated
on its own there it can defend itself
and okay he moves across suddenly there
are checks o the white king in a bit of
danger suddenly Fabby gives one of those
checks where are you hiding you can't go
to the Third rank you've got to keep
that A3 Pawn defended and it's going to
fall you just give a check on D1 pick up
the Rook pick up the pawn but he might
think that his King is close enough and
the black king might be cut off so is
this a theoretical draw that's the
essential question both players just
like the audience don't have that answer
in front of them so Rook takes Rook King
takes rook and Rook takes Pawn on the
flank Pawn with check the white king
slides up diagonally and the black king
is it close enough I think it does get
back in time Fabian is calculating that
right now yeah I just checked he cannot
take the The Rook he cannot he will get
cut off across the board and uh we'll
show this later on unless it happens on
the board right now he doesn't trade
Rooks he saves himself Fabby that was a
trap Abdu satoro looked a bit
disappointed there that it didn't happen
but now a bunch more checks Fabby still
extremely active I think this was a good
practical decision keeping the tension
because Abdu stov still cannot make
progress incredible Precision there by
Fabby and he's getting the extra seconds
on the clock as the position gets
repeated and look at not he's trying to
set up ladder checkm ideas his the black
king is cut off along the fourth rank
he's going put his own Rook on the fifth
rank but Faby continue to check this
King the white king does not have much
shelter so check check check check where
is that King running to and if you trade
Rooks too far away from those queenside
pawns then black will happily happily
pick up the A3 Pawn he's driving the
king forward but the king can hide in
front of its own Rook here okay it keeps
marching up the board and the white Rook
will Zoom behind to block it on F4 but
it's almost Checkmate that second Rook
the black rook in the corner when that
slides over to give a check only that
white Rook on the H4 Square can block
that check otherwise it would be made
the black king almost checkmated as well
the black king barely with any squares
look at it getting chased back now this
is surely winning Fabiano he's blundered
he's allowing a rook trade even
Checkmate and game over oh my God that
was a mid at the very end what a game
what a peace play there by both nck and
Fabiano Carana but nck comes back on top
takes that end game incredible
resistance but not a backck incredible P
play by him as well persistence trumped
resistance there nck he never lets up
not for a single moment and he should be
feeling good about himself today he beat
Dennis lazic in the round three match up
earlier now he takes game one against
favano that was Stellar stuff and that
was the only decisive game of round of
game one of round four nbec Abdu satov
takes down the world number two
meanwhile alira fuja with attacking play
Brave play but Wesley so keeping it so
solid that ended in a draw and Dennis
lazovic Maxim VRA great result for the
17-year-old also a draw and of course
the Mari matchup ended peacefully and
Kaa spoke to Magnus Carlson after that
draw in the Norwegian interview uh a
little bit surprised out of the opening
here with hiar and also some thoughts
about a queen sacrifice in this game
yeah there were several there were
several points where I could actually
think about sacrificing the queen and I
very much wanted to um but I didn't get
the chance really yeah so obviously it
was a surprise to see him play this this
line and um I mean I've played it like a
couple of times as black so I know a
little bit about it but not too much
detail so I was just trying to play
something you know with common sense and
um then yeah I just missed his move
Bishop to B4 later um I was going to
just capture on e4 earlier and thought
that was slightly better but um yeah the
way the way it went I had no chances I
mean I was probably even like very
slightly worse so for out to draw is
okay so what will you expect in game two
when he comes at you with the white
pieces
it's very hard to say sometimes in these
situations he just likes to try and
force the draw other times he's um you
know trying to give you best his best
punch it's hard to predict it's uh been
some epic Armageddon battles and bidding
with Hikaru throughout the season do you
really want to avoid Armageddon with him
or do you think U that would be a cool
thing um no I wouldn't I mean playing
Black in the second game without lead uh
it's hard to be too unsatisfied if it
comes to armagedon but you know I'm
prepared for um whatever like you know
he he tries and and then we'll then
we'll see if I have to play armagon and
then that's okay thank you for joining
us myness best of luck in next one thank
you that's Magnus Carlson let's see what
happens in game two the ball is in
Hikaru nakamura's court with the white
pieces will he get ambitious or will he
take this match into Armageddon we will
find out but what a round one we've had
David some big moments big end games
what's stood out to you yeah I just want
to highlight that key moment in the only
decisive game of uh that round it was
where Fabiano could have saved the draw
he defended so tenaciously he gave a
check he gave another check and actually
when the king marched back he did avoid
the Trap of taking this Rook because in
this position uh very instructively uh
the white king marches forward and the
black king gets driven uh away white is
indeed winning this end game but uh
instead he could have simply repeated
why did he come back to G1 that is the
mystery he could have just given checks
forever and would have secured the draw
Fabiano in the end did go down to defeat
but he was so close and Abdus took the
win it is so difficult to also just keep
the resistance going amazing pressure
there put by the usbek Phenom nck takes
the win which means that Karana has to
win on demand to take it to armag big
big game two is coming up and another
player who was very impressive in game
one or round two was a 17-year-old
Dennis lazic holding the former World
Blitz Champion to a draw they'll be
battling it out in the action coming up
in just a few moments from Toronto don't
go
[Music]
anywhere I can guarantee that working
your way through this course and solving
all 1,1 exercises will reward you not
only with a greater tactical knowledge
but also with spotting more tactics in
your own games my name is FES dantony
and I'm a woman International master I
wish you a warm welcome to the chorus
101 chess exercises for beginners
authored by Franco mazetti and Roberto
Messa with videos by me in this case the
Knight on C5 is not protected and so the
winning move is G6 G6 is the discovered
attack but it is also a double attack
because not only are we hitting the
Knight on C5 we are also threatening
mate on H7 in this case Rook C7 black
has no choice but to capture and now our
Queen comes in we've lured the queen
away now the king is too far removed it
cannot protect the black queen so we are
going to pick up the black queen on the
next
[Music]
move
any good chess tactics book has one
pattern in it that feels like it is on a
completely different level than all of
the other tactical patterns bearing the
Vivid and accurate moniker the windmill
this pattern features an amazing
sequence of repeated discovered checks
that can be used to win a nearly
unlimited amount of material the most
famous windmill is definitely the one
played by Mexican prodigy Carlos té
against former world champion Emanuel
Lasker but Bobby Fisher's game of the
century also features a windmill here's
another one that I really like white
starts with a rook sacrifice that leads
to a combination of Bishop and Rook
checks that simply consume Black's
forces the lefong is a dirty dirty trick
that will probably only work at bullet
but you have to pull it off at least
once in your life when you sense that
your opponent is pre-moving G6 and
Bishop G7 to start the game you can play
D4 and Bishop H6 to try to win the
bishop on G7 shakes guys no one is
watching
oh they all missed that I see the Tilt I
can feel the
Tilt it is a high risk and high W
strategy because you are hanging your
own Bishop if you don't catch them in a
pre-move but it is certainly hilarious
when you do pull it off like one of my
friends alos he made a um bot the report
was B partly based on hyper bullet games
so then you can see a lot of the Leong
and queen C2 takes H7 and so on
[Music]
so
it doesn't look like much much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
I am beyond excited to announce on
February 23rd through 25th we will be
hosting the first ever chess.com
Invitational presented by Discraft at
the famed course in Brooksville Florida
we will will be kicking off this year's
disc golf pro tour in style with not
only incredible disc golf but many more
activities there will be a one-of-a-kind
chess disc golf crossover you won't want
to miss as well as an exclusive
chess.com
fanzone I personally couldn't be more
pumped to bring epic disc golf
competition and fun hope to see you all
[Music]
there don't miss out on Twitch drops
during the CCT finals watch four
cumulative offs of Chess on chess 24 or
chess channels and unlock a free 14 days
of diamond membership on chess.com
connect to your accounts at go.
chess.com connect to redeem and enjoy
two weeks of Premium features and right
now it's time to enjoy the over the bo
action coming in from Toronto as we are
about to kick off game two of round four
in just a few moments it's already been
an incredibly dramatic day of chess can
we expect some more Armageddon coming in
oh I definitely think so we had a
decisive game there at the end between
Noir Beck up duar and five Carana but
Magnus Carlson AAR Nakamura I think that
one is definitely going to Armageddon
we'd love to see that one go all the way
David into the Armageddon yeah I want to
see a fight in the game first but I
wouldn't complain about Armageddon it's
going to get faster more Furious and
yeah whoever gets black that one I think
would be the favorite they're just
looking solid right now and Hikaru is
really pucked up today he's looked so
much better than he did yesterday uh
that first day blues and yeah it's hard
to predict that one suddenly I think
Dennis lvic he gets the white pieces
against Maxim Vash lra and in that first
game a solid draw with black white in
game two I don't think he's taking too
much risk he's a very solid repertoire I
think we'll see him in Armageddon once
more oh that's going to be amazing as
well and Dennis he's been having these
great games against the very best in the
world he hasn't managed to get up on the
leaderboard but that hasn't been
reflective of his quality of Chess here
yeah the zero doesn't tell the full
story he's been very accurate he's that
type of player and he could beat Maxim
if Maxim gives him the
chance the action is about to get
started we're going to go into our
playing Arena as we see the players are
ready to go and to start some more chest
wow no handshakes there yeah I think
they must have shaken hands beforehand
just uh before the game started when
they sat down uh no animaly a lot of
mutual respect of course but D4 and
Magnus thinking he does play his Knight
out to F6 his trademark move and Bishop
to G5 for trpovski just as Nakamura was
displaying yesterday he ventured this on
several turns Magnus must have prepared
what's so interesting about this is the
openings that hikaro have been playing
they're usually for surprise value but
when you play them over and over again
there's no longer the surprise yeah
shows his faith shows his confidence in
these openings and Magnus does does play
something slightly unorthodox there
usually in that that exact position
black recaptures with the G Pawn towards
the center I think usually in chess the
default setting is towards the center uh
unless you're kind of aiming to open up
pieces trying to accelerate your
development now Black's D5 Pawn is going
to be eternally a Target so Magnus has
to compensate with active pieces and I
must say bizarre that Magnus is the
first one to really think especially as
you say Robert that this is no longer a
surprise weapon from Hikaru and Magnus
just made the Big Choice he is the one
who captured away from the center this
kind of resembles some lines in the
Dutch defense he does defend that D5
Pawn his Knight on B8 can develop next
the dark score Bishop is already
protecting the C5 pawn and perhaps
Magnus wanted to avoid the territory
that Maxim vasher lra got himself into
because Hikaru showed he has very deep
preparation in some of these lines and
Hikaru had some deep preparation in game
one of this match as well as Magnus
himself admitted that he was taken by
surprise and felt the pressure can
Hikaru continue with that uh he takes
out the knight in front of the king it
will eventually land on F4 trying to put
more pressure on that D5 Pawn the
development continues are we expecting
White's Knight to land on F4 quite
possibly if not now then in the near
future first he might decide to Fan
ketto his Bishop white light squ Bishop
is stuck there we go who pushes the pawn
creating a nice beautiful home for it on
the G2 Square again peering at that
weakness the target the D5 Pawn for
black and uh Hikaru if gets two more
moves if he gets his Bishop there uh on
G2 gets castled I think he's going to be
loving his position longterm
strategically very strong for white
better Pawn structure and targets
especially if the center is closed
Knights will Thrive rather than Bishop
so Magnus needs to play energetically
and uh creatively here to hold the
balance and once again it is uh Magnus
who goes into a bit of think in this
position how can he try to play
energetically in this position does he
start attacking Hikaru Center take out
the queen to B6 Target the B2 Pawn not
give white the enough time and Tempo to
put pressure on the D5 Pawn I can tell
you what I wouldn't do if I were Magnus
I wouldn't close the center by pushing
the C5 Pawn because that feels like it
leaves the D5 Pawn as a long-term
weakness he starts by taking on D4 that
makes a lot of sense to me it opens up
his Bishop on f8 gives it full scope of
the diagonal maybe out to B4 to pin that
Knight his Queen can go out to B6 that's
one of the benefits of pushing your C
Pawn so early in a sicilian or in this
type of game the can venture out putting
pressure on B2 and the white Central
Pawn on D4 so I like the way that both
players are handling it thus far I think
it's early stages but for Hikaru he's
the one now taking a think here clearly
both players are on their own yeah if he
takes with a knight it does look nice
for white long term but short term I
think black has enough counterplay this
is a big big weakness in the center of
course isolated Pawn iqp uh here but
Bishop to B4 as Robert also mentioned uh
you hinted at this one and unfortunately
why isn't quite in time okay he's
actually played this but why isn't in
time here to put enough pressure on this
isolated Queen pawn and Magnus blitzing
down this road it does feel that Magnus
maybe was in preparation just took a
while to uh kind of familiarize himself
remind himself of what he had planned
and Bishop takes night is actually a big
strategic threat long-term white would
be suffering with a broken structure
there so maybe you need to defend this
Knight with your queen maybe you step
back with your fellow Knight but you're
losing time uh you're not playing Happy
moves here you need your king to get to
safety but Magnus en
really nicely handled by Magnus Carlson
and a non-standard pawn structure out of
the opening but he doesn't give Hikaru
the chance to get the ideal development
structure he does move ahead with the
queen so keeping the pawn structure
intact in any reality does white go
alongside
Castle maybe only if you're feeling
super Brave maybe Reckless um I've got
to say yeah the sea file it just looks
too dangerous right now and uh yeah just
while this position settles down I do
like the quality of uh black pieces I
don't like the quality of the D Pawn
though the pawn structure uh but the air
quality there looking Fair looking fair
and uh I think this position is fairly
balanced right now uh just level chances
and it is about who uh feels more
comfortable uh out there in Toronto in
this Arena feels like both players just
again probing testing each other and I
like the fact that we're guaranteed a
fight in this game uh no peace treaty uh
in sight anytime soon yeah because it
when he wants a draw he forces it he
plays openings that require repetition
we've seen these two have various
repetitions like uh in the Berlin is
what hiar usually does against Wesley
and some D4 lines against Magnus but
here we have a fight we have a pin along
the B4 Bishop down to the King on E1
with the queen in between them so I like
the position that we have it seems like
we could get quite some rich play but
will hiar learn a lesson that Fabiano
might have taught him that Fabiano
played on maybe a little bit too far and
then Magnus was able to seek control of
that position yeah talking of trying to
kind of just maintain control trying to
uh kind of kill the fun for black here
how do we achieve that do we test uh
magnus's intentions with the dart squar
Bishop do we just rush to get castled
with the white king probably on the king
side I think Tanya at this point it's
probably just a distant dream castling
on the long side castling Queen side
right now we were talking about the SE
file The Rook has already landed on that
the long castle with uh be hard to
imagine as a possibility but black he's
already threatening Magnus is already
threatening to jump ahead with the
Knight targeting White's Queen side
while Hikaru takes a think about how he
wants to get those pieces developed and
how he wants to get his King to safety
let's head over to another juicy match
up Wesley so with the black pieces the
man in formed the man to beat is playing
against Ali rzza feruza and regardless
of how the tournament goes we know Ali
Resa he always plays aggressive Dynamic
chess and what is that Rook doing on e4
yeah wow this is Juicy alera has already
sacrificed a pawn he's fighting against
the Berlin War the Berlin defense
normally one of the most Rock Solid
openings for black but he's thrown a
porn away and he's saying I've got
active pieces you mentioned that Rook on
e4 Tanya it looks weird it has just
landed there uh that white Rook has uh
yeah maybe aggressive intentions in mind
but I don't really see the the
compensation right now maybe it's just
in the fact that black cannot quite
fight for the center yet looks Dynamic
right that this Pawn on D4 was threaten
that's why the Rook came up to E4 that
Knight on C3 for white will jump forward
into the position putting pressure on
that Bishop on F6 so all of a sudden we
see where White's pieces are going
should black just develop with that
Bishop on C8 to B7 it will stare through
the Knight towards that Rook on e4 the
B5 Pawn is loose can that be captured
they're difficult questions to answer
and you know both players they are
trying to evaluate this position yeah
how to evaluate it it's the hardest
thing Tanya and I'm trying to evaluate
how we even got here uh David you got to
do an action replay of how this opening
went because to me I'm I'm struggling I
get that this is perhaps coming out of a
Spanish what happened in the opening
here yeah as I mentioned it's the Berlin
defense so after E4 E5 the knight's
coming out Bishop to B5 this is the
Spanish the Roy Lopez white puts
pressure on this Knight the Black Knight
comes out white just castles allowing a
pawn to be grabbed and here after Pawn
to D4 night back we normally see the
Berlin endgame after a trade on C6 pawns
coming off and queens coming off as well
this is well known well explored it's
actually happened in this tournament
already in the last game between Maxim
vasra and Dennis lazic but here fua
surprised his opponent weso by dropping
back simply saying I'm going to be a
pawn down I don't care uh White is ahead
in development and the black king is
slightly vulnerable but uh here white
simply pushing forward with C3 and this
is crazy stuff Robert he offered another
Pawn right he could have captured on C3
but that would give white such a rapid
lead in development and ala fuja during
the canis he play against Daniel nitzki
in this really long bullet marathon when
maybe some said he should have been
preparing for his game da plays this
style from the white side so maybe he's
picked something up from Daniel neski
learning from the best ala F there and
uh yeah this second Pawn should not be
captured it was not captured black
prioritized development and if we catch
up with the current position B5 is a
very clever move uh this is recommended
in various sources uh you need to
activate your pieces black Knight's in
the way of the deep Pawn so you need to
activate your Bishop on the long
diagonal
wow after Bishop to B7 uh in the game
position we were talking about some
x-ray vision here on the white Rook the
white Rook simply s stepped Robert
attacking this night ambitious play do
you think this is preparation for malara
it feels like it because who puts their
Rook on F4 rather than say a bishop if
not being well prepared in this line but
I like this for white I think that
Wesley right now can bring his C6 Knight
back to E7 to open up the scope of his
Bishop on B7 but we're getting into
territory that is about to get very
complicated 97 has just been played
white is down a pawn so do you think
David that he's got enough compensation
for it the evaluation Bar says yes so
I'll say yes but this is not what I
would be risking as you say I mean who
puts a rook on F4 uh definitely not me I
would never dream of such a creative
idea but this is why Aliza is such a
strong Dynamic attacking player I have a
feeling uh just trying to get into his
mind right now he wants to play the move
Pawn to D5 blocking out this bishop you
need to play against your opponent's
pieces here who cares if you're a pawn
down actually the lack of a Pawn on C2
means you do have a nice Square for your
Bishop to retreat to later on a
beautiful diagonal if you can line up
the bishop on C2 the queen on D3 along
this diagonal later on but first it
makes sense to block out this bishop and
maybe actually this comes with a threat
of Knight to E4 and this black Bishop is
slightly trapped if you can take it you
would wreck Black's Pawn structure so
I'm going to say it's growing on me
White's position the compensation is
there certainly I'm really liking what
alz has done here playing for the ini
initiative down upon bit a critical
moment right now the idea that David
pointed out will put big questions to
Wesley to handle the threats on the
pieces that are quite clamped on the
king side for black right now we will
check in with Ali Resa how he proves his
compensation another very uh interesting
game that is developing is Fabiano
Carana against nbec now fabii has the
white pieces he needs to win this to
force it to armagen NC is lead leading
the match with that first round Marathon
victory that he had and the position up
front I see that Valar says it's level
white does have the bishop air but to me
it just feels like black pieces are more
active the queen and the bishop lined up
on the diagonal the Knight on G4 all of
them eyeing F2 the Knight on D4 doesn't
look very stable there is a threat to
actually pick up that pawn on the next
move I see the bishop pair but I'm
liking Black's piece activity here
agreed I couldn't have put it better
myself Tanya just every piece is active
for black who cares about the bishop
pair even if it's an open position as
long as the rest of your pieces are
playing a part and yeah it's difficult
Fabby is going to be in the back of his
mind he needs a win so he will be taking
risks and okay he does kick the Knight
back out I'm assuming it drops back into
the center uh to E5 but yeah no issues
here for ab stov but considering how
quickly n plays in more complicated
positions that Knight if I'm not
mistaken has no other moves right that
Knight is under attack it can't go
forward so Knight E5 is the only option
so what is he thinking about here very
good question okay eventually he dropped
his Knight back maybe he was trying to
peer into the future and uh work out
whether now he can go for that idea
Tanya mentioned of taking a pawn taking
this Knight I was going to say Rook
takes PA now does look Frau with danger
you would be walking into a pin trying
to do some quick calculation I don't
think you should I don't think you can
get away with taking this pawn and if
that's the case then now I like the
bishop pair because it's two Bishops
against two knights the D4 Pawn can be
blockaded so what Aon nimzovich always
taught everybody is that if there's an
iqp and I said que Pawn you want to
blockate it with a knight so it can
never push forward and that is what he
has available to him he goes the other
direction Knight to G6 similar idea just
get the Knight out of danger block with
the piece on D5 but as David you were
pointing out the brook takes D4 a move
ago that was not a free Pawn in fact it
handed white a free Advantage yeah this
would have been disastrous for black two
pieces vulnerable on the diagonal so uh
very level position but Bishops versus
Knights is about who Maneuvers those
minor pieces better in this ensuing
middle game speaking of maneuvering
perhaps NC's Knight can also maneuver
from f8 to E6 putting more pressure on
the weak D4 Pawn that we're looking at
right now this one is going to be quite
a long long fight and we will check back
in with it meanwhile also developments
happening on our Maki matchup Hikaru
Nakamura with the white pieces against
Magnus Carlson the first game did end in
a draw speaking of the bishop it looks
like Magnus is the one who's got the
bishop a the pawn structure as we see uh
was uh was shattered out of the opening
but in compensation there we see the
bishop how much does that count right
now it counts for a lot I also think we
don't want to read too much into the
body language at least in a typical game
this is not a typical game it's Magnus
versus yaru and Magnus before he looked
like he was upright just hunched over
the board think yeah my position looks
good and hiar is deep in thought I like
Black's position you have this bishop
hair and the center you have great files
for your Rooks the queen on B6 is on a a
nice Square as well I don't see how
white builds up the pressure and black
Magnus he plays A5 he may even throw
away that pawn jettison it with A4 to
try to get his pawns U into territory
where they can't be counted on the C and
D files yeah I fully agree certain
positions uh like the one we mentioned
earlier it's unclear with how strong the
bishop pair can be but right now the
Bishops are complimented by some very
strong Pawns in the center uh for black
and there was a small trap in the
position that we can maybe highlight and
wow Magnus going for it right now trying
to open lines for his Bishops uh first
he pushed this Pawn to A5 and I just
want to mention this Pawn was poisoned
do not take it you walk into a horrible
horrible uh double attack here after
Queen takes uh recaptures the bishop
suddenly a hit on this rook in the
corner and a hit on the queen this is
why Hikaru actually preemptively shifted
his Rook from the corner over to B1
instead of taking on D5 and there was
suddenly potentially a threat against
this Pawn Magnus says okay take me if
you dare Pawn to D4 and this relies on
the fact that after an exchange suddenly
white is again caught in two mins
suddenly this bishop hits the a pawn
suddenly Black's Rook is Unleashed
against the backward C2 pawn and if you
take with the queen again a skewer a
double attack whatever you call it
disaster for white this diagonal is just
too vulnerable and I think this would be
disastrous suddenly the Bishops really
dominating the whole board uh so the
question is can you take with a knight
um that's one I haven't figured out yet
I think that's one Hikaru is trying to
figure out in the current position can
he take twice feels like Magnus has
something in mind here this looks so so
dangerous with the pin maybe you move
your Bishop to attack this Knight and
it's just hanging by a thread right now
for Hikaru with the bishop a seeing all
the files and diagonal open up one gets
a feeling that D4 might have been also
an intuitive sacrifice rather than
Magnus having calculated all the lions
and how he's going to win the pawn back
or take advantage of it it's really so
tempting and you have a feeling that
with the Bishops and the Rooks lined up
something has to work for black here
yeah for sure all the pieces are on
optimal squares and even if white can
grabb the pawn on D4 the worst thing
that happens for black is you grab the
A3 Pawn so you're like it's just a pawn
trade that's not a big deal I didn't
blunder anything so that's the good news
for Magnus as you said Tanya it might be
an intuition decision there like let me
just go for it at the very least I'm
equal material but he may even have more
yeah I'm looking at ideas like Bishop to
E5 maybe bishop to G4 kick away this
Rook before takeing back on this square
but Hikaru goes for it he's uh maybe
obliged to go for this otherwise he's
just suffering for nothing often in
chess if you're worse if you realize you
have a disadvantage you might as well
grab some material you might as well get
some long-term advantages and hope to
survive suffer uh for a reason but right
now it's up to Magnus Carson I'll let
him make the decision rather than myself
because it's calculation time he needs
to justify uh this sacrifice if he takes
that pawn uh as you mentioned Robert on
A3 he's probably still slightly better
but um he might looking for more first
of all so many options here for black
and that's can be difficult for a player
in fact it can backfire like oh I have
so many options my position is great but
then you burn clock trying to figure out
the best path forward I'd like this move
Bishop E5 or Bishop C5 to induce C3
that's an option I'm wondering in those
lines can black also go after the B3
Pawn but they pins Galore it's not easy
to calculate so Magnus he's investing
time wisely and as Magnus does just that
uh try trying to figure out the way
forward after giving up that pawn we
will check in with this game meanwhile
action is really heating up as Ali Resa
Fusia has sacrificed an exchange for
once again to get that attack and
initiative against Wesley so we are
going to jump into that as it is a
critical moment between these two
players their first game ended in a draw
and this one looks like draw is perhaps
the least likely of results is there
enough compensation for white hair I'm
surprised I've got to say the evaluation
bar if I were black I would be tempted
to resign it looks like Checkmate but
with cold blooded defense which Wesley
so is capable of uh it looks like black
should be able to survive this Onslaught
look at that White Queen though look at
the White Knight the two white Bishops
both pointing towards the king side the
black structure is totally shattered I
mean it looks so so dangerous right now
but uh this is where engines killed the
joy killed the the fun I love it though
fua playing to his strengths but he's
also maybe playing into a trap because
Wesley so he may not bring the heat he
doesn't always initiate the
complications but when they're brought
to him he says let's do this thing and
Wesley has been in great form thus far I
think he was fortunate to survive the
first game between these two he ended up
sacrificing his Queen for a couple of
Rooks rather than stealing a pawn but in
this position I mean Wesley he's shown
that he can defend he did it against
Maxim Vash grav in their Armageddon game
and in this current position we see that
black has a rook for just a bishop and
black also still has an extra Pawn so
it's one of these things where if white
is not quick if white doesn't seize the
initiative right here and right now
you're down a whole lot of material and
black has a basic but an extremely
strong threat on the board right now
let's show it Tanya big threats should
not be missed and I don't think Ela FIA
will miss that there's actually a
Checkmate in one threat back rank uh
Checkmate here Queen to E1 uh but he
does need to therefore cover this Square
on E1 or at least cover the first rank
it makes sense as well to try and
activate this white Rook eventually so
that does beg the question where to move
this bishop therefore you would cover
the E1 Square you can choose D2 E3 H6
multiple options uh but what to do here
um I mean the first one I would look at
create a threat why not but the problem
is you might want to use that square for
your queen and after the black Rook
simply moves same threat persists again
Queen to E1 would be a back rank
Checkmate within two moves even at the
cost of a queen he does Play Bishop to D
two instead and uh wow Wesley bringing
the other Rook into the game I was going
to say this is a bit OD to trap your
Rook on f8 but um yeah he's activating
all these pieces still needs a breakr
fua here something we've yet to speak
about though is look at Fu's clock I
feel like usually it's Al Raza putting
pressure on someone on the clock now
it's Wesley do that he has nearly eight
minutes now Al is down to three and a
half minutes in this position where f is
down an exchange has to deal with some
back rank threats constantly doesn't
have a clear path to delivering any sort
of checkping attack of his own I have to
like Wesley's chances here just the way
he's playing overall and given this
current situation Wesley so looks like
he might go four out of four yeah and
that last move Rook to E8 uh it does
have a deep idea as well not only are
you blocking White's Bishop from
stepping on to H6 because the mate on E1
if it's black to play here let's say
white makes the natural move H3 creating
a lift for the king black is threaten to
actually push out that knight from C3
with advancing that B Pawn and then
Black's Queen would have landed on E2
which is why alira he's played a really
nice prophylactic move here with putting
that Bishop on D3 it might look like
he's just attacking the B5 Pawn but he's
also controlled a very key E2 Square
from where a queen trade could have been
offered yeah and here we see a helping
hand from the engine from stockfish
suggesting three moves that give black
quite a significant Advantage so it uh
basically proves that Black's material
the extra material the extra exchange
and porn that Robert mentioned I mean
it's the most important factor right now
White's attack is illusion Black's
Knight on G6 Knights are a king's best
friend is holding the fort covering
everything and okay he plays Pawn to B4
not one of the moves suggested by the
engine uh but still looks very natural
and white apparently only has one move
to minimize the damage that's Knight to
B5 wow that is not an intuitive move
because Knight goes away from where most
the action is taking place but you're
trying to distract the Black Knight and
he finds it he understands the Knight on
D6 is the critical defender of this
position and if you take this Knight on
B5 in comes that white knight
Queen H6 to follow Queen G7 Checkmate
thank you very much wow what a trick
what a trap so vigilent there just full
board awareness and and this is Ali RAR
strength right he finds these creative
ideas on the board just voluntarily
sacrifices the exchange for a long-term
initiative and now finds the defender
he's getting rid of it Wesley so he
needs to be precise in this uh position
he's got a lot to think about and
meanwhile big update coming in uh Dennis
AIC has drawn his second game against
Maxim vasher lra the 17-year-old should
be very proud right now Maxim vasher lra
he has been on fire he's had some
tremendous games one of the best in the
world and the youngster for whom this is
the platform that he's been waiting for
the opportunities that he's been waiting
for he's been showing Amazing class
himself that one goes into Armageddon
and here anything can happen this was a
position I thought Wesley had the
obvious upper hand now I'm looking at it
that F5 squares juicy and a night might
plop right on it and try to help deliver
a Checkmate so Dennis lck Maxim Vash
they go to Armageddon for Dennis lvic 0
out of three thus far in match play but
he's really been just a couple moves
away in every single match from being on
the scoreboard we'll see if he can get
that done but right now we're going to
have to see if Ali Raza can turn this
disadvantage into a win yeah Wesley just
missed this one I think it was that
simple Wesley assumed that he had full
control and he nearly did but just one
careless slip and suddenly tactics again
uh Knight and F5 will Thrive that's the
rhyme Knight and F5 we're live as James
KY would say and uh yeah suddenly big
big threats actually a narrow path
potentially for Wesley to save this game
I think it's just that powerful the
White Knight if it does land on F5 would
just spell the end so uh this is a
narrow window of opportunity to kill
White's attack but I'm struggling to
find it why I mean Wesley so struggling
to find it as well he's tanked now for a
couple of minutes he find he find the
move Bishop to A6 wow clever clever
defense there lovely move by Wesley so
he's realizing that I've had a material
advantage if I have to give some of it
away to save my king that is the best
decision and he may be saying okay if
the Knight takes the Knight on D6 then
the bishop on D3 can be captured here
and you just don't have enough Firepower
Knight F5 still looks really scary I
don't even want your Rook I'm going to
go for checkmate but once I take your
knight on F5 and you take back with your
knight I can make this move Queen to E4
and the point is Queen H6 still checkm
one is the threat but I get to take your
knight away on F5 you don't have another
Defender yeah just in time it's all
hanging by a thread but it is surviving
for Wesley so and the critical line
therefore is after night takes night to
take this black Rook but as you said
Robert you're no longer The Exchange up
you still have an extra Pawn though as
long as you survive this attack only
black can be better with the queen
coming into E2 it's all of these ideas
we've mentioned uh Tanya's Queen to and
uh yeah right now I think alera a bit
disappointed that Wesley did find the
best defense just precise play by Wesley
he's so resourceful and just so hard to
crack or beat even in these positions
Knight B5 arise on the board and mayor
mles would just collapse at that moment
but he finds the right path and it is on
the board will Ali Risa now grab the
rook and more exciting news coming in as
we will have another Armageddon asaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson have drawn
their second game I knew I recognized
that shirt blocking Al's camera for a
while there it was Magnus Carlson he did
finish and uh we have more chess uh to
look forward to to from him a bit later
on but Magnus is out of there and uh
let's focus back on this one where all
is a Retreats not a good sign usually
but that night was no longer playing a
purpose on the edge of the board I'm
still looking at the clock and Al it
down nearly to a minute and a half
whereas Wesley has nearly 5 minutes on
his clock so Knight goes back to F3 the
black king is no longer In Harm's Way
perhaps at this point Al just want to
say rookie one are trading pieces and
going for a draw but I don't see an
advantage for either side at the moment
it one does feel though that white has
to have enough compensation with Black's
destroyed Pawn structure as well Bishop
E2 played uh it's also against the idea
of the queen sliding onto A5 White's
Rook you've got to be a little careful
do you want to make a move like Rook e
one allowing tactics like Bishop takes
Knight and perhaps Bishop takes KN he
plans to take on E E7 and things are
still under control so while these
players work out the tactics we will uh
keep an eye out and uh come back to this
but Fabiano Carana against n back Abdus
satro also very very critical as Fab's
got about a minute on the clock and it
is his move right now nck ahead on the
clock nck needs only a draw and we were
quite happy with his position last when
we left it and I think we still should
be Fabiano needs a miracle it's as
simple as that Robert so he needs to
turn into Wesley so and then thrive in
Toronto but that's not happening here
this is dominance on display from nbec
abusar he's kind of Kryptonite for
Fabiano he beat him over the classical
chess in the Olympiad he beat him to win
the chess kid cup here he won game one
and he might even just win game two I
don't even think he'll offer a courtesy
draw he's not that type of player
sometimes when you're at one- nothing
all you needs a draw to win the match we
saw Wesley do this against Hikaru gave
him a draw kind of a a sympathy draw
that's not happening when n Beck abaro
is playing because there also fed rapid
points on the line he wants to increase
his rating yeah and look at that the
computer says there are two winning
moves for black right now White has just
snapped off a pawn Fabiano decided to
suffer for something and there is a
material advantage but the black Rook
coming into F3 being the top move that's
the most natural move in the position as
well and I think he will play it it's
more about the followup it looks like
the white king is just devoid of any
Defenders right now black has a queen
coming in a knight coming in Rook coming
in everything's Gathering the storm
clouds are just hovering above there and
he's going to move his Rook look at that
body language it's on the board and now
you're thinking about yes all the
sacrifices but he first up the pawn
you're hitting the D2 Bishop you're
attacking the G3 Pawn the F2 Pawn is
pinned uh and the Fabiano car has only
40 seconds to solve all these problems
can he do it no there's no way it's even
material so it's not even like n had to
sacrifice anything to get to this
position and he does attack that Rook on
F3 did Fabby The Rook goes to D3 so B3
is loose there's some checks on the
first rank that are about to happen I
see the evaluation bar going up for
Fabby but I see his time going down and
it just doesn't give me much hope for
him yeah I just want to highlight one
moment where actually he could have
wrapped it up in style Abdu satoro after
Rook to F3 the queen dropped back guess
what Black's best move is uh this isn't
me this is the computer that suggested
it or Rook E3
Rob this would have been the I'm going
to say it sexiest move of the tournament
so far um just overwhelming white
defenses there's a threat of a sacrifice
here going for checkmate and a night
coming in would have been disastrous for
white but if we catch up with the
current game is he surviving Fabiano
that's the question the answer is no
he's the exchange down uh we saw a
tactical uh kind of sequence there and
simply nothing to be done let's just
show that in slow motion Queen to B2 and
attack a double attack against this
bishop he did try to defend by taking
giving up his queen with the idea of
Bishop to C3 check but Fabiano played uh
no sorry Andor of played Queen day C1
check intermediate move uh in between
move there and now it's just a lost end
game yeah this is easy at this stage
because they're pawns on both sides of
the board if you could could sweep off
the queenside pawns if none remain then
maybe there would be some chances for
Fabiano to hold the draw and he's going
for this technique he really would like
to trade B Pawn for a pawn but why in
the world would not Beck allow that he
can instead bring his Rook to D3 He does
just that try to take the B Pawn for
himself and there's nothing Fabiano can
do it's been a tough day in the office
for Fabby he lost his uh round three to
Magnus Carlson and it looks like he will
be losing round four to n Abdu satov
he's got so much time on the clock as
well Fabby under 30 seconds and I like
that nck has slowed down because this
got him a little bit into trouble in
their first game in their first
encounter so it's a good idea you're up
in exchange you want to just you just
want to draw you want to try and wrap it
up as quickly as possible n back he
keeps playing fast yeah you saw the
frustration on his face he was trying to
force himself to slow down he's so
excited right now and rightly so because
he's about to wrap up a win I think this
last maneuver was the Clincher putting
the black Rook behind White's oh but
there's tactics yeah that was actually
really nicely done by Fabby he trades
off the queenside pawns yet it's still
losing according to the engines and it's
probably just because the black king
will infiltrate uh The Rook is in a
perfect position and here comes King F5
Pawn G5 he may be able to spring for an
outside pass Pawn as well yeah this is
still is still winning but I was about
to praise him for pinning and winning uh
instead it's far less simple uh
sometimes you can hold a fortress here
but unfortunately rook and three versus
bishop and three usually is a win and
white just cannot hold the light squares
long term and not a b now the big
question is will he just get a draw and
uh wrap up the match or is he going to
try for more because points do count
here Robert points are important in
those top eight standing I see you
shaking your head but you know these
youngsters I have a feeling he's going
to try to push this one there could be
nothing on the line and abitar would
still be playing like he could be in his
backyard playing as his favorite person
in the world and a draw is still good
enough he says no he's that much of a
fighter and I think that's what people
love about his style he should get
invited to all the tournaments where
it's you know the organizer has to pick
some people because he always fights
there's never a game where he takes it
off and why should he give faon a draw
he's got no risk in this position yeah I
even forgot that a draw was sufficient
for him because he's been playing such
aggressive chess he's not been backing
down and this is good wisdom for anyone
at home as well even if you're happy
with a draw play objectively correct
chess play for the win that's the best
way of securing that result later on if
you play too passively negatively
tentatively it will backfire your
opponents will punish you and uh he's
being rewarded for his courage here Abdu
satov he's trying to break through
White's holding the Fortress Fabiano
still tenacious defense but it shouldn't
be enough long term although the Evar
going right back towards the middle so
just as you said that he pushed F5 which
was apparently the wrong idea and now it
seems that Fabby May hold this draw but
without time on the clock what should
happen doesn't usually usually happen
yeah this last move putting porns all on
light squares a bit strange but uh yeah
we'll see how this one plays out yes
mbec undoubtedly will go for as long as
he can and Fabiano Carana will have to
earn this draw meanwhile we've earned
ourselves a lot of fun because we're
already guaranteed three Armageddon ala
peruja and Wesley so also ends in a draw
alz are sacrificing The Exchange finding
his contemplate this the amazing play
and Wesley with his resistance
impossible to crack but in the end there
will be a sudden death in each of these
games and this one continues Fabby doing
all that he can to hold on is this now
closer to draw territory I think yes um
I mean I was just singing his Praises
after dorov but he's kind of allowed
Fabiano to get a fortress I he probably
was thinking can I sacrifice my Rook for
this bishop you can tell that the wheels
are turning in nre's head his King is
coming around I don't know where to but
King can go to D1 E1 F1 G1 H2 I don't
know what to do with it but the king can
just wrap itself around and actually
Faby block that but there may allow F4
at some moment Fabby does need to be
very careful because if that pawn
structure is shattered and the H4 Pawn
is loose that could once again give n
back some winning chances and the thing
about these end games is you can play
accurately for 20 moves for 30 moves but
very often the pressure just keeps
accumulating till uh eventually you
allow a break like F4 or a winning King
Pawn ending and has that happened well
the King has found its way to ew1 things
are getting nasty for white already yeah
the King has infiltrated it's found its
way Behind Enemy Lines and yeah I think
holding this one now is going to be well
it's going to need a miracle it's going
to be super tough and what's the winning
plan here for black something to do with
Robert's F4 I'm not sure when where why
but it is F4 you need to break White's
porn structure everything's defended
right now you need to ensure that that
won't be the case long term F2 is the
base of White's Pawn chain as well so if
you attack that one um you do tie down
White's remaining pieces Fabby playing
under 10 seconds and Utterback still
enough time he's putting the pressure on
the board and on the clock and making
progress slowly but steadily and he
wants the now he gets F4 so he finally
at long last has been able to push the
pawn he shattering White's Pawn
structure and Fabby takes it but that
can't be good the pawns are split and
you probably just losing one on the spot
look at that body language he shifts he
knows he's got the job done that is big
progress once he split the pawns he's
going to go for them uh now the king can
also go up to F3 you start threatening
Rook takes F2 Pawn at the right moment
ooh yeah Rook G2 and our Rook F2 is Rook
F2 winning in these positions yes it is
and that is it Fabby resigns a King Pawn
ending would be lost and look at nbec
he's happy of course he is he beat
Fabiano Carana who's had the best year
in classical chess of any body two in a
must-win match so not entered the day
with zero match points now he's won two
in a row and he has found his form and
Fabby immediately leaves without setting
up the pieces it has been a
disappointing day for world number two
he lost to Magnus now goes down to NC
Abdus satra who after a tough start on H
day one where he lost both his games
he's made a comeback on the leaderboard
and these are the results of round for
we've got three big Armageddon coming up
nak Magnus Carlson fuja Wesley lazic
Maxim VRA all go down to the
wire and David what was the highlight
for you and once again tough to choose
tough to choose but it will be that only
decisive game uh from that last round
and uh it was nbec Abdu zoro's attack in
the end he did find a way to convert his
Advantage it took a while though and uh
after Rook to F3 it was this little
sequence the queen dropping back and
there might have been stronger moves he
found something strong and simple Queen
takes D4 double threat attacking this
bishop and due to the pin along this
diagonal threatening this G3 Pawn after
Queen to G3 he wrapped it up with this
nice tactic Queen to B2 and a slow
action replay of this trick Queen takes
Knight was not a defense do not take the
queen it is poisoned after Bishop to C3
check white would save the game by
winning the black queen back instead the
black queen is doomed anyway so why not
give it away for the highest price Queen
takes Rook check and only then winning
the Material Exchange up he converted it
smoothly breath taking play there and
hold your breath everyone as we are
going straight to Toronto as Kaa is with
Hikaru and Magnus and their Armageddon
bids the moment everyone is waiting for
armag get on bids between hikaro and
Magnus you guys turn your boards let's
see it Magnus oh 15 minutes I guess that
means you win it 9 minutes 40 seconds
what your reaction Naru well it's funny
because I actually thought about bidding
50 minutes just to get white in between
these two games but yeah it's what it is
you just play the game can you Reveal
Your tactics with butting 15 minutes
minus yeah I wanted to to play white but
I thought he would be a little bit lower
so uh I I mean knowing that I could have
bid uh 939 and
one not so happy with that but that's
okay well you guys go prepare thank you
for uh placing your bids here back to
you wow 15 minutes by Magnus making his
intentions very clear that he wants the
white pieces at any cost yeah I think he
doesn't trust hikaru's repertoire at the
moment because he keeps playing these
odd lines but when it comes down to one
game against Magnus Carlson with a Time
deficit I think that's when hikaro he
won't be as adventurous he'll stick to
his main repertoire yeah I mentioned
earlier Magnus is traditionally the king
of Armageddon so many Armageddon wins
but you saw the doubt in his voice there
he wasn't sure Hikaru still has enough
enough time and if Hikaru gets out the
opening in good shape it's going to be a
race on the clock wow this is going to
be a lot of fun the armagen that is
coming up we' got three of them and
Magnus there with his bid against Hikaru
Nakamura they are ready to go Magnus
will start with the white pieces Hikaru
takes on black Hikaru needs only a draw
to win this match and we will be back
with this armag Garden that you don't
want to miss do not go
[Music]
anywhere we're here in Toronto for the
global Championship I got Fabiano Carana
with me you don't need to talk yet I got
James K we're going to see who
recognizes these guys out of the out of
the random passerbys and we're going to
ask them some fun questions about Chess
for five bucks do you know who this is
no okay actor an actor when you see this
guy any idea who he is somebody very
famous he is RA this is actually 50
cents brother his name is darl Right
goes by 75 you want to play chess okay
so what is he a player or something of
Chess he is a chess player I'm not but
he is I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster KY over here recently
calculation over everything what's your
name again sir uh my name is jimie
what's your name I already know it it's
it's Daniel yeah Daniel nitzki
okay there it is come on on the attack
baby on the attack if he wins I know the
guys at chess.com we'll get him a
diamond membership okay do you know what
that is yes okay is that something you
want yes yeah okay look at you look is
this a London playing a yo we got a pro
here with the London full on London How
It Go I won won the won that's great hey
good game all right I should have said
youtube.com/ csq
what is the URL just YouTube I actually
don't
remember look at the
[Music]
pot chess again no this is spell chess
do I dare read the instructions or
should I go in without reading them I
didn't read the rules this man is just
blundering what basically it's normal
chess but they're two spells jump and
freeze the freeze is applied to a 3X3
area man this game is what freeze here
night check boom that's made oh that's
that's that's incredible stuff uh oh
freeze wait a I froze my cor a jump
spell which allows you to jump over a
piece and I'm setting up a win oh then
black would just freeze
me then I make a double threat you don't
have any freezes left so if
here this is too hard wait once I get
the hang of this we're going to be
winning so many games though I can't
block with any of those pieces but I can
use this this and then
this raise this and then go
here yay I won let's go cannot take my
Bishop he cannot take my
Bishop it's a nice feeling when you
start understanding the game and you win
oh they off I don't even lie I think I'm
one of the greatest spell chess players
to ever played spell chess that was fun
I'm enjoying
[Music]
this
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things registration is now open for the
CCL spring 2024 season represent your
school in the Premier University league
for team chess compete against top
talents like GM Aang Benjamin Bach and
aarin stake your claim for the
$25,000 price fund use the command CCL
in chat to learn how to register and uh
the chess doesn't stop even on day two
of the Champions Chester finals as we
have not just one but three armagon
coming up and uh we're also going to be
revealing the bids as skak caught up
with weso and alira
fua this guy is so sneaky he has been
peeking Wesley no peing no peeking all
right yeah I thought a little bit oh oh
okay let's not keep the tension you guys
turn your boards and let's see what your
armag get on bits are let's see it show
it to the camera so we do have
929 853 that means you will be playing
with the black pie Sala what was the
thought behind this bed that's low yeah
I mean um I think I have better chances
for if I have two results in my favor so
but yeah it's always double age and
Anything Could Happen he's incredible
was beat this guy so how do you feel
about playing with the white pieces now
Wesley well I need Danny wrench's help
he need to like predict who's going to
win
in the playing Hall one minute before
the game yeah we I need I need his help
now yeah you guys best of luck in your
game thank you so much for placing your
bids here armagedon is coming up back to
you guys Ka we are so excited three
amazing fights coming up ala gets the
black pieces was that a cat that Wesley
saw just drew on his Armageddon bit I
think it was his cat we know how much
Wesley loves his cat brings him some
good luck so why
not yeah they've both been playing chess
worthy of works of art that was Wesley's
work of art I mean I admire it I admire
it that picture alone could be worth a
lot of money especially if he wins this
Armageddon game this is going to be
really exciting and speaking of
Armageddon we got one more let's take a
look at the bids between these two and
this was a close one Maxim B lra takes
it with his 9 Minute 24 second bid and
will be starting with the black pieces
danis lazovic with white will have to
win on
demand Rob but what do you make of that
Maxim happy with his bid and getting
black it's quite low I mean all these
players are bidding in that territory
with the exception of Magnus at 15 full
minutes but I think for Dennis lazic you
have to use the time as a weapon the
problem is you're playing one of the
best prepared deepest prepared players
in the planet and someone he looks cozy
in that t-shirt yeah Maxim I think he's
made a good bet just based on the stats
Dennis is yet to win a single game in
the final so far but on Dennis's side
what speaks for him is that he's been up
it day by day day one he drew a couple
of games but lost both matches now it's
his second Armageddon of day two feels
like he's moving in the right direction
he just needs to make that breakthrough
he just needs a stroke of Fortune or
that Killer Instinct he needs to make
use of those extra minutes danis lasic
has to forget the match score he has to
look within himself and find the
strength in The Amazing chess that he
has been playing against the very best
in the world he starts with white it's
no easy task for the 17year old but one
win is all that he needs right now I
feel like he must play something
different than he normally does because
he has such a solid repertoire he can
draw any of these players in the field
with the white pieces and he drew Maxim
with black as well but he to win on
demand he I think is going to have to
choose a new opening something that has
more fight to it these two did draw
their rapid games and we'll fight it out
in the armag and harkar Nakamura also
drew his two rapid games against Magnus
gson he St with the black pieces Magnus
with that 15minute bit do you think he
kind of got a little bit into hikaru's
head there I'm not sure maybe he got
into his own head because 15 minutes
that is brave but if the opening doesn't
go magnus's way he will regret choosing
white and uh Hikaru does have enough
time uh Hikaru has plenty of time by his
standards at least you make that bid of
15 minutes and you're just saying I'm
going to crush you well Magnus also said
yesterday that it's good to switch up
your bid so you're not predictable when
it comes to the next armor geddon that
said as you're suggesting Tanya he wants
the white pieces he feels confident he
can win the game and the big question is
what will Hikaru play with black because
in most of his games he's playing
offbeat stuff but the line that he chose
earlier with pushing his DNC Pawn
forward he managed to survive out of the
opening and neutralize it really quickly
but Magnus will not let that happen this
time uh he has to win uh black needs
only a draw in the Armageddon Magnus
Carlson starts with 15 minutes hiar
nakura starts with result odds and this
isn't the only exciting matchup it is
also Ali Resa fuja against Wesley so
guys this is going to be a hard hard
armagedon to call we'll have to do a lot
of jumping around yeah it's going to be
tough we'll have to follow the action
where it lands but I mean one thing
that's going to be tough is avoiding
being distracted by that shirt during
the Armageddon I mean that could be mind
games with a clock ticking just kind of
look at my shirt well leavon aronian
called he wants his style back but I
feel like leavon will be cheering on Ali
Rizza just because of that shirt and his
play has also been stylish in this event
even his match against Wesley I mean the
way he's just sacrificing material first
a pawn then an exchange in the first
game I think he had Wesley on the Rope
so Al it now gets the black pieces I
think he'll tone it back though you
don't want to continue playing so
aggressively when all you need is a draw
Ali Raa fuja playing the chest that he's
best known for and there we see Wesley
so has arrived handshakes have have
happened the three armagen games are
ready to be on the
way the world's best players and uh now
we go handshake and we're off Magnus
Carlson he starts with the Kings porn
instead so veering away from that double
Queen's Gambit and we see Nakamura
employed the Petro defense solid stuff
and it again the Damiano variation that
we saw yesterday he employed this with
success what do you think Robert it's
one of these decisions where either
Magnus looked at hikaru's games because
he played this yesterday or he didn't
look at it because it's so ridiculous
that he would play this at the highest
level and Hikaru well what risk does he
have right now that being said it's an
equal position on move four move five
who cares it's Magnus Carlson he's
proven time and time again he can
somehow squeeze water out of a stone
will he be able to this armag again game
that's the big question yeah and
interesting that Magnus doesn't go for
any forcing lines any direct lines we
saw complicated battles in this
variation yesterday Magnus says my
Approach in this Armageddon is to slowly
outplay you later and uh maybe hustle
you on the clock it's very strategic
very slow right now actually this is a
well-known position with colors reversed
and uh it's odd to see the White Knight
stay on E5 in the Petro defense um looks
like Nakamura is prepared though playing
Super Quick up to this point only
spending a few seconds Magnus brings his
Bishop out slight Advantage because he
has that centralized Knight he has the
first move in uh these types of
positions and it is about fighting that
night on E5 with your own pieces as
black here expecting Hikaru to line up
his Rook on the E file develop his own
Knight to C6 try to trade off that very
strong piece that is posted on E5 the
task is clear for both these players
Magnus has no choice but to keep the
game going he has to try and keep as
many pieces on the board but one more
set of Min one more one set of minor
pieces will come off uh in the center of
the board that's very likely but it's
hard to know when to capture it because
if black captures that Knight on E5 at
some moment a pawn will replace the
Knight and then there will be attacking
chances for white namely with that
Bishop on D3 so I think Magnus he needs
to play a little bit quickly here Hikaru
with nine minutes remaining on his clock
I think he's off to the best start
imaginable yeah Hikaru will be thrilled
you might not look it I'm not sure what
face number that is of hikaru's right
now
shelding oh Danny might tell you off for
that one but shielding uh the glare of
Magnus but he's solid and that's all he
can ask for
solid uh is the name of the game right
now with the Petro defense Rook has
lined up we are expecting a night
development and meanwhile Magnus takes
his time but he's got to be careful
because he has to keep the pressure on
the clock as well if the clocks level
out then it's just result odds for white
and uh Hikaru does not develop the
Knight but strikes immediately in the
center targeting the main defense of
that E5 Knight huge decision though
because of Magnus just captures the pawn
that was placed on C5 there will be an
isolated Queen Pawn for Hikaru that
that's not a bad thing necessarily but
when you don't have so much time I think
players tend to struggle protecting that
pawn you operate around it that's true
but defending it that's a different
story yeah big uh big decision as you
mentioned Robert to change the pawn
structure I just don't know whether
Hikaru is playing for the result or
sorry I'll let you take it away there
you're absolutely right here C5 is a
very committal move by Hikaru and we
will come back to this and see what
Magnus decides how does he respond to
these questions being asked at the
center of the board remember it's all
about the fight for that E5 post
meanwhile action is heating up on the
other armagedon as well and uh big
fights all around right now Magnus
really taking his
time 12 minutes on the clock he's and we
will come back to this but let's jump
over to a Wesley so and alira fuja that
one I am expecting not to be such a
strategic fight the kind of chest that
we've been seeing from Ala I think we're
going to see some fireworks already on
the board you don't wear that shirt and
then just play for a boring draw and we
have a position where white has these
double Pawns in the C file that may seem
like a bad thing but inherent having
double pawns is an open file you see the
queen and the Rook for white are more
active than Black's pieces the queen on
d8 doing not so much at the moment but
will there be an attack that's the big
question white will need to storm up the
kingside try to open up some lines and
uh yeah sorry everyone about that it's
been a long day chess a long day of uh
action and uh yeah I've got to say I
really like White's position here but my
question is is it Wesley so style uh if
the only way to break through is to
throw pawns forward towards the black
king I don't know it feels risky somehow
it feels like you might have to
sacrifice something at some point and
the time Advantage is now down to 3
minutes it's not going to be easy and
wesle so needs to take action now or in
the next few moves if he really wants to
motor forward and attack win this game
and one way to do that is to start
pushing the Jeep on right you want to
get that pawn rolling you want to try
and open up the G line get G4 get G5 in
perhaps even look at sacrificing the G
Pawn to open up uh the G file and Wesley
is trying to find his way forward while
White's plan is clear you either prepare
it with the line that David's pointing
out F3 G4 maybe bishop B2 G4 maybe Rook
G1 G4 but what is Black's way of getting
counterplay against white King on the
other side of the board well if White's
going to pawn storm on the king's side
why not Pawn storm on the queen side and
uh I'm not sure how exactly you do
uh sometimes you can throw this Pawn
forward that might not get you anywhere
you can throw a pawn to A6 maybe then
you hint a move like C5 at the right
moment but yeah every Pawn push comes
with consequences maybe A6 B5 and then
throw a knight into C4 um various
options but I think because he has draw
odds forja he can sit the pressure is on
white the onus is on white and maybe he
doesn't even need to attack maybe just a
move like Queen to E7 just uh kind of
centralize your pieces connect the Rooks
and look at this uh okay he's pausing
now but Wesley's time Advantage down to
2 minutes only I was going to say
something similar that because ala only
needs a draw instead of pushing pawns
forward maybe he'll bring his Knight
backwards because he might want to offer
a knight trade then he can might bring
his Bishop that's on F6 over one square
to G5 offer a trade of Bishops so trades
I think they're good for black in this
position when all you need is a draw
yeah just so solid this pet off defense
it's been the bane of so many uh one4
players careers and it's just Rock Solid
so trustworthy even even if it goes
wrong you end up in a position like uh
this one and actually uh unless white
can attack nothing to complain about so
fuja he needs to speed up though one
minute on this move is a bit too long
maybe just centralize the queen queen E7
just keep the status quo and uh okay he
does play one of the ideas we suggested
Pawn to A6 this one will heat up but
it's on Wesley to heat it up at the
right moment all right so both players
eyeing that flank attack pushing their
own pawns towards enemy lons and and
meanwhile our third Armageddon also well
underway with quite a crazy position we
have been talking about danis lavic
having a slow strategic style but take a
look at what has come out of the opening
Maxim's King is in the center White's
Knight on e4 eyeing those dark Square
weaknesses I am loving Dennis's position
here if white is able to trade off those
dark Square Bishop with a move like
Bishop G5 and Landing Knight on either
D6 or F6 this could be big trouble for
maxim and Maxim is the one who's got six
minutes on the I don't need an
evaluation bar to tell me that this is a
great opportunity for Dennis lck in a
must-win position you want chances
that's really all you can ask for and
not only does he have chances he's got
space that pawn on E5 is a thorn in
Black side it's covering some really
important squares and look at that F7
Pawn that's a backwards Pawn that may be
targeted so how to actually convert this
Advantage into something that is instead
of aesthetically pleasing where tactic
will land in White's favor that's a
different story and he moves his Bishop
all the way out to H6 I like it Bishop
G7 maybe the H7 Pawn will be picked off
Dennis this is the style that I've
wanted to see from him and he's taking
it right to Maxim yeah whatever he's
done just uh you mentioned switching it
up whatever he's done he needs to keep
doing this you need to attack the top
players that's why he hasn't had that
breakthrough yet but finally he gets a
dream position and it's horrible for
maxim this black king is stranded in no
man's land it can never now Castle on
the king side that would be illegal
castling Queen side as well Frau with
danger especially once the a file opens
up so I love this last move keeping his
options open Maxim wow 5 minutes now how
does he defend he can plant a knight on
a nice square but one good piece is not
enough Rook to G8 wow just stopping
Bishop to G7 and Dennis immediately just
drops back big threat on the board and
uh Knight jumping into D6 on the cards
as well this looks almost terminal now
for black deeply unpleasant as you're
saying numerous threats with every
single turn played I don't even care if
the evaluation bar is going down
slightly what is Maxim's plan I don't
see an easy one taking the Knight on e4
that looks terrible the bishop will
replace the Knight attack The Rook in
the corner that is probably just losing
on the spot so what Maxim can accomplish
here is unclear he's only on move 20
he's about to get 5 minutes left he
pushes his H Pawn but Knight D6 check as
you mentioned David that looks very
appealing you don't need to do it but
you get the bishop pair and you start
opening up more lines yeah you also can
open up uh on the queen side at will you
can maybe repurpose this White Queen
first and move like Queen to G3 save
this one for later no rush it's not
running away anytime soon keep the
tension maybe would be my advice because
you do have the added time on the clock
and you have an Attack Force your
opponent to kind of suffer defend defend
defend and only pounce later um Dennis
he's spoiled for choice and dream starts
this game for him I like what you just
said though instead of just going too
quickly May Rook F1 to B1 just continue
to apply pressure on that black queen
side there's no rush over there black
doesn't want to take on A4 anyway so
Rook F1 to B1 instead of Knight D6 check
I like your idea David I think actually
that will be a better choice big
question will Donis lazic be able to
keep the tension undoubtedly he knows
that he's managed to get big Advantage
out of the opening but we know just how
resistant and resourceful Maxim can be
how tricky he can be Dennis instead goes
for a more direct approach he gets that
Bishop air and Maxim blitzes out his
moves putting pressure on that G2 Pawn
tying down White's Queen to defend it
but it looks like Dennis had calulated
his way forward the bishop lands on E5
black king not feeling safe but you
might be forced to put it on the queen
side yeah still very good but I'm
slightly afraid lavic is playing
positionally in a position that kind of
Demands dynamism at some point that
being said white does have a dream
position look at the clock as well Maxim
is not comfortable at all we're used to
seeing Maxim Blitz even in kind of the
most dubus of positions but here Maxim
is in the tank that clock is ticking
ever further down and still glorious for
white that Bishop controls everything on
E5 you see a move at a time for black
you Castle Queen side good for you that
F1 Rook does slide over to B1 that side
of the board will open up sooner rather
than later and G5 played look at that
desperation from Magnus with the
evaluation bar went all the way up do
not take that pawn on H5 Queen takes G2
would be Checkmate so that's what Maxim
is relying on right now is that there
are threats on the diagonal and look at
how simply Dennis lazic plays F3 Bishop
E4 next H5 is truly hanging this might
just be over in the youngster favor yeah
I think Maxim was banking on the fact he
could play porn to G4 but now white can
just slide forward remind black that
there's a Checkmate threat in this side
of the board as well and this would
simply be terminal look at this black
king stranded and uh soon to be M this
one is almost over he just needs a few
more accurate moves H4 aims to trap this
White Queen but we said it Bishop to E4
just looks so strong right now and he
does play it this is looking just
fantastic for the youngster he might get
his first match win of the finals and
what a win it would be against Maxim V
lra can Dennis lavic finish off this job
he's so close the queen moves back now
big questions do you trade off the
bishop do you go for Black's Rook
because Bishop 87 you don't have so many
squares yourself first Dennis decides to
liquidate the queen side uh he wants to
trade off the Rooks there are a lot of
pleasant choices already upon up wow
this is going to be a huge breakthrough
in his career in the tournament for
Dennis lck this will fill him with
confidence this is I mean look at the
control the calmness he's done the hard
work he realizes he doesn't even need to
do much anymore he's one upon PA one
material he's just sneaking in now with
the White Queen blocking Black's
counterplay black is stranded black is
helpless and Maxim didn't take the pawn
back because he wanted to keep files
closed he thinks that if the second Rook
would appear on the queen side for white
that would have been disastrous but this
is no better we see Dennis lvic pouncing
first establishing his Bishop in the
center then taking a pawn then SL lering
his Queen forward up to G4 maybe it goes
to H5 and further into Black's camp but
Maxim he is trying desperately to close
down the queen side to close down that
front so his King maybe can escape but
even if the king escapes he's
positionally in huge danger and black
has to watch out of that Bishop from E4
moving to 87 and it has happened Bishop
87 is he about to win big material Now
The Rook it's got no squares you go to
f8 the other Bishop can jump on to uh G7
G5 Pawn is hanging and gives up more
pieces this is just too much material
and now white is up the exchange and a
porn and look at the white D6 Pawn just
beautifully entrenched in Black's
position I don't see any counterplay the
White Queen isn't trapped she has
squares the only good thing for Maxi
vley grv is the black king for now is
safe the Black Knight is the glue
holding everything together what a move
D5 so good he just gave his Pawn away
that square is covered by three
different black pieces and he said take
me with any of your pieces the queen it
can slide to D4 all of a sudden and it's
going for checkmate if the Knight moves
A4 drops more of an attack so that was a
wonderful decision you see the evalar
approved of it D5 that was sick so
classy those invisible moves as we call
them on squares that are protected so
many times by enemy pieces they break
the enemy's coordination they open up
lines and Bishop to D4 back lining up
with the White Queen would have been a
Terminal Threat there okay Maxim he's
fending things off move by move but long
term he's busted he's down material and
the black king is a target he simply
slides back and sooner or later that
white Bishop will drop back kick away
the Black Knight and everything will
fall apart and that's all you need to do
the Knight on B6 holds Black's position
just for now and Dennis lazic finding
the right squares for his pieces he
needs to put pressure on that Knight
Bishop D4 will be the final touch to
this Dennis has to be feeling confident
look at that clock he's kept it under
control on the clock as well and this in
no way is against Maxim with this will
be a phenomenal phenomenal win for
Dennis lazic you have to feel happy for
him if he gets a job done here and Maxim
now in time trouble his King is being
hunted he's down material and as you
said it's nothing against Maxim we're
all friends with him he's a 2021 World
Blitz Champion so for Dennis to just
bring it to him I think it will give him
some serious confidence boost because
instead of playing a quieter positional
style which we know he loves he just
said let's go and he went for an
aggressive attacking game and right now
he's completely winning but will he be
able to convert this I'm sure a lot of
the chat is perhaps rooting for Dennis
right now but we know how tricky Maxim
can be we've seen him trick his
opponents with even in positions which
look even more hopeless than this one so
it's really not over that's the thing
about these top players it's so hard to
beat them even in positions that you're
completely winning and finally that
Bishop does arrive on D4 Bishop takes
Knight is the big threat Dennis is up in
exchange what does he need to watch out
for in these positions
well uh it's hard to imagine too much
going wrong for white but now the D6
Pawn has dropped watch out your Rook on
A3 is hanging uh Dennis blocks that
threat I guess he has just has to just
cash in at the right time you just want
to make sure you don't kind of
transition too early into an endgame
where black keeps the A4 Pawn alive for
example black keeps the D5 Bishop on an
outpost because there might be no way
through later so don't trade off
everything don't take that black knight
yet that end game might be holdable for
black uh so you just need to keep calm
you need to keep patient Wasington okay
he's building Rook to B4 I was wondering
if the Knight can drop back to D7 here
because if the bishop slides back to D4
E5 that almost traps the bishop so he
goes up instead of back he saw this all
that was really brilliant by Dennis
there because now A4 is falling the
bishop on E7 you can go take that for
black as long as the Rooks crash through
the a file white will be winning and
because this has been so much action
we've just forgotten about some of the
other armagedon already one has been
decided as Wesley so takes the win
against Ali Resa f
we've got our eye out on the Hikaru
Magnus match we will go to that but for
now let's stick to this as it's about to
reach its uh final critical moments yeah
H3 is a randomizer it's a desperate
attempt but he's just collapsing now on
the queen side Maxim Vash gr big threat
of Rook to A7 check there so that was
blocked but Black's Knight is not going
to hold this one together for long no
it's not take a pawn G2 leave it there
that's an umbrella Pawn bring that
Bishop back to C5 kick the Knight out of
there it feels like white is just doming
this game he doesn't even go for the
night he just takes pawns why not there
is no attack for black and that Bishop
will come on D4 with the same idea that
you were pointing out but he's picked up
a key Pawn along the way yeah and the
Black Knight desperately trying to
defend squares now still no checks
Black's King is miraculously still
surviving you still need to land the
killer blow but look at the clock as
well we're at move 43 Maxim only has one
minute left you can even play for time
right now okay Queen H7 there is a hint
of counter play coming down to B1 watch
out for the white king but it's just one
check it's just a ghost right now
protect it though cover it and Maxim's
chances of counterplay should slip away
and you don't win the world Blitz
championship by accident Maxim has done
just that and queen H7 is one of those
moves that you scare your opponent but
this isn't Blitz for both sides Maxim is
playing bullet and right now Dennis is
the one with five plus minutes on his
clock so Queen B1 check is it actually a
threat I would just avoid it altogether
but I think it is only a single check
down there and the King can pick up the
G2 Pawn there is no checkmating attack
yeah just when in doubt though protect
guard kill the counterplay wh Rook could
at the very least come back to the first
rank back to A1 just stop and he checks
no checks ever there and uh you can
slowly but surely go about your business
uh Dennis he's doing the right thing
he's so professional at such a young age
slowing down almost 5 minutes still and
uh he just has to battle his own nerves
that's the only thing that can stop him
now and maturity there by danis lazic as
in this critical moment he knows he's
got it in his hand but he has to wrap it
up as quick quickly as he can without
giving any chance to Maxim vashir lrab
for mvl you give him one opportunity and
you know that it will be uh it will be
back to being a level game but it looks
like he's calculated his way through he
grabs a pawn loses two pawns but he
keeps majority of his Advantage but I
think Maxim should be pleased with this
I was surprised by that decision from
Dennis to take a Pawn on G5 it looked
like it was away from the action but now
black doesn't have very much material
remaining it's a rook and a pawn for
just a knight that Knight is stuck
defending the King is wide open uh this
would be a miracle for Max te to survive
oh look at that check black is just
immobilized now black can barely move
White H Pawn could just motor down the
board that's a potential future Queen uh
maybe he's looking for checkmate here
Dennis lazic maybe there's something
more Queen you got ideas like Queen D6
but I think you have to watch out for
threats here because Knight into Bishop
Queen into bishop and then suddenly
Bishop takes Pawn could be a big tactic
so Queen D6 might look like you're
threatening Checkmate but you could just
walk into some danger territory there I
think you just back that Bishop up all
the way towards your king then bring
your Rook next to your king so there's
no attack whatsoever and then that H
Pawn goes up the board so Dennis has
everything under control especially his
time management he started with a huge
Le on the clock that's the nature of
Armageddon but he's been taking it to
Maxim and he's only slowing down when he
knows he needs to be precise so cynical
Robert I can tell you've done this
before that would be the most
professional way of doing it just
killing all risk in the position but uh
still under control Black's King coming
out to C6 surely it's time sooner rather
than later to push that white H Pawn
maybe he wants to repurpose the White
Queen which is a bit offside right now
he's still in
control what to do next where's the
killer blow all right well Dennis lawick
looks like he knows exactly what he's
doing The Rook might jump into A7 the H
Pawn might start advancing we will keep
an eye out on this one but let's uh
check in with the dust settle in that
and Dennis in driver's seat Hikaru
against Magnus and what expression
number was that oh look at the position
Hikaru is losing as we tune in because
of the weak dark squares around his King
you see the board on the bottom right
hand side of your screen a rook trade
just happened and Hikaru his dark
squares he doesn't have a fetto bishop
over there the bishop for white just
going one square forward in the diagonal
I think the black kings is getting
checkmated yeah and uh hearu he did such
a good job on the clock but
unfortunately one slip just as we joined
the game and there we go Robert uh you
mentioned it the white Bishop landing on
E5 and Black's Knight simply stuck it
cannot cover enough squares G7 is a
potential Checkmate Square the corner
Square on h8 all the dark squares
potential uh Landing spots for the White
Queen and it's sneaking in no way to
stop it now how is he going to try and
cling on he drops the Knight all the way
back but there we go the Queen's coming
in oh he's allowing some checks at the
very least white can grab the A7 Pawn
because the bishop on E5 dominates the
Knight there are no moves without giving
a check and if white can force the
queens and the Knight off the board it's
a winning King and pawn end game but be
careful in positions like this because
just trading the Queens if those
disappeared maybe black would have some
chances because white doesn't have the
easiest path towards a pass Pawn still
some work to do he doesn't trade off
immediately and my question was going to
be if he did take Bishop takes Knight
were there some threats of perhaps
Landing into a Perpetual but Magnus
doesn't even want to calculate that that
Bishop on E5 is dominating the pawn on
F3 dominates that Knight on F6 uh and
it's magnus's pieces that are playing
all over he's up a pawn but at some
point you have to start making progress
he sidesteps any checks and now he's
threatening to grab that Knight and
perhaps going into a winning King Pawn
end game definitely he wants to
transition he wants to transform his
Advantage uh make things easier simplify
the equation also that white king can
start walking its way forward now on the
dark squares black is just really stuck
hikaro needs to avoid this trade Bishop
for Knight but if he drops his Knight
back still no threats nothing to do he's
stuck and look at the clock suddenly
under 20 seconds
increment is still a distant dream it
only kicks in at move 60 it's physically
going to be impossible surely 14 seconds
left and here's the big question and you
can see that Magus thinking about can I
take this Knight on F6 and if the queen
takes out can I then put my queen on E5
with check and trade queens now
sometimes you try to liquidate too soon
and it's actually the black king that
will March quickly up the board and
start stealing some of White's pawns so
it's a big moment here for Magnus
Carlson I do not think he should take
the Knight and trade queens that could
easily backfire as black will shut down
the protection of that pawn and go and
Win It moral ethical decision here do
you just try and play quick moves flag
the opponent or do you actually slow
down and try to find objectively the
best moves because uh 12 seconds for
Nakamura physically so tough and queen's
off the board Now Queens up the board
Hikaru needs only a draw somehow but he
needs a big miracle right one to convert
this into a draw but at least he can
feel Sav that he's not getting
checkmated anytime soon but he's going
to lose his Rook Pawn that's on a dart
Square only one side is a darkart sore
bishop and here it goes Magnus breaks
that little Pawn chain there steals The
Rook Pawn so now he'll have a pass Pawn
on opposite sides of the board that's
going to be too much for the black
pieces to deal with and four seconds for
Hikaru he has to make a
move whoa Magnus is playing surprisingly
slowly but
Hikaru look at that speed he's trying to
pre-move but he's running out of time
there's no mouse there's no mouse and
okay hiar resigns handshakes and Magnus
Carson doesn't takes it in the
Armageddon wow some fantastic technique
there by Magnus and big news coming in
Dennis lasic takes his armagon against
Maxim VRA he gets his first win against
the 2021 World Blitz champion on fire
Dennis the Menace we all knew what he
was capable of he himself said this was
going to be his toughest challenge to
date and he's able to beat Maxim in
Armageddon in fact all three players
with the white pieces won their
Armageddon matches and we saw Fabby when
he lost to nbec he immediately got up
left did not put the pieces back Hikaru
with the same reaction definitely upset
the game was leveled for the most part
of it and then Magnus doing Magnus
things strikes and there we see the
world number one after his win walking
off what a day he's had and that was the
end of it as nbec took it against
Fabiano Carana in the two rapid games
the rest of the three went into
Armageddon Wesley soul is lack the man
of the moment with his win against Maxim
bagra and Magnus against Hikaru ends in
magnus's
favor Pras David what stood out to you I
just want to break down the critical
moments of that Mammoth Clash that
monster clash between Magnus Carson and
Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru was on the back
foot slightly just as we joined in but
then one move L it all slip and Magnus
was able to break through the defenses
here white has has a small Advantage
mainly due to the activity of the pieces
the Queen the bishop The Rook but uh
here Hikaru helped white out by
weakening the dark squares further Pawn
to G6 was simply mistaken he should have
just waited a move such as king to H7
maybe Pawn to A5 just maintaining the
tension would have given him great
drawing chances instead G6 allowed a
transformation of the advantage a simple
Rook trade and this move that Robert
mentioned earlier Bishop to E5 the
killer blow because simply the black
king is in too much trouble the Knight
has to move if for example it drops back
this way then a check would have been
deadly on the back rank potential
checkmates in the air if black isn't
careful instead it dropped back to E8
but the White Queen snuck in anyway and
the threat of this Checkmate was deadly
black was forced to push a pawn forward
but after a couple of checks white
simply pocketed this Pawn on A7 and the
dominance of this bishop ensured a
winning end game what a turnaround in
that game because it looked very solid
for black and we understand why he
pushed this Pawn to G6 he realized I
don't really have too many options I
need to defend my Pawn that sticks out
like a sore thumb but unfortunately he
defended a pawn but lost his King yeah
wow that was a amazing play there with
the queen and Bishop combining together
to finish off the game in what would
look like a level a level position but
Magnus doing Magnus things but I'm just
thinking about Dennis laic I mean the
guy is 17 years old he is an underdog in
this tournament the lowest rated player
he's got the X on his back he's the big
Target and he's been showing his spark
here you know he's been holding those
draws finally he gets that win in and
once again maxim of course you've got to
be a fan of Maxim but I feel like we
were all at some point rooting for
Dennis to get that win with the position
he had out of the opening well Dennis
may be a teenager but he's not kidding
around he's here to play and he just
showed a dominant display of Chess from
start to finish that was all Dennis lack
and he's proven over the years he's
capable of winning in big events he's
sted titled Tuesday when he's 15 years
old a feay master like who is this kid
then he goes to the world rapid and
Blitz he becomes a grand Grand Master
his good showings pretty much everywhere
gaining rating you can look online and
see it but Dennis lvic to this point
hadn't won a single match now he gets on
the scoreboard and I think everyone's
looking at like that's no longer a free
point we got to be careful about Dennis
yeah and this should be inspirational
for everyone at home just when you play
these higher rated players first you
need to learn how to draw against them
how to survive Dennis has done that day
one we saw a couple of draws then you
need to start taking your chances start
learning how to attack them kind of
being brave against these high rated
opponents and we see denn growing
learning in front of our R and everyone
at home should be doing the same you
will take hits you will take defeats but
as long as you improve and keep the
confidence which he has done you will
get your results in the end and he did
get his result in the end what a day of
Chess it has been we had Mind Games we
had dramatic Armageddon we had some
brilliancies we had turnarounds we had
all of it and it was so much fun calling
uh the moves and the action here from
Oslo but the action continues in Toronto
while we're signing off we're sending
you over to the playing arena with
Donnie and James guys what a day of
Chess take it
away what a day of Chess unbelievable
chess I honestly don't even know where
to begin wow I think we have to go back
to the Marquee matchup obviously Magnus
Carlson gets the job done in Armageddon
fashion what an incredible game a
grinded out Magnus fashion I mean it's
incredible how he does every in game
everything goes to an ingame no really
crushing ATT attacks here doesn't care
about the opening Advantage doesn't care
about what opening you play we get to an
ing game I do my thing he does it every
single time it's funny cuz in the
critical moment Magnus didn't have an
advantage and the clocks were almost
even up until that fateful G6 by hikaro
so your heart goes out to hikaro there
losing that Armageddon but he did get
one win today let's remind everybody
real quick what the standings are after
the play is done here the uh four rounds
are in the books where does it put
everybody after that we also had another
Armageddon victory of course I think
Dennis lvic getting his big win is uh is
huge for the standings as we bring them
up if people thought it was a sure thing
that the youngster would go home I guess
think again KY think again like H said
Robert was like yeah free point walking
free point try again in fact I'm walking
around with my chest out not cuz I lift
weights it's because my name is Dennis
lavic and I got my first dub today I'm
feeling great the other person who not
only got his first dub today but got two
dubs today Notre Beck ABD her off up
there in third place now what what a
tale of two days Fabian Carana wins two
matches in Armageddon fashion today he
loses both matches I guess I jinxed him
I picked Fabby to win both of his
matches that didn't go very well dang
Danny you always doing that I'm the
commentator's curse is real but nottock
Abus aov's chess is real and he caught
up with K just moments ago after his
huge day
two I'm here with the man of the moment
beating Fabiano car congratulations yeah
thank you you were high on energy after
that first game how are you feeling
right now after winning the match yeah I
um I'm relieved so you know it's been a
very good match and uh yeah I I
really um I really played well I think
in second game without a mistake so yeah
um looking good for me what was your
plan heading into this match with
Fabiano who's just been so good lately
yeah um but today I think he you know he
was maybe a little bit um in not shape
but uh um I think it's partly okay
because also he played Magnus and um and
after losing to to him it's maybe he he
was a little bit frustrated so
yeah I am I'm I think after beating laic
I was I was very confident and you know
I was I was really uh really in in good
shape and uh with three rounds to go how
do you see your chances now to go
through from the round
robin um it's still looking very tough
right now because there are a lot of
players who on two points so yeah we'll
do my best and just just looking forward
to to to to get to play some interesting
games and you mentioned that confidence
you got from winning against lazovic
heading into this match with Fabiano for
us who don't play Chess at the level
that you do how important is momentum
confidence when you do play these big
guys like Fabiano yeah it's really
important because you know then
everything goes well for
you um and uh yeah it's but it's also
very very hard to to to keep that
momentum you know it's not um not every
day you you you can B it uh Fabiano so
yeah it's really really really tough so
uh the other matches will be going to
Armageddon you are done for the day what
will you do now the rest of the night to
celebrate this great day so who's going
to be who's going to play Aragon the
other three matches are all going to our
get on yeah oh okay then it's really
interesting to watch yeah you'll be
enjoying that yeah of course all right
well congratulations on a great day
Norbeck thank you thank you for joining
us wow the man of the moment you guys
Norbeck of the Soro back to you
thank you bro was so focused on his own
dominance he didn't even know the other
three matches were going to Armageddon
got to love it there you see he took
down Fabiano Carana despite big age Gap
there you look at the accuracy just
fantastic chest day I mean really good
in fact uh Robert said it in a way this
is Kryptonite we've seen norback do this
before in different matches OTB as well
so you know nck is just feeling good
after that he's feeling good you're
right for some reason maybe he likes his
match up against maybe he also didn't
like our prediction to take fa and he
used it as fuel who knows whatever it is
Notre Beck Abdus turov is right there in
the thick of things behind the only two
guys who remain 4-0 of course we already
talked about Carlson got it done in
Armageddon fashion against Nakamura but
Wesley so also still 4-0 still four I
mean Wesley so is absolute Beast right
now he's walking around he's feeling
good I'm like yeah I'll do the interview
yeah I'll talking doing puzzles he's
having a time of his life it's like you
know uh Wesley Toronto because Toronto
is his place right now Wesley so loves
Toronto he is 4 and0 I can't think of
any more ways to rhyme with that so
instead we're going to throw to Kaa who
caught up with Wesley after his second
perfect
day it's a perfect start for Wesley so
another match win how are you feeling
Wesley yeah very happy uh like to
glorify Lord Jesus for all those wins
my goal before the start of the
tourament was like to finish in the top
six like at least not to go home so
early so it's looking good yeah it's
looking good so far uh things are going
well so far couldn't have asked for a
better start crazy and how are you
feeling about your playing Armageddon as
well here pretty good pretty good yeah I
think against Maxim I played really well
and against Alesa I did I wasn't
familiar at all with the opening like he
had a very comfortable position but uh
he has it he has his ated I believe with
A6 when he could have played B5 maybe
like he hesitated a little bit and then
next thing I knew I had a very good
position like I knew I had to play G4 if
I don't play G4 I'm just going to lose
and he he used so much time like I
didn't even have to win the
position you're walking around here in
the player Lounge Wesley with just a big
smile on your face you seem relaxed how
important is that and how big of a
factor is that in your perfect score
here here so far yeah well I won all my
games yeah which so does does the
results come first or does the you know
the great mood come first well they go
both hand in hand yeah like uh becoming
determin I was just putting no pressure
in myself if I win I win if I if I lose
then just you know go home and then
prepare for the next one so it's my it's
my mindset like I love the game I know
this tman has a huge humongous price
money but I'm not really playing for
money you know I'm just trying to enjoy
have a good career and uh live life and
uh tomorrow on day three in the finals
you will face Magnus Carlson among
others thank for letting me know I I I
didn't know who my pairing was like I
was taking it one round at a time so
thanks for letting me know do you would
prefer not knowing until like the same
day uh well for for Speed tournaments
preparation is not that important so
like I tend to check the pairings in the
morning well what can we expect when you
do play Marcus Carlson tomorrow both of
you looking extremely good here ah what
can I expect well it's it's up to
him
uh yeah it's up to him which Magnus
shows up I
hope I hope the best Magnus doesn't show
up but if it does it will be an uphill
battle obviously but the best Wesley so
will turn up like I remember he beat me
so convincingly in San Francisco last
year and he just won the tournament like
he had six match wins out of seven
something crazy like that so when he's
in good form he's uh just crazy crazy
strong uh so um yeah we see he's an
amazing incredible player what what can
I do yeah so are you Wesley so
congratulations on a great day yes thank
you yes good luck tomorrow as well
Wesley saw you guys per perfect start to
the tour
finals well we saw Wesley so say that he
hopes the best Magnus Carlson doesn't
show up tomorrow because the result is
in magnus's hands and there you know
what the round five pairings are Wesley
so will be taking on Magnus Carlson
first thing in the morning and that is
the matchup of two players who've been
perfect so far of course we have a ton
of other matchups to talk about laic
Carana and the many others but right now
we have Magnus at the desk so I'm just
going to jump right in Magnus Wesley
said that the result tomorrow depends on
which Magnus Carlson shows up if the
best Magnus shows up he says you win but
what do you think about that um well I
usually I usually do but uh um I I don't
know he's generally playing quite quite
well here but um no generally I agree
like if I play at my best I I usually
usually do pretty well so I I I hope for
this you go do agree with him what what
do you think talk a little more about
Wesley's play here he seems to like
Toronto he's obviously had a couple of
Armageddon matches to get there but your
thoughts just on on how difficult he'll
be to beat
tomorrow um he hasn't been like
extremely solid recently in in Rapid but
um I don't think he's played like too
differently from from what he has
recently here um I mean he's a very very
strong player but u i I wouldn't say
he's done anything too too special uh
but obviously his score is his score is
great and if he plays the way that he
used to play back in 2020 2021 online
then he he's very tough to to beat for
sure yeah physical fitness is of course
very important this is something you do
and follow as well are you doing any
type of exercise while you here in
Toronto not so far not so far we got to
take you to the gy probably probably
should but I mean at least I had a
couple of weeks of relaxation before I
got here so I still I don't feel
particularly energetic but I feel fairly
calm and I think that's that's uh helped
me in some critical moments very nice
shifting away from so to the match you
just had with Hikaru obviously that was
huge for all the fans you did get it
done in Armageddon but take us into the
final moments of that game you were
getting under time pressure you guys
were about dead even on the clock even
with him having drawing chances right
before hikaro play G6 so were you
nervous at that moment what were your
what were your feelings at that point in
the game I wouldn't say I was nervous uh
but I wasn't 100% confident either um at
that point um well I did have some
structural Edge and I do know that he's
very strong when he gets his nights
going but it felt to me that um it was
not so easy and that he would have to
jettison the pawn to get any sort of
activity and clearly he just blundered
there um Y which was good for me but to
be honest like he had been under a
pressure for a long time there so I'm
I'm not shocked that he that he he
blundered you beat Notre Beck with white
in Armageddon and you wanted that you
wanted that color and then you bid 15
minutes against Taro I know you already
gave some thoughts on it with Ka but
take us back into that what is the is it
really based on the opponent cuz we're
all talking about the meta it's
fascinating to understand that sometimes
you want black sometimes you want white
is it based on the style the opponent
take us in into that a little bit Yeah I
think you should have sort of a balanced
strategy while bidding for Armageddon
but uh that was like one of the extremes
of of course um I thought also I thought
psychologically it would
be um it would be fun like if he if he's
thought longing hard about his did and
he thinks he got it just on the second
and I just did
um and I was yeah I was happy to play
play White um I mean considering the the
fact that he bid that his bid was so
high yeah uh I probably gave away a
little bit of equity there uh but still
I didn't feel uh didn't feel too bad
going into uh going into the armagon cuz
even though I hadn't defeated him in
Armageddon as white before and I also
think like he hadn't defeated me either
so I think black has won every time I've
won loads of games against him on demand
that's as white so I I knew that I could
do that so I was just trying to play as
normally as um as possible and uh you
know with his Mimi opening then right
it's not bad but it just means that we
get a game right nice uh with strategy
you mentioned staying calm so is there
any strategy or Preparation that keeps
you of course in these high level
matches every day of course they're
coming at you they're trying to beat you
strategy and preparation on staying
calm um no I haven't done anything not
nothing too much I just I feel feel
relatively calm man that's nice your
your mindset is strong so you play
Wesley so tomorrow uh you played lavic I
think after no you've already played
loic I've already played lasic so I've
got the I got Wesley and the Frenchman
Wesley and the Frenchman your thoughts
on you're just focused on Wesley for now
or do you do prep for both players the
night before I'm really not focused on
anybody right now I'm happy with the
score the way it is and then I'll start
thinking about the the matches um
tomorrow yeah well appreciate you
joining us and uh congrats again on a I
don't think we're quite done okay what
do you got cuz uh you know one of the
reasons why I get here early sometimes
is that I really like oh you like
hearing the pred I like hearing the
predictions and you guys had some
interesting ones
today so so appreciate that I did take
Fabby against you but I took you against
and you've met against me twice right
yeah it's just it's content you know
it's
content but I mean you also have to like
understand you know what I mean it's
definitely hard to to pick you every
time I don't I don't take offense but I
notice it that's what I'm saying okay
well you know we might as well dive into
that I'm glad you brought it up because
we've already chatted about it obviously
there was the interaction with Aldi Resa
he didn't didn't like the prediction I
think that I think most the players are
okay with it I think we will continue to
do it but maybe try to get it done
earlier so it doesn't feel like it's
right before the game what do you think
I if it's up to me do it as the players
are hearing I think that's like that
okay well maybe that's a good lesson in
the the the mental and remember like
every time you bet against me I get like
a couple percent better well maybe that
was secretly why we doing but anyway no
I appreciate that it is it's interesting
because this is different than other
sports football players don't hear the
pundit saying things right before the
game right so you have this mental
toughness do you think that what would
be your message on that because you want
us to keep doing the predictions you
like it obviously one player didn't like
it today what what are your thoughts on
on the difference in your mindset there
I think it's very easy like if it's if
it's going well then yeah then you just
enjoy it if you're if it's not going so
so well then I can see why it would be
annoying right 100% definitely well
appreciate appreciate that I'll think
long and hard about whether I'm going to
predict you or tomorrow I'm going to try
to take three steps ahead in the meta
whether I'm picking Magnus or Wesley
tomorrow Magus Magnus Magnus Magnus
Magnus well thanks man thank you
appreciate your time bud and we'll we'll
let you balance that's Magnus Carlson
loving the candid thoughts there this
has been quite the day from Toronto can
we just say that 100% ups and downs all
day everywhere we've had we've had
amazing fashion by Gucci Resa Olie Olie
didn't take too kindly do some
predictions we had some real time
discussion about the content with Magnus
himself the goat the goat bringing his
thoughts about it and obviously you got
a huge match up tomorrow between wesle
so and Magnus Carlson that's going to be
amazing can't wait for it two players
undefeated we will be back tomorrow for
everyone thank you to the crew in Oslo
the crew here in Toronto will'll see you
for the championship the Champions chess
tour in Toronto
tomorrow the queen goes all the way back
to the corner London from fuja this will
end in Checkmate hiar Nakamura relieved
after his first win can go Queen B
instead that is stunning Magnus Carson
he plays he
wins oh my goodness oh that would have
blundered and lost blocking black coun
play Black is stranded black is helpless
what a move Magnus Carson does it takes
it in the
Armageddon I feel
[Applause]
[Music]
conf
sh
[Music]
[Laughter]